Ihr hört CRE Technik, Kultur, Gesellschaft, mein Name ist Tim und nach einer,
längeren Pause setze ich hier mal das Programm fort, weil es einen Anlass,
gibt. Ähm ist es ein Film veröffentlicht worden unter dem Namen Sibilian Dollar Code und,
Ja, da steckt eine Geschichte dahinter und die möchten wir heute mal erzählen. Und es ist für mich ein bisschen schwierig,
weil ich selber so ein bisschen na ja Teil der Geschichte ist vielleicht nicht so äh die richtige Bezeichnung, aber war auf jeden Fall so Active-Bystand.
Doch, ich würde schon sagen, Teil der Geschichte auch, ja.
Würdest du sagen, na gut, da werden wir vielleicht noch drauf kommen. Äh betrifft mich auf jeden Fall auch äh persönlich, denn dieser Film, der bei Netflix rausgekommen ist, erzählt eine Story, einer Softwareentwicklung.
Eines Programms mit dem Namen Terrorvision, was von einer,
Firma oder damals war's ja eigentlich eher ein Verein äh entwickelt wurde namens A plus com, wo ich äh,
viele äh andere Freunde von mir äh ein paar Jahre lang gearbeitet habe. Ja und äh ich kam auch genau zu dem Zeitpunkt dazu.
Als diese Software mehr oder weniger fertig war oder zumindest das erste Mal halbwegs fertiggestellt gewesen äh ist. Ja und da spreche ich heute mit Pavel rüber. Pavel Meyer, hallo Pavel.
Denn äh ja, wir haben ja hier schon ganz oft miteinander gesprochen bei CRE, über die unterschiedlichsten Themen.
Ähm und in gewisser Hinsicht bist du auch so ein bisschen schuld da dran, dass CAE so geworden ist, wie es letztlich ähm bekannt ist, denn ganz am Anfang war es ja für mich.
So ein experimenteller Kanal. Wir haben dann in der dritten Sendung mal die Testsendung aufgenommen. Und die hat so nur so ein bisschen so angedeutet, was hier eigentlich am besten funktioniert.
Dass ich dann diese Experimente der ersten 1, 20 Sendungen dann irgendwann mal weggepackt habe.
Und ähm ja, so ist es dann ein Format,
worden, wo man einfach mal länger über Sachen spricht,
Ja, wie steigen wir da ein? Also erstmal äh,
wenn ihr diesen Film noch nicht gesehen habt, dann macht ihr's vielleicht nochmal Pause, weil das wird hier eine Spoilerparade. Auf jeden Fall, denn wir wollen einerseits ein bisschen über das Projekt reden und mal erstmal die Geschichte erzählen, wie sie eigentlich wirklich passiert ist.
Und dann so gegen Ende auch in zunehmenden Maße auf diesen Film eingehen, um mal zu schauen, wo eigentlich die Unterschiede liegt und wo der Film,
die Wahrheit oder die echte dahinterliegende Geschichte gut getroffen hat und wo sie auch deutlich davon abweicht, denn es ist eine Dramatisierung, es ist kein Dokumentarfilm.
Ein bisschen so ähnlich wie auch dreiundzwanzig, nichts ist so wie es scheint, auch so eine Dramatisierung einer einer wahren Geschichte war, da ist viel dokumentatorisches drin, aber am Ende, wenn man genau hinschaut, wie das immer so ist
passt es dann natürlich nicht ganz zusammen, aber diesen Anspruch hat dieser Film auch gar nicht. Es ist eine vierteilige, sogenannte Miniserie, also viermal eine Stunde ungefähr
und dann hat man die ganze Story drin.
Außerdem gibt's noch so ein Making-of, wo du noch ein paar andere Protagonisten der äh Geschichte auch noch direkt zur Sprache kommen, wo man ähm ja vielleicht noch ein bisschen besser versteht, was äh der Hintergrund war. Aber wir wollen's heute mal ein bisschen genauer.
Analysieren.
Pavel, da müssen wir ja eigentlich nochmal mit dir einsteigen, auch wenn wir schon so oft miteinander gequatscht haben, aber ich denke, das ist auch so eine so ein Hintergrund, den wir hier so noch nie wirklich mal betrachtet haben.
Wie du nämlich selber eigentlich so ähm zu den Computern gekommen bist. Das hat bei dir doch eigentlich relativ früh angefangen, oder?
Ja, ja, ja. Also im Grunde genommen hat es angefangen, so, da war ich zehn Jahre alt und habe dann endlich einen Elektronik Experimentierbaukasten
bekommen,
damals blauer Koffer mit irgendwie Transistoren und Widerständen und Kondensatoren und da kommt man halt alle möglichen.
Dinge mit äh mit Bauen so, also ja elektronische Schaltkreise und ähm,
Ja, äh zum Computer äh gekommen. Da gab's auch so ein Erlebnis, das weiß ich noch so, das ist an einem Tag äh passiert,
bin halt gerne nach der Schule immer, wenn man das früher macht, hat so dann im Kaufhaus umher gestreift,
dann in der, wenn ich Spielwarenabteilung und Elektronikabteilung hat man sich all die tollen Dinge angeguckt, die man sich alle nicht leisten konnte und da stand halt
dann irgendwann einen Homecomputer im Kaufhof, weiß noch, waren TI neu, Textesinstruments TI neunundneunzig vier, glaube ich.
Vier A.
Oder so. Ja.
Wir reden jetzt von Anfang der so dreiundachtzig.
Das muss nee, das muss so Ende der Siebziger gewesen.
Ach so, es gab auch einen TI neunundneunzig vier und dann gab's noch ein vier A, so. Okay, der ist.
Wann kam der raus?
In Deutschland 80. Der vier.
Sich. Okay, ja, dann.
Vier A.
Ja. Er muss das so achtzig also ich erinnere mich so sehr, ich war dann vierzehn oder fünfzehn ähm äh jedenfalls äh,
war ich zu dem Zeitpunkt äh hatte ich mich dann schon ein bisschen mehr in äh auch
Digitaltechnik reingearbeitet so kleine Digitalschaltkreise gemacht was man damals so gebaut hat, irgendwelche elektronischen Würfel mit sieben Segment LCD Display wo man dann
irgendwie die dann eine Zahl von 0 bis 6 ähnull bis fünf oder eins bis sechs ausgeworfen haben und und so ein Krempel halt und.
Dann sah ich halt diesen Computer und dann weiß ich, da hat dann jemand,
Äh ein kurzes Basic-Programm geschrieben, wo man ein Datum eingeben konnte und das wird einem dann den Wochentag ausgespuckt für das Datum. Und ich,
dachte in dem Moment so, oh mein Gott, wie viele äh TTL-ICs müsste ich da aneinander löten
um äh irgendwie sowas in Hardware zu machen und der Typ macht das da jetzt irgendwie in fünf Minuten oder so und ich hatte keine Ahnung,
wie das jetzt ging. So und das hat mich halt massiv gestört. Ich bin dann direkt von dem Kaufhaus in die Stadtbücherei gegangen.
Auf diesen Texas Instrument. Mhm. Genau. Also ein Bas.
In Texas Instrumentsding, genau. War am ja, wer noch war, war schon bunt auf dem Fernseher und so. Ja und dann bin ich halt.
Äh äh von da in die Stadt Bibliothek marschiert und habe mir dann irgendwie,
fünf oder zehn Bücher zum Thema Computer einfach er wusste ja nicht was so wilde wilde Dinge da war dann unter anderem war da eben auch ein Basic
Buch dabei, was sich am nützlichsten erwies, weil das auch so programmiertes Ding war, wo man dann so Stück für Stück,
durchgehen konnte und das war halt ziemlich gut. Da kommt man dann wunderschön, da konnte man an einem Tag Basic, wenn man sich das, wenn man das durchgearbeitet hat, das war super
und der äh Rest waren dann so teilweise auch Bücher über Simular und PL eins und äh äh so weiter, also auch teilweise nicht krasser. Es darf ja jedenfalls,
Was ich dann auch noch gemacht habe war, äh es ist gab dann an der Volkshochschule, so Mikroprozessortechnik, Kurse,
und Elektronikkurse.
Die ich dann belegt habe, das heißt, das war dann sozusagen neben der Schule, ich weiß nicht, ich hatte dann manche Tage hatte ich dann so sechs, acht Stunden Schulunterricht und abends nochmal vier Stunden ähm,
ja, an der Volkshochschule, aber das war halt, war halt super, äh, nett.
In welcher Stadt? Lüdenscheid. Hm.
So, das war in Lüdenscheid. Genau. Und dann hat mich äh irgendwann äh der äh nicht nur mich, sondern auch äh noch einen einen Freund, äh der dabei war, Hendrik, der jetzt,
ist, der dann auch bei Artcom äh war, später. Äh ja, wir haben jedenfalls äh äh wurden dann beide angeheuert von,
dem Dozenten, der einen Ingenieurbüro hatte und äh uns dann quasi als Jugendliche beschäftigt hat.
Das ist ja so eine Story, die man tausend Mal gehört hat. Bei mir war's ja auch nicht anders, ne? Man muss sich einfach vorstellen, Homecomputer waren damals in Kaufhäusern,
Und sonst gab's Computer eigentlich nirgendswo niemand hatte welche. Das ist echt mal so eine Zeit, in die man sich reinfühlen muss,
waren einfach nicht da in der Gesellschaft. Es gab,
das Wissen, dass es sowas gab, wie Computer, aber die Vorstellung davon war halt immer riesige Räume mit Schränken, in großen Konzernen oder vielleicht auch Universitäten und war ja auch vor allem in den siebziger Jahren so, ne.
Und an Universitäten war das auch noch genauso an den Universitäten gab's keine.
Ja äh da gab's dann, wenn's dann Informatik gab, gab's dann so IBM drei sechzig Großrechner, das habe ich dann also Jahre später noch äh äh erlebt dann in in Braunschweig, im Studium,
ähm ja. Jedenfalls ja wurde ich äh dann äh wurden wir dann dort angeheuert. Erstmal so für ich sage mal Lüt und Testarbeiten,
und dann aber auch zunehmend äh so für Softwareentwicklung. Da habe ich.
Ne, dort für dieses Ingenieurbüro begonnen, auch eine Leiterplattendesign-Software. Zu schreiben, ähm weil.
Auch zum damaligen Zeitpunkt war die Software um Leiterplatten zu machen war halt nicht so wirklich
geeignet äh um ja, also die war nicht toll
sagen wir mal so für für viele Anwendungszwecke und dann habe ich erst für einen Apple zwo und dann für Mackintosch äh habe ich dann auch noch einen Schaltplan und äh äh Designprogramm und ein Leiterplatten Design Programm so in einem geschrieben.
Also auch schon richtig visuell.
Visuell, ja, ja, mit Maus und irgendwie mit Bussen und Dragging und mit äh IC Librie und und und allem und so mit irgendwie Plausibilitätscheck. Ich hatte nur keinen Auto-Router
drin, aber äh ja, man musste dann halt die Leitungen dann doch per Hand äh ruhten, aber
Ja, da gab's eben auch viele Hilfen und Kontrollen und dann einen Plotter Treiber, der dann noch mitm Stift irgendwie die Masken äh ausgeplattet hat. Und so, ja war ziemlich abgefahren dann
Habe ich aber auch noch bei der Hardwareentwicklung ausgeholfen, weil ich mich halt in Elektronik auch gut
auskante so und habe dann teilweise die neue Hardware äh mitentwickelt, so das waren also Betriebsdatenerfassungssysteme, die dann
ja in allen möglichen Firmen in Deutschland die Ployd waren so für Zeiterfassung, für.
Eigentlich die erste große, wirkliche Anwendung von Computern in den Firmen damals, ne? Kassensysteme, all sowas.
BDE Betriebsdatenerfassung so an Maschinensteuerungen hing das mit dran und hat dann, was weiß ich, Teile gezählt oder für Warsteiner, äh deren äh äh Tankanlage, so habe ich äh die, die,
die Software geschrieben, wenn die halt ihre LKW betankt haben und somit Kartenleser und Zapfsäule freischalten und so einen Kram. Aber nicht nur, wenn ich halt dann die Anwendung dafür geschrieben hatte, sondern ich hatte,
die Schaltplan äh äh Design Software geschrieben, die Leiterplatten designen äh Software hatte äh ja, an der Hardware mitentwickelt, habe
Betriebssystem dafür geschrieben und die Anwendung. So, das war halt,
total geil, weil ich quasi den gesamten Steck äh so von unten bis hin sozusagen zur Produktionstools äh war ich irgendwie dran beteiligt und es war nett. Ich meine, so konnte ich, hatte ich dann auch ein Betriebssystem
und dann portiert wobei ich nur den den nicht hatte und halt dann den Samler Code gepatcht habe um den den zu portieren also solche Sachen
ich dann da gemacht, aber insbesondere gehörte ich dann.
Äh zu der äh relativ kleinen Zahl von Macintosh Programmierern in Deutschland, weil das war am Anfang war das halt sehr mühsam
noch auf dem Mac äh zu programmieren. Man braucht ja eine Lisa am Anfang, um überhaupt auch für einen Mac Software zu schreiben. Dann gab's so die ersten Möglichkeiten. Jedenfalls hat das dann doch stark die Zahl der Softwareentwickler gerade in Deutschland, die für ein Mac was
machen konnten, hielt sich in Grenzen so, man kannte sich, waren vielleicht fünfzig,
hundert Leute äh in Deutschland, die so ja,
reden jetzt von Ende der Achtziger ähm,
Anfang der Neunziger äh wirklich offen Macinto stammer, es war Macintosch zwei war so äh äh glaube ich das Gerät äh.
Der der Zeit beziehungsweise die Nachfolger und,
Ja, man hatte schon die ersten Festplatten und so am am Mac äh,
Alles noch sehr langsam, sehr gemächlich äh gegen das weiß ich noch. Wir haben die ersten Entwicklungssysteme und das war dann auch äh der Grund, wie ich dann zur Art komme gekommen bin.
Lass uns noch mal kurz in dieser Zeit äh bleiben, weil also so ein Projekt, wie du das jetzt gerade beschrieben hast, wird dich von der Hardware bis zum Betriebssystem bisschen in Anwendungen zu machen. Ähm so umfangreich habe ich nie gearbeitet, aber wann auch immer man.
So ein Bereich mit mit der eigenen äh Software durchdrungen hat und zu einer Lösung beigetragen hat, das hat einem ja ein Wissen gegeben jenseits dieser Anwendung von.
Was macht der Computer eigentlich,
wie funktioniert der eigentlich genau? Wie funktioniert er auch tatsächlich in der Elektronik genau, aber vor allem, was macht ein Prozessor, was machen Co-Prozessoren, Grafiksysteme,
IO, also das Wissen da drum und das ist ja eigentlich sagen wir mal ein bisschen auch der Segen der Achtziger gewesen, dass.
Dass man genug Zeit investiert und und das interessant genug findet und dann auch,
dranbleibt und sich nicht sofort abschrecken lässt von den zahlreichen äh Fehlermeldungen und und Unmöglichkeiten, die äh auf die man ja auch sofort gestoßen ist. Wenn man das so durchgebracht hat, dann.
Mir ging das so, hat das so eine hm willst jetzt nicht zu sehr überhöhen so, ja, äh aber man
wirbt sich relativ schnell dann so ein holistisches Wissen, sodass man die ganzen Abhängigkeiten und vor allem auch die Grenzen des Ganzen sehr gut verstehen kann, bis hin zu wenn man sich dann,
andere Systeme anschaut, Programme bedient, die man jetzt selber nicht gemacht hat, dass man irgendwie, also ich habe immer so das Gefühl gehabt,
Ich weiß, was für eine,
Mensch so ein System programmiert hat, wie die so drauf sind, was was wo die gesellschaftlich so unterwegs sind, ganz Merkwürdiges äh Gefühl. Heute ist es kaum noch machbar, weil eben Dinge nicht so von einzelnen Leuten gemacht werden mehr.
Ja, also man, man konnte zumindest damals die Systeme der damaligen Zeit noch ziemlich komplett durchschauen und verstehen, so bis.
Auf Transistor-Ebene äh äh runter, äh so ähm man hat sehr viel eben noch oder sogar Maschinensprache gemacht. Also ich habe,
teilweise sogar noch von von Hand im Kopf äh assimbiert, weil ich keinen Sampler hatte, so mit Buch und ob kurz äh und so.
Wir wir haben alle noch so zehn, zwanzig Obcodes im Kopf, die man irgendwie nie vergisst, was für ein Wert das ist, den man da in den Speicher schreiben muss.
Ja, ja. Ähm ja und äh aber äh ihr Recht man hatte dann,
Ganz gute Vorstellung und das war später auch so immer wichtig, weil es gibt
heute auch in der Informatik oder es gibt halt sehr viele Schichtenmodelle bei der Kommunikation des OSI Schichtenmodell oder im Betriebssystem halt, hast du die verschiedenen.
Abstraktionsschichten und was man dann aber feststellt, wenn man dann auf allen Schichten unterwegs sind
dass äh diese Schichten nicht wirklich voll voneinander isolieren oder unabhängig
sind, sondern dass die halt sich durchdringen und das was man halt auf einer Schicht
macht äh oder was was dort passiert oder wie die aufgebaut äh sind, hat halt
ja Effekte nach oben und nach unten und man kann das nicht immer so genau trennen und wenn man halt effiziente Programme haben möchte, dann
weiß man idealerweise wie die Schichten darunter genau operieren, was teuer ist in den Schichten, darunter, was
billig äh ist und dann geht es nicht.
Sehr darum klar Algorithmen sind auch immer wichtig aber oft ist es dann die untere Schichten auf 'ne Art und Weise anzusprechen die ihnen entgegenkommt was halt natürlich jetzt zu einer Isolation von Schichten entgegen
spricht oder äh ja, aber in in Wirklichkeit musste man das halt immer
komplett mitdenken. Sieht man ja auch an moderner Netzwerktechnologie eigentlich erst in der Netzwerktechnologie so, ich sag mal physische und Media Excess und Transport äh äh Layer und so
ja, hast du diese ganzen Layer ja eigentlich
getrennt, aber wenn du dir moderne Switches anguckst, siehst du, dass die in allen Leeren irgendwie rumfummeln, um ihren Job
äh besser machen zu können. Das heißt, dass die teilweise in den Application Layer reingucken und dann auf im im Network äh äh leer irgendwie Dinge
Dinge machen.
Mit teuer und billig, meinst du teuer ist etwas, wenn es dann auf einmal lange dauert äh oder viel Ressourcen braucht, äh die Büchse warm wird.
Genau, wenn es dann viel Speicher oder Rechenleistung äh benötigt oder teure spezial Hardware, dann ist es halt sozusagen teuer und.
Ähm ja und und heutige Rechner, wenn man sich das anguckt, sind teilweise oder heutige Anwendungen sind sowas von unglaublich ineffizient ähm.
Aufgrund dieser verschiedenen Schichten, aber das ist halt auch da äh Computer.
Billig so Hardware Ressourcen sind billig Programmierer, sind teuer, deswegen hat man halt dann so in den letzten Jahren äh schmeißt man lieber gerne irgendwie mehr Rechenleistung auf Probleme als sie jetzt mit Brain Power
so zu lösen, dass sie halt auch performen.
Ja, das sieht man äh dadran, dass Computer heutzutage oft bei Anwendungen einfach.
Dauert gefühlt immer gleich lange mit diesen Computern zu arbeiten. Und das war auch schon,
früher so, nur damals waren halt auch die Computer tausendmal langsamer und obwohl sie tausendmal schneller geworden ist, sind die ist die Bedienung der Systeme nicht tausendmal schneller geworden und auch nicht hundert und manchmal auch nicht zehnmal so schnell, einfach weil man mit so viel.
Ja
arbeitet und natürlich auch zwangsläufig gar keinen Vorwurf, aber wer heute neu einsteigt und dieses ganze Tiefenwissen zwangsläufig so nicht hat, weil es einfach zu viel geworden ist
im zwangsläufig
teuer. Ja, äh weil man es gar nicht besser weiß oder es eben sehr viel Recherche und ausprobieren und nachlesen, benötigt, um das eben zu wissen, um eben effizient,
arbeiten. Und das hat auch dann immer so ein bisschen eingeschränkt.
Ähm wo wirklich die nächsten großen Schritte,
gegangen werden konnten, weil's eigentlich immer nur den Leuten erstmal gelungen ist, die all das von vornherein umschiffen konnten, um dann auch wirklich das rauszuholen aus den Maschinen, was was theoretisch möglich war.
Ja, aber da dafür, also es ist jetzt nicht alles verschwendet. Natürlich, ich meine, man hat unglaublich viel mehr Features und Möglichkeiten und so, aber noch mal, um zurückzugehen, ähm mal klarzumachen, äh.
Videos abspielen auf dem Computer.
Wie lange das gedauert hat, also im Prinzip in den Neunzigern
gab's jetzt keinen normalen PC, auf dem man irgendwie in Parkqualität Videos abspielen konnte, ohne spezielle Zusatzhardware oder Zusatzkarten. Also das das war einfach nicht,
also irgendwie Videostreaming oder so ja.
Hat lange gedauert, ist aber auch ein komplexes Feld, ne, was ich äh lange entwickelt habe. Okay, jetzt warst du noch in Lüdenscheid. Da bist du dann geblieben bis.
Na ja, es war so, ich ich habe dann äh habe ich äh zwei Jahre lang in Braunschweig studiert äh so.
Was? Informatik. Mhm.
Das dann aber irgendwann so furchtbar
ich hätte an so was von kein Bock mehr und ich hatte eben zu dem Zeitpunkt auch hatte ich halt schon sag mal professionell für mehrere Jahre Software entwickelt also bezahlt wird ist es professionell würde ich mal,
sagen
und ja, das heißt, es fiel mir sehr schwer. Und was ich auch nicht wusste, war bis äh sagen Braunschweig dann als irgendwann später das Spiegelranking rauskam von 50 Hochschulen, wie auf dem fünfzigsten Platz gelandet ist bei der Informatik,
so, es bestätigte dann, dass es jetzt nicht nur alleine, äh ich sage mal an, an mir lag oder an meinem Unwillen äh dann irgendwie früh morgens da zur Vorlesung aufzutauchen, wo dann teilweise die Professoren nicht auftauchten oder ich,
das zum fünften Mal in meinem Leben ähm irgendwie mir jemand versucht äh äh KV Diagramme äh beizubringen. Ich hatte.
Logik Diagramme und das hatte ich.
Halt in der Schule schon im äh Mathematikunterricht und in der Schule im Informatikunterricht und dann gab's das in der Mathevorlesung und in der Programmierenvorlesung und in der,
Technik Vorlesung, sodass ich irgendwann
irgendwie Leute, also irgendwie könnt ihr euch nicht irgendwie mal ein bisschen wenigstens absprechen, weil jeder hat halt so seine also Professoren haben halt untereinander gar nicht geredet, wer was irgendwie macht in seiner,
lesung. Und das war aber gesagt, äh waren aber andere Dinge jedenfalls ähm habe ich dann, wäre ich dann fast CT-Fachredakteur
geworden noch, weil ich hatte mich dann ja, weil ich hatte dann irgendwann in der CT äh eine Anzeige, diesen Ausbildung zum Fachredakteur, so mit Praktikum beim Spiegel und weil ich auch immer gerne geschrieben hatte und irgendwie.
Ja, mit Prack, also genau, wenn du sagen äh, die Ausbildung zum Fachredakteur so beim Heiseverlag, äh so für die, für die CT umfasste dann auch sechs Monate Praktikum beim Spiegel.
Mhm. Und es hätte irgendwie damals auch also sechzehnhundert.
D-Mark gegeben im Monat dafür während der Ausbildung, also eigentlich äh.
Relativ gute Bezahlung ist für eine Ausbildung, ja.
War achthundert
D-Mark äh damals äh und äh zusammen mit den Nebenverdiensten, die ich hatte, äh ging's mir war meine Situation finanziell nie so entspannt wie als Student, ja, weil man hat halt auch
null Ansprüche und irgendwie ja äh bin ich halt nach zwei Jahren studieren, hätte ich mehr Geld auf dem Konto als als ich angefangen äh äh hatte.
Ja, egal. Jedenfalls kamen dann halt äh ja äh und ich hatte dann äh sogar, ich hatte mich dann vorgestellt und habe den den Job
auch gekriegt, hatte da ein bisschen, ich habe da auch ein bisschen für die CT schon geschrieben gehabt so als äh nee, das kam dann nach erst, aber ähm.
Ja, äh aber habe dann wieder ein Angebot von dem Ingenieurbüro in Lüdenscheid äh gekriegt, IKW, Klaus Weber.
Ähm.
Und der hatte dann gesagt, irgendwie naja, wenn du jetzt sowieso äh aufhören willst zu studieren,
dann komm doch lieber zu mir und hatte mir dann irgendwie nochmal das Doppelte äh geboten äh an
an Geld und dann wusste ich auch, naja gut äh
okay, das ist dann auch eine Umgebung, äh die ich, die ich die ich kenne und dann war mein Programmierfrust auch so ein bisschen wieder äh abgebaut und bin dann eben.
Also wieder in,
ja, in das Ingenieurbüro in Lüdenscheid äh zurück. Das ist dann da, wo ich dann sage, da hatte ich da auch die Leiterplattentwicklung und und alles äh äh fortgesetzt, beziehungsweise weitergemacht und äh ja.
Und dann äh wie gesagt, dann kannte ich halt kommen schon über Freunde, die da waren. Ich hatte schon den
ähm in Berlin und war halt schon fasziniert so mit den na, die Silicon Graphics-Rechner da rumstehen und
ja, war einfach, war einfach cool.
Müssen wir mal sagen, was jetzt A plus com, so ist ja eigentlich der äh richtige Name, äh äh ist. Also wir reden jetzt von.
Achtundachtzig.
Achtundachtzig, da ist A plus com gegründet worden.
Com e. V. Und zwar war's äh äh tatsächlich so, dass ja damals auch der Computer eher was Böses äh
war, als die Grünen dann im Bundestag eingezogen sind, weiß ich nicht, war da ein Typ, der dann Computer benutzt hat und dann irgendwie geächtet wurde von allem, weil Computer waren irgendwie
Macht Instrumente, äh Instrumente des des Bösen und der Konzerne und so. Aber es gab da ein paar Leute, die meinten halt, ja mit Computern kann man eigentlich auch,
Kunst äh machen und Architektur und Musik und äh Videos und fanden,
sich jetzt an der HDK, an der Hochschule der Künste damals, wie sie noch hieß, heute UDK.
Fanden sie sich nicht so richtig wieder und haben dann gesagt, naja, da machen wir halt einen Verein äh mit dem Ziel, dass der dann später an Institut äh von der Hochschule der Künste ist. Da hatten sich halt ein paar.
Professoren und aber auch paar, ja, andere äh Leute ähm auch ein paar ähm ja.
Entwickler oder ITler äh und so zusammengetan. Architekten, Filmemacher.
Und ähm ja, die haben dann eben dieses äh diesen Verein gegründet und haben dann auch äh nach.
Kurzer Zeit, also so nach einem Jahr äh auch äh Funding von der Deutschen Telekom äh bekommen. Hauptsächlich wegen,
ja äh einem Prof damals äh
der äh halt ein ganz gutes äh Verhältnis zu äh als Jürgen Kanzler hatte, der äh eben bei der bei der war. Früher
Staatssekretär im Bundespostministerium unter Helmut Schmidt zuständig auch für die Einführung.
Äh von BTX äh unter anderem und der war dann halt in Berlin und hatte dann den Auftrag halt die ganzen Millionen Hauptstadtförderung und das Volk zu bringen.
Ist äh das Berliner Kommunikationssystem und das ist sozusagen so eine Unterabteilung der deutschen Bundespost gewesen. Mhm. Mit dem Ziel.
Tja. Ja.
Ja. Also damals ging's darum, Breitbandanwendung zu fördern.
Das war das große Thema. So, ISDN und Breitband, ISDN.
Genau, ISDN Breitbandnetz war halt so das große Thema und das Problem war, wir hatten halt jetzt da diese tollen Glasfasernetze, aber keiner wusste so richtig, was man damit jetzt anfangen sollte, weil
einfach die Bandbreiten so irrsinnig hoch war, dass es nichts gab, was irgendwie diese Netze auch nur annähernd auslasten.
Weil eigentlich alle damals nur telefoniert haben und äh ja. Das eben in so einem Netz kaum eine Bedeutung hat.
Ja oder sie haben's dann zum Video überspielen genommen. Sie haben's dann zwischen verschiedenen Fernsehsendern dann mit einem Hardware auch äh.
Wurden dann äh sagen konnten dann die Fernsehsender untereinander anrufen wie ISDN und dann konnten sie halt da äh.
In Echtzeit äh Videos übertragen, also ein Palvideo von 5 Minuten braucht dann halt fünf Minuten, äh um übertragen,
zu werden,
Während ja Internet, was hatten wir da so für Bandbreiten äh zu der Zeit wie eher so Anfang ja Breitband,
also ihr Anfang der 90er tatsächlich Modem und dann irgendwann ISDN.
Kanalbündung, also weißt noch, bei Artcom auch die erste Anbindung, nee, war sogar da text P. Ja, äh äh die erste Anbindung noch, bevor es das Internet gab, ähm so, weil ich noch ans DFN-Netz, da war die Domain auch noch,
Plus kommen ähm mit einem Pluszeichen und als ins sagen auf Internet Standard umgestellt wurde, mussten wir das Plus äh rausnehmen aus der Domain.
Weil das nicht mehr ging. Ja, also es war ebenfalls äh war irgendwie Video über spielen. War halt,
undenkbar gewesen und das war aber, aber videoüberspielen ist dann halt bisschen langweilig so als Demo auf der Messe zu zeigen, weil das sieht halt dann aus wie Fernsehen. So, das ist ja jetzt auch nicht besonders
beeindruckend, ja. Das heißt, sie brauchten halt dann etwas oder waren auf der Suche nach etwas, äh was dann
so mehr irgendwie sich mit Zukunft assoziieren äh lässt und,
dann so ja unter anderem den Bereich Telemedizin entdeckt,
kommen dann auch involviert war. Wir haben dann so mein erstes ja.
Wir haben dann mit der mit dem Klinikum damals unter anderem 'nen
zur Visualisierung von CT und MR Daten äh gemacht, mehrere Projekte, das halt auch recht lange gedauert hat, was halt auch spektakulär war, weil wir dann sagen, mit einem Volumen,
Datensätze, Visualisiert haben mit irgendwie rot glühenden, transparenten ähm Bandscheiben und so zwischen dann knöchernden Strukturen und so, also die.
Was für damalige Verhältnisse total futuristisch äh waren, ja. Vielleicht nochmal kurz zu zu äh Art kommen, also,
Als Verein gegründet worden, hat es dann geschafft, über die Kontakte zur Bergcom Geld quasi äh zu aquirieren
dieses Geld war vorhanden, weil normalerweise ja so Investmentkapital und sowas, das war ja in Deutschland
vollkommen absurd, schon gar nicht für äh Computer waren niemand bereit, da irgendwas auszugeben, aber in dem Fall war es halt einfach so, dadurch, dass dieses diese Bergcom in Berlin
angesiedelt war, war der Sinn eben auch Geld nach Berlin zu schleusen, weil Berlin war ja damals noch eine eine Insel und äh durch die,
Teilung Deutschlands ist die ganze Industrie in den Süden
abgewandert hier,
kaum irgendwas getan, bis auf ein bisschen Chemie, ein bisschen dies und ein bisschen das, äh aber es hat einfach nicht gereicht, um so eine riesige Stadt wirklich
durch und durch äh in so eine blühende Wirtschaftslandschaft zu
verwandeln und deswegen gab's halt immer wieder diesen politischen Auftrag, wir müssen irgendwie Geld in dieses Wirtschaftssystem reinchanneln und unter anderem gab's dafür halt die
Bergum, die letzten Endes die vollen Geldtöpfe der,
genommen hat und irgendwie irgendwo ausgeschüttet hat, wo sie gehofft haben, da könnte was Nettes bei rauskommen und wenn's nur eine geile Demo auf einer Messe ist.
Also letztlich waren alle Staatsunternehmen dazu angehalten, genau und.
Bei der waren's halt hunderte von Millionen, die sie mehr oder weniger sie kann so mehr oder weniger in der Stadt verschenken musste oder äh ja für Projektförderung ausgeben musste und das ist,
nicht so einfach wie man denkt so weil du kannst weil du willst es natürlich irgendwie skandalfrei tun und du musst natürlich irgendwie auch dann irgendwas vorzeigen für,
Geld, also du kannst es nicht einfach jetzt hier so mit äh so und äh ja,
Und da war äh halt äh Artkommen einfach so ein äh wichtiger Teil, äh der die Telekom hat halt cool aussehen lassen.
Und das ist äh meine erste Berührung mit,
A plus com hatte ich ähm ich weiß es nicht mehr ganz genau. Es muss so neunundachtzig ich glaube, ich bin so neunundachtzig neunzig das erste Mal über Leute, die ich halt dann kannte, die dort waren.
Da gehörtest du noch nicht dazu. Bin ich da mal gewesen,
Und es war halt so ein langer Follower mit vielen Räumen links und rechts und man ging von Raum zu Raum und es war einfach total awesome. Überall standen,
Silicon Graphics Unix Maschinen, Rum, äh es gab ein dickes, fettes Videostudio,
irgendwie seine Videokunst äh gemacht hat. Äh es gab eine Werkstatt ähm.
Und das ist ja auch im Namen von Art Plus com und ich glaube, das kann man gar nicht genug betonen, es gab wirklich diese zwei Teile. Es gab wirklich,
und es gab kommen, es gab Gestalter, es gab drei D Designer, es gab Leute, die wirklich mit den limitierten Möglichkeiten der Systeme sehr viel rausholen konnten,
alle Werkzeuge, die die Computer damals grafisch bereitstellten, wurden von irgendjemand irgendwie beherrscht, ja? Also es gab Leute, die konnten mit Photoshop arbeiten, mit äh Layout Software arbeiten, mit 3 D arbeiten.
3D-Architekturprogramm, drei D Animationen äh äh machen.
Genau, also der Artteil war auf jeden Fall sehr stark und.
Überrascht wenig, dadurch dass diese Verbindung und im Prinzip ja auch dieser Geburtskanal, der äh Hochschule der Künste äh dort da lag, dass,
schon eine ganze Menge Auswirkungen gehabt. Und auf der anderen Seite gab's aber auch einen starken Combereich. Es gab viele Leute, die sehr gut programmieren konnten, die sich in unterschiedlichen Systemen auskanten,
Und nicht zuletzt das Plus fand ich immer, war so diese Werkstatt, ja, die da war, ähm.
Mhm. Ja, es gab eine Elektronikwerkstatt ohne Mechanikwerkstatt.
Genau, vor allem diese Mechanikwerte, aber einfach dieses, wenn wir Interfaces brauchen für unsere Sachen, wenn's einfach quasi mit dem, was es gibt,
Wenn das nicht ausreicht oder wenn die Anwendung einfach ein spezielles Interface erfordert, dann würde das eben auch in Haus erarbeitet. Und so hatte man halt eigentlich,
Vollständigkeit, von der du vorhin so gesprochen hast und das komplette System, ja. Man man hatte wirklich für jeden irgendwie was äh im Angebot und und und konnte dann Systeme, ja, so holistisch äh aus dem Nichts schaffen.
Sagen heute so ein bisschen, eigentlich wie so ein Makeer Lab äh auch, könnte man äh.
Sagen, somit allen möglichen, verschiedenen Dingen, nur dass es halt außerdem auch noch äh ja äh eine Menge Geld gab.
Also es war, war halt schon äh äh ja
wie gesagt, also da stand stand halt schon also Equipment für auch Millionen am am Ende, also,
ich weiß nicht, wie viel insgesamt für alle Projekte zusammen äh äh geflossen ist, aber ich würde sagen, es waren so.
Zwanzig dreißig Millionen äh am Ende des Tages über zehn Mark, ja. Äh über einen Zeitraum von zehn Jahren äh.
Das war auf jeden Fall schon äh fett. Aber mit hat dieser Spirit gefallen, weil dadurch, dass es ein Verein war und man eigentlich ja nicht an Produkt
in dem eiligen Sinne arbeitet, sondern eigentlich permanent nur neue Prototypen geschaffen hat, sich immer wieder was komplett Neues, hat einfallen lassen und äh am Ende musste es halt nur irgendwie funktionieren und demonstrbel sein
Das hat einfach auch dazu beigetragen, dass da nie so eine Businessmentalität vorherrschte, sondern dass halt wirklich so ein Make-up war.
Und das führte dann natürlich auch zum Problem irgendwann,
über kurz oder lang, weil.
Ja, äh wie das so in Vereinen manchmal so ist, gibt's dann in Vereinen halt auch manchmal Krach.
Und wenn's dann äh letztlich niemanden gibt, dem das gehört.
Also der Verein hat sie dann irgendwann ja, also die ganzen Maschinen und so gehörten halt dann dem dem Verein.
Äh und äh ja, aber wem gehörte der Verein, so seinen Mitgliedern und äh ja ähm und dann.
Gab's halt äh irgendwann eben äh äh Krach mit.
Zwischen unter anderem dem dem langjährigen Geschäftsführer, der auch eigentlich die ganze Kohle rangeschafft hat, im Eduard Bannwart.
Ehemaliger, reicher, Schweizer Bank hieß Sohn, der aber dann rebelliert ist und nach Berlin gegangen ist, sich erst im SO 36 irgendwie engagiert hat und da nicht so ganz auf
sagen Begeisterung gestoßen ist
und dort halt rausgeschmissen wurde, dann gegründet hat äh äh und äh ich sage mal, ohne ihn äh also durch ihn ist glaube ich,
hauptsächlich dieser Telekom Kontakt zustande gekommen, weil ja doch jemand war auch wo,
Fünf Minuten Charisma äh genannt, äh hinterher war, halt,
Einfach so ja braun gebrannt, sympathisch, so norrische Stimme, super angezogen, wo ich alleine nur geehrt fühltest, wenn äh er dir die Hand gab so. Ja, also er hatte wirklich dieses also schon,
Äh ja adliges, wenn du so willst an sich, was vielleicht auch durch seine Erziehung ähm irgendwie kam, sowohl dann mit
so Problem konfrontiert war als Jugendlicher, so nehme ich jetzt, weiß ich nicht, nehme ich jetzt den Maserati oder den Porsche oder den Royce-Royce und sagt, ich,
aber eben komplett gewandelt hatte, aber so diese diese Erziehung, keine Ahnung, wenn man in so einem Haus aufwächst, glaube ich, sieht man die Welt auch ein bisschen.
Anders als ähm normale Leute.
Jedenfalls in der Erde halt sagen riesige Verdienste eigentlich äh entwickelt äh,
aber ist dann so ein bisschen abgedreht äh irgendwann und äh,
Ja, hat dann im Überschwang halt Verträge,
ich sage mal, ist größenwahnsinnig geworden. So hatten wir jedenfalls das Gefühl.
Großteil ist gefühlt und dann gab's so dann kam's zum Showdown.
So im Verein, wo dann auf einer Sitzung sagen, die eine Seite und die andere Seite, dann argumentierend und um die Stimmen.
Der Mitglieder äh geworben äh haben und am Ende, ja, hat, ich sage mal, unsere Seite oder meine Seite, so ich
war halt immer einer der Meuterer, dann nachdem ich lange Zeit mit ihm im Vorstand zusammengearbeitet habe, aber irgendwann nicht mehr konnte, weil er,
äh irgendwann so vom Führungsstil so aller, der was gesagt, ähm hat er mir was gesagt. Ich habe dann gesagt, das ist keine gute Idee.
Ja? Lasst uns das lieber nicht machen. So nee, äh so ähm ich bin hier, das ist meine Verantwortung, wir machen das jetzt. Ich sage okay, ist deine Verantwortung, wir machen das jetzt so, so. Dann ging's halt.
Schief. So,
und dann was sollte denn der Scheiß? Was sagst denn du da gemacht, ja? So, ich meine, das machst du irgendwie einmal mit.
Aber beim zweiten Mal hast du nie, also unter den so kann ich nicht arbeiten, so will ich nicht.
Arbeiten, ja? So geht das nicht. Und bin dann halt raus, dann sind halt andere in den in den Vorstand, die haben's dann aber auch nur eine Woche ausgehalten äh so im Vorstand, bevor es dann geknallt hat, so dass es dann halt diesen Streit gab, so,
und ähm.
Dich dann der Einzige war, der dann mit Eduard Panward immer damals zu gegangen ist äh so und ihn kannte und er sagen die große Eminenz war mit dem Geld, die man überzeugen musste und äh.
Er war jetzt gar nicht so,
oder null begeistert. Ich meine, er hatte jetzt in ich weiß nicht, über Jahre hinweg irgendwie da Millionen in die Projekte reingegeben, da hat sie sich jetzt mittlerweile auch Know-how angesammelt und auch auch Werte äh möglicherweise, keine Ahnung,
Aber äh ja, jedenfalls plötzlich äh äh war für ihn klar, okay, ähm nee,
in so einem zerstrittenen Laden gebe ich jetzt nichts und
Eduard hat dann gesagt, so ich mache jetzt mein eigenes Ding und äh äh sehe jetzt zu, dass ich da irgendwie das das Geld äh nicht mehr nach Artcom fließt, sondern das wird jetzt alles irgendwie in meinen
in meinen neuen Laden gehen.
Bevor wir da weiter gehen, musst du nochmal kurz erwähnen, wie du eigentlich zu Art komm dann gekommen bist du.
Okay, also äh zur Art kommen gekommen äh bin ich eben dadurch, weil ich halt zu den wenigen Macintosh-Programmierern gehörte und die mich kannten und ein paar enge Freunde und dann habe ich mir gesagt, Henrik und der Klüsebrink und so, die waren,
halt äh und und Hans, die waren halt schon äh irgendwie alle da, darüber kannte ich Art kommen und die kannten mich und mussten jetzt für die Cebit neunzig,
mussten sie irgendwie ein VR-Exponat machen und in diesem VR-Exponat spielte auch Meck eine wichtige Rolle, weil dort äh nämlich,
auf diesen Mac äh damals von äh VPLYS Firma äh.
So einer der Pioniere der drei D Geschichte.
Pioniere der der drei D Geschichte mit dem Datenhandschuh damals, sie hatten so den ersten Daten Handschuh und den ersten das erste Headmounted Display so Ende der Achtziger, Anfang der Neunziger,
rausgebracht und damals und mit irgendwie dann magnetischen weiß ich noch.
Äh und,
VPL glaube ich für und.
Programmiert hast das System, in dem du dann so.
Prinzip Funktionselemente, grafisch auf dem Bildschirm hin und her gezogen und verdrahtet Hass und dann habt ihr die ganzen Transformationen äh äh gemacht und zu sagen, die VR-Anwendungen,
gesteuert, wenn du wenn du so willst und das sollte dann halt aber so laufen, dass quasi.
Die Sensoren und ähm das Headmounted Display und.
Die, ja, der Detail, äh, wie er hieß, der Datenhandschuh, dass die halt alle in Hamburg sind und die Maschinen, die Silicon Graphics, Maschinen aber in Berlin stehen und.
Über halt die Glasfaser, die Sensordaten nach Berlin geschickt werden, dort die Bilder gerändert werden, so
eins ist eine Maschine fürs Rechte, eine andere Maschine fürs linke Auge
Und die wurden dann wiederum per Glasfaser dann nach Hannover zurückgeschickt, sodass man dann dort wie VR machen konnte und das war dann aber noch mit irgendwie Kamera und Live abspielen und da musste dann,
halt äh dann in,
musste dann halt das System gesteuert werden, weiß ich noch, das lief so ein offener Sun auch äh und.
Ähm äh ja, es es musste halt dieses ganze Ding irgendwie zusammengedraht.
Prinzip so die Idee wie so heute moderne online Gaming Netzwerke arbeiten, wo wirklich auf den Servern das Spiel geändert wird und,
hast nur noch irgendwie im Browser oder Interface und lieferst dir Input. Das hat dann nochmal 20 Jahre gedauert, 25 Jahre, bis das für dich Realität äh geworden ist.
Bis die Leitung dann so schnell waren wie die, die wir äh damals hatten so, ja.
Aber du bist dann sozusagen von Lüdenscheid nach Berlin gegangen für dieses.
Ich hatte, ich hatte noch, ich hatte noch irgendwie in der alten Firma, hatte ich noch zwei Monate Rest
Urlaub und äh so mein Konto war auch äh irgendwie gerade so ein bisschen im im Notstand ähm und dachte mir, naja super äh gut eigentlich darf man ja während des Urlaubs nicht
arbeiten, weil der muss ja der Erholung dienen, aber mein Chef hatte da jetzt kein Problem mit, also.
Klaus in Lüdenscheid und ähm dann habe ich sozusagen meinen Urlaub, zwei Monate lang äh bei Artcom diese Vorbereitung auf die Cebit gemacht.
Du bist dahin gekommen, weil du Leute kanntest, die da waren, die da waren, die auch aus Lüdenscheid waren.
Weil ich Leute kannte, die da waren und weil ich, genau, die auch aus Lüdenscheid waren und weil ich aber halt Kenntnisse hatte, die sie brauchten. So, das war sagen das Ding, weil sie niemanden.
Für dieses Projekt auf der CBD199. Ich glaube, das habe ich sogar gesehen, diese ganze Datenhandschuhgeschichte, das.
Mhm.
Als das so anfing, dieser ganze VR-Hype, der da nie enden wollte und.
Ja, also jedenfalls war Artcom, auch wenn man sagen, äh der erste Laden, der in Deutschland VR gemacht hat, also lange voll, bevor die Fraunhofer angefangen hatten, äh sich ihr VR-Equipment oder ihr VR Labor
aufzubauen,
sondern und haben sogar dann, äh also Henrik hatte als Diplomarbeit einen Rediosity-Ränder äh geschrieben, der es halt ermöglichte, so drei D Szenen äh wirklich äh mit.
Ähm eine Art von Beleuchtung äh zu Rändern, die realistisch
außerhalb im Prinzip äh diffuse Lichtberechnung war halt perfekt,
so, wenn halt äh oder perfekt, also war halt jedenfalls physikalisch,
gerechnet, äh wodurch halt äh die ganzen VR-Szenen nicht mehr so flach aussahen und nicht mehr so ja äh kartoonmäßig, sondern,
einen riesigen Schritt an an Realismus gekriegt haben, deswegen VPL dann auch lizensiert und und vertrieben.
So, also.
Okay, also Überkontakte in deiner Freizeit quasi oder in deinem Urlaubszeit äh bist du für dieses Projekt dazugekommen und bist dann gleich geblieben.
Nachdem ich irgendwie auf dieser dann erlebt hab, ich weiß noch dass damals irgendwie kam dann Schwarz-Schilling auch auf den, auf den Stand.
Also damaliger Postminist.
Bundespostminister, genau. Und äh ja, plötzlich, ich meine,
Das Gefühl äh so wir befinden uns so schon mal an der vordersten Front
technischen Entwicklungen mit den Grafikzeit, mit CT und MR äh äh,
Apparaten äh äh.
Anfang der Neunziger war das wirklich ganz weit vorne.
Es war also mal äh ja, das war also einfach mehr, als ich mir jemals erträumt hatte so und ich dachte dann plötzlich, okay
ja, was jetzt irgendwie alles erreicht. Ja, was sie erreichen wolltest, ich glaube, ich habe meine meine Ziele ein bisschen äh zu niedrig gesetzt äh so,
so so war das auf einmal ja und so bin ich dann geblieben und hab dann als erstes.
So in dem im Bereich.
Ja, wie die mäht, hieß das damals, visualisierung, digitaler, medizinischer Daten, war ich erst Mitarbeiter, dann irgendwann Projektleiter und.
Das war so eines der Projekte, was dann später auch mündete, also später haben wir dann auch für Ärzte ähm so.
Trainingssysteme, Operationstrainingssysteme äh geschrieben für so Neurologen, für minimal invasive Eingriffe.
Und äh dafür musste ich dann halt auch äh ja.
Bei Operationen zu gucken, also bin dann halt auch mit im OP.
Wa. Oh Gott.
Wiesn so äh und ja, ja, das war, war schon fies, zumal, was ich auch nie vergessen werde, war äh
offensichtlich so Tricks, die die dann bei Medizinstudenten machen, so einer der Patienten, der hatte dann äh lag dann in so einem stereotaktischen Geschirr, das heißt, das ist so ein
Prinzip, wie auf so einem Globus und so mit so einer Gradeinteilung, das ist dann an den Schädel geschraubt äh und mit dem wird der dann durchs CT geschoben.
Und äh dadurch,
wissen sie halt genau wo sie halt jetzt wie rein müssen um den wenigsten Schaden anzurichten und ja,
Und weil das halt sehr schmerzhaft ist, passiert das halt alles äh während der Patient dann eigentlich schon in Vollnarkose ist,
muss dann aber durchs ganz in Vollnarkose durchs ganze Krankenhaus äh,
Card bewerben, muss dafür dann beatmet werden
und es war nicht etwa so, dass dann irgendwie so ein Beatmungsgerät dann mitfuhr, sondern dann
wurde mir halt so eine Luftpumpe wie wie so eine fast wie so eine Matratzen-Luftmatratzen-Luftpumpe in die Hand gedrückt und dann sagt der mir hier, irgendwie jetzt pumpt mal und nicht vergessen, sonst erstickt.
Gut.
Ich bin ja davon ausgegangen, naja gut, da sind wahrscheinlich jetzt so die Challenges, die sie dann auch mit äh irgendwie Medizinstudenten machen. Ja, jedenfalls habe ich dann, also ich war nie äh so aufmerksam und konzentriert beim Pumpen.
Oh Gott.
So ja. Also insofern hat mich das halt auch viel äh äh rumgebracht auf der Medizinerkonferenz habe ich dann auch wie.
Dirk das so schön unter den den Doktor de facto äh äh bekommen. Doktor de facto ist, wenn nicht irgendwie dreimal jemand als Herr Doktor vorstellt, ohne dass sie irgendwie selber Anlass gegeben hast oder äh.
Und auf der Medizinerkonferenz gibt's sowieso nur entweder ankreuzen dann ob du Doktor oder Professor oder beides bist,
so normalerweise, ja. Also es war jedenfalls auch, also Medizinerkonferenzen ist immer so eine spezielle Art, weil könnte ich jetzt auch lange äh drüber erzählen, aber wir, also.
Das führt dann zu weit. Okay, also du hast äh,
Okay, du bist also zur Art kommen gekommen, du hast das erste Projekt gehabt, du hast gemerkt, okay, alles klar, hier findet irgendwie die Zukunft statt, dann hast du dich dort eingebracht, viele weitere Projekte äh folgten.
94 brach dann das ursprüngliche Konstrukt auseinander. Es gab diese Meuterei.
Was dann übrigens auch der Zeitpunkt äh ist, wo äh ich dann äh ins Spiel kam, weil ich war dann in so einer ähnlichen Situation, damals in Hamburg, irgendwie Konto, war dann irgendwie äh leer gefeiert und äh.
Äh der ja auch Teil dieser äh Revolution war, rief mich irgendwie an, meint so, ja, wir haben jetzt gerade einen Laden übernommen irgendwie, wir brauchen neue Leute. Hast du nicht Bock, nach Berlin äh zu kommen? Und so kam ich dann äh mit dazu.
Ja und genau, meine Rolle in dem Ganzen war dann erstens, ich hatte halt jetzt den Kontakt zu,
aber die Telekom und äh und wir hatten zudem zu dem Zeitpunkt aber war Terrorvision schon beauftragt. Also es war, sagen wir ein Projekt, was ursprünglich noch,
äh an den EV gegangen ist und während halt.
Dieses Jahres zwischen Beauftragung und und dem Auftritt in Kyoto passierte halt diese äh Revolution. Also vor, die war jedenfalls vor Kyoto und.
Ähm dann war's eben auch noch so, hm,
dass es jetzt darum ging, ähm dann.
Ja äh kriegen wir überhaupt noch weiter Geld ohne Bannbad, ohne den großen Zampano. Und weil was was,
nämlich die Telekom dann gesagt hat oder kannst du dann gesagt hatte ja nee also wir geben
an einen Verein zukünftig kein Geld mehr, weil diese dieser Konflikt äh so, das das ist uns zu unsicher. Ja, das ist uns zu instabil, also wir haben jetzt nicht gesagt, wir geben euch kein Geld, nein, wir werden grundsätzlich keine Vereine mehr.
Fördern. So. Was ich natürlich dann als Aufforderung zur Gründung einer GmbH empfunden hatte.
Und äh ja, haben dann halt unter anderem ja eine eine GBR und eine und eine GmbH dann gegründet und quasi,
parallel zum Artcom e. V. Gab's dann eben die Art kommen äh GmbH und später Artcom e. V. Und ich war dann der erste Geschäftsführer, weil irgendwie.
AG, meinst du? Ja. Splitter die AG. Mhm.
Ja, äh genau. Artcom AG.
Ich war sozusagen dann einer der äh beiden ersten Geschäftsführer, weil irgendwie war das so auf meinem Mist gewachsen und
Ich hatte mir dann auch Hilfe von anderen grauhaarigen, weil die ganze Situation war auch noch so. Ich meine, als Mitte 20-jähriger war ja es nicht, nicht so wie bei dot com oder so, sondern da waren halt die grauhaarigen, hatten alle
haben eigentlich alles untereinander ausgemacht so und als Mitwanziger oder Anfang 30-jähriger wurdest du in dem Kontext äh unter den alten Herren überhaupt nicht ernst genommen. Deswegen
habe ich mir dann so ein paar äh grauhaarige noch zur Hilfe geholt, die mich dann immer begleitet äh äh haben. Und.
Einer von den so Berliner Anwalt auch episch Löchel, damals Anwalt von,
Udo Lindenberg und Nina, unter anderem, der hat dann ähm auch eine große Rolle gespielt und sagen uns
Kids äh zu helfen, uns durchzusetzen und mit dem bin ich dann zur Bergraum äh marschiert und habe dann irgendwie gesagt, ja, können wir voll verstehen, dass wir Verein äh kein Geld mehr geben wollen, deswegen haben wir hier jetzt irgendwie diese Firma gegründet und alles wird gut,
So
Das war natürlich ein bisschen, war schon ein bisschen frech äh so, aber äh ja.
So ich sah es nicht ein, dass das irgendwie alles den Bach runtergeht. Und ja dann haben wir es mehr oder weniger erfolgreich geschafft
das Personal äh also die ganzen Arbeitsverträge, die Leute in die neue GmbH zu transferieren und den Verein gab's dann auch noch. Äh der hat von dem
hat die GmbH dann das ganze Equipment gemietet und die Räume übernommen und so. Also wir haben das halt dann auch formal ganz gut hingekriegt und.
Was die Telekom dann letztlich getan hat, war dass die Hälfte des Geldes an gegeben und die Hälfte mit der Hälfte weiter Hardcore gefördert. Aber,
Deswegen waren wir so im, im, im Stress, was äh, äh, war, dass, äh, sagen, dass das erste Bewährungsprojekt war in Kyoto. Sagen das erste Mal ohne Bannwart.
Und das Projekt hast du schon gesagt, heißt Terrorvision und ähm.
Da müssen wir ja natürlich jetzt mal äh im Detail drüber reden, weil das ähm das ist jetzt das Ding, worum es ging im, in diesem Film. Wann ist das dann.
Wann ist denn die Idee zu diesem Projekt überhaupt gekommen und woraus resultierte das? Was was war jetzt sozusagen die Genese?
Okay, ähm also es gab mehrere Dinge. Zum einen äh kamen ein Freund von Joachim, Andreas Schneider.
Joachim ist Joachim Sauter, der.
Fässer Joachim Satan, genau.
An der Unika leider dieses Jahr verstorben. Ja. Mhm.
So ähm,
und der hatte einen äh Freund, der in Japan lebte und dort an der Kunsthochschule war und der hat wiederum für die Firma namens News äh gearbeitet. Äh IshiBashi, toller Typ
Sohlfirma gibt's, glaube ich, immer noch und die haben unter anderem.
3D Wetteräh gemacht für den den japanischen Sender.
NHK oder so. Nee, ja, irgendwie ja, haben die halt wetter äh gerändert. Ich glaube,
gar nicht auf was für eine Maschine, also war jetzt halt keine SGI, aber äh es war halt Pott langsam. So, es dauerte zwischen vier und sieben Sekunden, um ein Bild aufzubauen.
Also wir reden jetzt von diesen Wetterkarten, wo so die Wolken äh langziehen und so.
Genau. Genau.
Heutzutage vollkommen normal ist, aber damals halt ein erheblicher Aufwand war, sowas überhaupt erstmal hinzubekommen.
Genau und er hatte das halt aber automatisiert und war dann auch ja äh also sah halt ganz ganz ordentlich aus.
Und ja, dachten so, na toll, aber äh ist halt ja, ist halt eine automatisierte Animation, aber eigentlich musste es schneller gehen. Ich äh hatte mir sowieso wieso rendert der irgendwie sieben Sekunden äh äh für dieses Bild so?
Welchem Jahr sind wir jetzt dreiundneunzig.
Gewesen sein, genau.
Und das war sozusagen so ein bisschen ein Anlass. So und er hatte halt eben auch Satellitenbilddaten, äh wo er gesagt hat, ja hier kann ich euch zur Verfügung stehen. Also äh sagt.
Es läuft irgendwie super langsam. Wir würden gerne mal gucken, wir glauben, dass das deutlich schneller geht äh so. Äh äh sollen wir da, sollen wir da dem nicht mal irgendwie einen Schott
geben, äh gucken, wie weit wir das beschleunigen können eigentlich.
Also es war so die Situation, die Daten, die Verbindungen waren da, Daten lagen so rum. Ich meine, muss man sich auch vorstellen, dreiundneunzig man hatte keine Daten von der Welt,
es gab nirgendswo irgendwie nennenswert was zusammenhängendes überhaupt so,
Bilder aus der Luft von der Erde zu bekommen, war Sack schwierig. Ich erinnere mich noch, als wir
das erste Camp äh organisiert haben, 1999 wollten wir auch zur Planung irgendwie ein Luftbild haben zum Katasteramt gegangen und dann irgendwie diesen Behörden auch nur irgendwie nennenswert,
brauchbares, geschweige digital aus den Fingern zu saugen, war einfach sauschwierig. Insofern war das natürlich jetzt auch eine besondere Gelegenheit, überhaupt über solche Daten zu verfügen.
Also es gab einmal Firmen, wo man einkaufen konnte und die NASA fing auch an, so langsam
in die zu stellen
Aber äh das Internet war halt auch noch zu langsam. Das heißt, man konnte die dann auswählen und äh dann kamen die halt auf äh so, dass weiterhin auch nicht ganz billig, weil man die für die Datenträger äh bezahlen muss. Das heißt.
Bänder, Bänder, genau, da kamen dann halt Bänderlager in einer kistenweise irgendwie Bänder äh an, die man dann einlesen musste und äh ja. Also,
Es war halt alles äh wirklich mühsam so. Äh und genau und die.
Plattenstapel, weiß noch, äh ja, die große Workstation, also.
Kam dann mit entweder eine 500 Megabyte ähäh Festplatte oder dann hatten wir ein Gigabyte.
Für 93 auch schon mega viel.
Ja und später waren dann, weiß ich noch, sind wir auf neun Gigabyte äh äh hochgegangen und als wir dann,
Also die Datenbasis, mit der wir nach Kyoto geflogen sind, das waren halt so Plattenstapel mit fetten, neuen Gigabyte Platten, also wir hatten dann irgendwie.
50 Gigabyte oder so in der in der in der Datenbasis was für damalige äh äh Verhältnisse einfach.
Datacenter war.
Einfach äh ja, ein Data-Center war und,
der Hauptspeicher waren 512 Megabyte, das war auch so hammermäßig, mal gucken, also was PCs so damals äh äh hatten, aber äh ja.
Dreiundneunzig muss so ein, zwei, ich glaube, da war vier Megabyte, war schon viel.
Komm, wir hatten halt über bis zu fünfhundertzwölf ähäh davon, äh so, das war schon, ja, mega.
Okay, also ihr habt diese diese Daten gehabt. Diese Wetterdaten, also im Wesentlichen äh also.
Videodaten von äh Meteo Satelliten, von Wettersatelliten, die lagen euch digital vor und jetzt ging's dadrum, okay, wie kann man das schneller ändern?
Und habe das hinbekommen. Ähm ja.
Ja
so ja, also es ging, wir haben ja erstmal ganz einfach angefangen und äh im Prinzip mal gesagt, okay, ähm.
Wir brauchen halt für das Terrain und für die Topographie brauchen wir halt so eine multiresolution äh äh Pyramide, also das war halt
relativ klar, so wie das auch bei Photoshop macht oder generell zur zur Beschleunigung, dass du halt ähm.
Dann äh ja das hochaufgelöste Bild in verschiedenen Auflösungen.
Runterrechnest und dann äh ja in verschiedenen Auflösungen erstmal vorliegen hast. Aber
verschiedene Auflösung alleine reichen nicht, weil du musstest halt zusätzlich noch aufteilen, also muss es halt zusätzlich noch jeden, jeden Layer in.
Aufteilen, damit du halt, wenn du jetzt schräg auf die Erde guckst, äh hast du halt direkt in deiner Nähe, brauchst du halt eine hochaufgelöste Kachel und je weiter äh das in die Ferne geht, umso niedriger aufgelöst sind dann die Kacheln.
Dieses Video, was ihr da letzten Endes erzeugt habt, darum ging's ja, ne? Ähm das war jetzt, was so ein schräger Anflug auf Japan oder äh was was war sozusagen das eigentliche Ziel.
Ja äh Grunde genommen ja waren das so Blicke aus erstmal.
Ja Anflüge schon aus dem Weltall, aus der quasi aus einer die Erde gesamt.
Teil äh Ausschnitt so von von Japan äh jetzt im Wesentlichen. Damit hatten wir angefangen und.
Das hatten die auch vorher schon.
Das hatten die auch vorher schon, ja.
Aber es hat nur ewig gedauert.
Aber es hat ewig gedauert, äh so, dass das zu.
Und äh ja und sie konnten auch nicht so richtig nah ran äh so, also.
Die weiteste bis die nächste Entfernung ja äh und wie gesagt sieben Sekunden pro Bild und ähm.
Ja und wir hatten dann erstmal, ich hatte dann erstmal angefangen, weiß ich noch äh halt Software zu machen, die dann einfach die äh Satelliten,
Bilder ähm skaliert und klein hackt und irgendwie einfach wegschreibt, dass sie halt schnell äh zu
sind und dann einfach ein zwei D Browser erstmal gemacht, mit dem man sich rein und rausklicken konnte, ganz ohne Perspektive,
und war dann halt total geflasht, wie schnell das ist. Gut, ich war halt auch immer so ein bisschen Performance äh äh Fetischist, das heißt, ich habe halt schon auch immer geguckt
okay, was sind so
Fast, Pats und wie muss ich die Daten am besten auf der Platte auch ablegen? Äh was sind so die optimalen und Buffer äh äh Größen und und so und das war so ein
äh Teil und das hatte ich aber quasi immer auch schon so drin äh so, das heißt, ich habe schon von vorne herein, ich habe zwar nicht mit dem Optimieren angefangen, aber ich habe
sagen, schon von Anfang an mehr oder weniger,
ist relativ schnell gemacht. Ja und dann war ich auf einmal total geflasht, als ich feststellte, dass ich diese, dass diese Kacheln äh so verdammt schnell reinkommen, dass ich
ja, das war schon fast wie ein Flug einfach nur so und dann kann man der zweite Teil, das war dann hauptsächlich.
Also anstatt ein einzelnes Bild in sieben Sekunden zu berechnen, war's schon ging es schon in Richtung Echtzeit.
Ja, ja, ging es schon, also es war, war halt schon mal ganz, ganz klar, dass man dass wir
Ich weiß nicht, so hundert Patches äh pro Sekunde, laden und darstellen konnten, irgendwie größenordnungsmäßig, also 100 Flicken und das schien mir halt jetzt auch eine Rate zu sein, äh die ähm
das soll jetzt dann der nächste Punkt, wie wenn man die jetzt,
Texturen äh äh benutzt, es ausreichen müsste, um jetzt bei der Annäherung äh halt äh ja äh die die schnell genug zu aktualisieren, das das dann kontinuierlicher Flug.
Ist der Begriff aus der Computergrafik, wenn man quasi einfach so eine Pixel Pixelbild nimmt und das auf dreidimensionale Elemente drauflegt.
Ja, genau. Also im Grunde genommen ja, wird das perspektivisch ist das ein perspektivisch verzerrtes Bild äh und die Verzerrung,
folgt halt in der 3D Geometrie im Wesentlichen Dreiecken. Und äh in dem Fall war unsere Geometrie war halt eigentlich Topographie, also Höhendaten und und eine Kugel,
So ja jedenfalls äh mal an der nächste äh Teil.
Das jetzt in eine 3D-Szenerie äh zu bringen und äh im Wesentlichen war dann halt der der Globus bestand dann eben aus einem drei D Gitter.
Ähm einer Kugel, also eine Annäherung, einer Kugel durch die durch Dreiecke angenährt war.
Und äh beziehungsweise eigentlich durch quadratische,
patches, die so entlang der Längen und Breitengradlinien ausgerichtet waren äh und jeweils aber um die Höhendaten so nach oben verschoben. Das heißt, das ist sozusagen auch Gebirge,
Gebirgsstrukturen und so äh dann halt äh in diesem Gitter äh hattest. Und dann war ihm dann auch noch die Schwierigkeit, äh.
Jetzt nicht nur also einem Schritt gegen die die Daten jetzt von der Platte, also aus dem Netzwerk von der Datenbank in den Hauptspeicher, aber dann mussten sie noch in den Hauptspeicher in den Texturspeicher auf der Grafikkarte.
Und da äh gab's dann eben auch so ein paar Tricks, weil es gab einen sogenannten wenn
Auch heute noch, wenn die Daten ein bestimmtes Format hatten, dann gab's eine spezielle Hardware dafür, die die Daten dann schnell bewegt oder transformiert hat, das heißt, du musst es dann auch noch, wenn du,
Pixel im richtigen Format hattest, äh so dann konntest du die auch relativ schnell vom Hauptspeicher in den Texturspeicher,
transportieren, was dann an der, der zweite Teil war. Ja, und dann?
Der eigentlich schwierige Teil war dann aber hm.
Weil die Erde ist verdammt groß. Das merkten wir dann. Dies, die ist viel größer, als man denkt.
Als man denkt.
Und wenn man versucht, äh die jetzt sagen, auf eine Dimension runter, die jetzt so menschlicher Größe entspricht, also ich sage mal, im Zentimeter oder Meter,
Maßstab man sich bewegt, ist es einfach gigantisch. Man kann, ich meine.
Klar, gar nicht vorstellen, es dauert ein Jahr, bis man so äh durch so ein Kontinent marschiert,
zu Fuß, so und das,
wäre jetzt auf äh den den echten Daten jetzt auch nicht anders, ja? Das heißt, du kannst da Jahre, Jahrzehnte, Jahrhunderte in diesen Daten äh rumlaufen, was halt aber auch bedeutete, dass allein.
Des Inhaltsverzeichnisses, welche Daten sind überhaupt da? So groß war, dass man das nicht einfach laden konnte.
Das war dann so das nächste Problem, was wir dann äh lösen.
Mussten, wie kriegen wir jetzt eine Schnittstelle hin, mit der wir die Datenbank so ansprechen, ähm dass sie uns die äh.
Die richtigen Daten zur richtigen Zeit liefert, sage ich mal und das möglichst schnell. Und das war dann an der.
Der eigentlich ein Kniff Plus.
Film vorkommt äh die Welt ist halt auch einfach zu groß für 32 Bit Floating Point äh Zahlen.
Reden wir denn jetzt noch von dieser Wetter äh äh Rändergeschichte oder war jetzt im Prinzip schon die Idee für ein äh eigenständiges System geboren.
Also.
Zu irgendeinem Zeitpunkt waren wir relativ sicher, dass wir was Geiles mit Satelliten machen können.
Und mit der Welt und mit Geodaten, also dass wir auf jeden Fall den State of the Art äh so weit nach vorne pushen können, dass wir damit was spektakuläres zeigen.
Ist in euer System dann auch wirklich mal benutzt worden, um diese Wetter äh Geschichte in Japan zu rändern.
Jein. Äh Ishibashi hat dann irgendwann auch eine Kopie von Terrorvision äh äh sagen, gekauft oder bei sich installieren lassen. So, also.
Fern, ja, äh auf Prinzip ja, aber äh äh tatsächlich Wetterproduktion haben wir dann wiederum noch mit einem anderen System. Wir haben dann später für die Deutsche Welle,
auch eine Zeit lang das Weltwetter produziert in 3D. Das haben wir aber auf eine andere Art und Weise gemacht. Also.
Okay, also das war so quasi die Inspiration. Ihr hattet die Daten, die hat damit rumgespielt, wie könnte man das machen? Dann war das relativ schnell da, aber dann ist so daraus die Idee entstanden so,
also wenn wir das jetzt so schnell hinbekommen, was wäre wenn wir jetzt quasi ein System bauen,
dass die ganze Welt abdeckt, vorausgesetzt man kriegt auch genug Daten von der ganzen Welt, aber wie du vorhin schon gesagt hast, es ging halt langsam los, Landzeitdaten, der NASA-Satellit wurden die Daten öffentlich zur Verfügung gestellt, konnte man sich im Prinzip,
Na ja, runterladen ist im Sinne von LKWs mit äh Tapes und dann äh vorausgesetzt, man hat genug Speicherkapazität seht ihr das auch in dem eigenen System
abzuspeichern konnte man darauf zugreifen, aber die eigentliche Frage ist, wie organisiert man jetzt diese Daten um diesem Problem äh entgegen zu treten, was du schon gesagt hast,
Die ganze Welt sind einfach sehr viele Daten. Also
muss man sich Wege ausdenken, dass man die Daten so organisiert, dass man eigentlich auch immer nur und zwar auch relativ schnell auf die Daten in der Auflösung zugreift, wie man sie jetzt grade in dem Moment braucht, wo man etwas
visualisiert. Ja. Das heißt, im Prinzip war jetzt die Idee eines eines virtuellen Globus geboren.
Und der Vorstellung, man könnte diesen Globus aufm Computer mehr oder weniger in Echtzeit rotieren lassen und sich,
vor allem beliebig tief auf die Erde herabsenken und während man das tut, immer,
aufgelöste Daten bekommen von dem Bild, von diesem Bildausschnitt und.
Wir haben dann auch, wir haben dann auch immer von virtuellen Globus im Maßstab eins zu eins gesprochen, ja, weil Karten hast du halt immer ja den Maßstab, aber sagen, unser Globus war halt im Maßstab eins zu eins, wenn man so.
Okay, das heißt, das war dreiundneunzig. Und wie lange hat es dann noch gedauert, bis ihr da auch wirklich jetzt ein Projekt draus gemacht habt und gesagt habt, jetzt jetzt bauen wir das auch, jetzt brauchen wir ja auch Geld dafür.
Ja, also es ging,
Ich glaube, es ging relativ fix, also nachdem wir das hatten, weiß noch, habe ich dann, glaube ich, einen Projektantrag geschrieben, habe dann mit der Telekom äh geredet. Wie gesagt, wir hatten zu dem Zeitpunkt schon,
ganze Menge Projekte für die gemacht oder am am Laufen, also im Medizinbereich und Architekturvisualisierung. Ach ja, wir hatten,
glaube ich, weiß gar nicht, zu welcher Zeit das dann äh war, ob vor oder ich glaube, das war sogar noch vor Terrorvision. Hat mir auch einen Architekturentwurf fürs Regierungsviertel.
Und waren auch als an dem Wettbewerb beteiligt, wie denn das Regierungsviertel zukünftig aussehen soll, wo 880 Architekten eingereicht hatten, so Wettbewerbsentwürfe.
Artkommen hat, glaube ich, mit Platz 15 auch noch einen Ankauf gekriegt. Also unser Entwurf ist sozusagen auch dann von der
Bundesregierung angekauft worden als eine mögliche Variante, äh was dann dort äh äh gebaut wird, was ich auch also nur so,
auch so ein Ding äh nebenbei ja Art kommt, äh paar Architekten beteiligen sich mal eben äh sagen an der Neugestaltung des Regierungsviertels
Wir haben dann den Gewinnerentwurf visualisiert auch in der VR und unseren äh Entwurf und das Jetzt und das haben wir dann auch auf der,
dann Helmut Kohl mit der Pappbrille äh und so wurde dann.
Ziemlich durch den Kakao gezogen, als er sich das angeguckt hatte, somit irgendwie sieht rot grün und er ähm.
Aber.
Stimmt.
Also es war schon, fand ich, fand ich schon äh ja ähm bemerkenswert damals auch immer Kohl ist auch mehr also zu mehreren Anlässen äh weil wegen Telekom natürlich ähm.
Ja, hat er das zu sehen,
gekriegt oder oder Kanzlern vorgeführt und vorgezeigt, weil die waren halt,
immer spektakulär und und gut anzuschauen.
So, das heißt, ihr seid zu Telekom gegangen, hat gesagt, hier wir wollen so einen virtuellen Globus bauen, wir haben hier mal so eine tolle Idee und ähm gibt auch mal Geld und das haben die dann gemacht. Und dann ging's los. Aber das Ziel war halt, das auch dann zu zeigen.
Also ich glaube, das war von vorne herein, dass ich dann sagte, äh so, ja, wir hätten hier so eine Idee und dann hieß es, ja, wir haben halt irgendwie ein Budget für die, für für Kyoto, äh so, da wollen wir gerne was
machen und äh ja. Und weil die halt gute Erfahrungen mit uns äh gemacht hatten, äh bis dato immer äh,
so haben die halt gesagt, ja, macht mal.
Wenn du jetzt sagst, wir.
Wer Wahlen das dann äh konkret, wie groß war denn jetzt dieses Team, was sich um dieses Projekt gekümmert hat? Weil im Film sind ja im Wesentlichen zwei Leute plus diverse Teamzuarbeiter äh im Fokus.
Ja, also auf.
IT-Seite, ja, waren's halt im Wesentlichen Achsel und ich und weiß noch, Henrik hat auch ein bisschen äh mitgemacht zu dem Zeitpunkt, glaube ich, mit dem ähm.
So äh ja schon sagen.
Plus Gerd, der sich dann um die Daten gekümmert hat, also es kommt so ungefähr hin, da so eine Handvoll Leute am Anfang.
Vier, fünf, sechs Leute so in der Größenordnung, die jetzt speziell an Terrorvisionen gearbeitet äh haben, der.
Rest hat halt an anderen Projekten gearbeitet. Also war nicht so, dass das jetzt das einzige Projekt zu dem Zeitpunkt.
War das Artcon gemacht hätte, aber es ist und es ist und Artcom in dem Sinne ist jetzt auch nicht extra für Terrorvision gegründet worden, wobei auf der anderen Seite durch diesen Vollaut, der da passiert ist, mit mit Bannmaht, ist es dann doch.
Prinzip, also die Art kommt Firma, ist dann tatsächlich zeitgleich oder oder während Terrorvision oder für Terrorvision, um das weitermachen zu können, gegründet worden. Also insofern ja, passt das, aber ähm.
Das war jetzt hier die Anspielung auch den.
Die Einspielung auf den Film, ja ja.
Die Story so war. Aber da gehen wir dann später drauf ein, um das nicht zu sehr zu äh vermengen. Aber es war auf jeden Fall schon so, dass Terrorvision dann auch irgendwie,
ein bedeutendes Projekt geworden äh ist, relativ schnell. Und wenn du sagst, Kyoto, damit war halt gemeint,
das große äh Treffen der Post und Telekommunikations ähm Behörden muss man ja fast sagen, äh weltweit, wie wie hieß das nochmal?
IT
Das ITU-Treffen, genau, also in der IT User, die ja alle zusammengeschlossen und da stand eben dann für 1994 an und da treffen die sich halt immer und zeigen sich gegenseitig wer die Geilsten sind und wollen halt immer schön scheinen
scheinen die Objekts haben. Damit sie das irgendwie ihren äh Regierungsfürsten vorstellen können, damit sie auch weiterhin viel Kohle bekommen.
Ja, also im Wesentlichen äh aber über technische Standards äh geredet äh und,
aber ja, natürlich die großen äh Protagonisten oder großen Player äh dort jetzt kommerziell äh waren halt ATNT aus den USA,
aus Japan und die deutsche Telekom aus Deutschland die waren so sagen von allen nationalen Telekommunikations,
Gesellschaften so dort am prominentesten vertreten mit irgendwie in einer Show, ja.
Und äh wir haben tatsächlich irgendwie allen die Show,
gestohlen, als es dann endlich lief. Und es war nicht so, dass wir losgeflogen sind aus Deutschland und immer noch einen Back hatten, der das Ding so nach 30 bis 60 Sekunden crashen
und wir hatten zu dem Zeitpunkt noch eine eine Start-up-Zeit, weil wir dann doch ein paar Indizes vorgeladen haben von mehreren Minuten
das Ding halt nicht wirklich präsentierbar gemacht hätte, wenn es drei, vier Minuten starten zum Starten äh braucht, aber nach dreißig Sekunden Absturz kannst du damit jetzt keine gute Show machen. Und den hatten wir dann tatsächlich noch in der Nacht.
Vorher gefixt gekriegt, so dass das System dann 'ne Viertelstunde, zwanzig Minuten stabil lief und damit.
Wir dann die Show machen und ja, haben wirklich allen die Show gestohlen. Es war auch äh wirklich so, dass,
Telekom war super pisst, weil es nicht halt nicht funktionierte und auf dem Flug hin und wenn sie gekonnt hätten, hätten sie es alles gecancelt. Aber wir hatten jetzt natürlich schon Hotel und Flüge und Reisen und den Standplatz. Und es war halt alles schon
gebucht äh so, so dass sie dann halt sagten, okay, ja, es geht es ist sparen tun wir jetzt sowieso nichts. Jetzt müssen wir aber durch, aber,
haben uns halt dann weitgehend irgendwie gemieden und nichts mit uns zu tun haben, dann weil und befürchteten jetzt alle auch äh das jetzt Ärger kriegen und ihre Karriere und.
So und äh ja, dann aber lief, wie gesagt, der erste Tag so, dass dann vor allem,
halt die ganzen äh äh Politiker und eben aber auch die Chefs von ATNT und NT halt die meiste Zeit äh mit,
Verbracht haben und gar nicht auf ihrem eigenen äh äh Stand und so und die
Kontrolloffiziere waren irgendwie von den ganzen äh äh politischen, wenn man halt verzweifelt, weil die Leute halt nicht weg wollten, so die ganzen Honorationen und und abends waren wir dann wieder die besten Freunde so,
stolz super.
Okay, dann muss ich ja zu dem Zeitpunkt, ich bin ja dann
später auch so einer der äh Terranauten äh geworden und habe äh das System auf Messen äh gezeigt, auch mal auf der CBD an anderen Orten und äh auch oft
bei Art kommen, wenn so Gäste da waren, war das ja eigentlich immer so der Knaller, großer, äh schöner Präsentationsraum, den wir dort hatten. Man ging da rein und dann war da so eine Leinwand, die quasi die gesamte Breitseite der einen Wand äh einnahm, beziehungsweise vor den Fenstern so äh herunterrollte, ganz dramatisch,
zwei dicken, fetten Röhrenbeamern. Das war so damals die Technik, mit der man noch arbeiten musste, die schön kalibriert waren, also auch alles sehr schön scharf eingestellt haben. Und wenn man dann einfach Leuten ähm
jetzt mal was äh gezeigt hat, das war einfach für für viele.
Ähm ein Schock. Also es ist äh es es war wirklich der totale Future Schock vor allem, wenn man nicht genau vorher angekündigt hat, was jetzt eigentlich wirklich kommt. So und dann hast du diesen komplett dunklen Raum.
Und das finde ich ist jetzt sehr, sehr wichtig und hier kommt dieses Plus auch nochmal zum Spiel, ne? Deswegen hatte ich das vorhin auch so betont, diese Werkstatt hat,
für Terrorvision, für diesen virtuellen Globus. Der, wenn ihr jetzt immer noch nicht verstanden habt, was eigentlich dieses Programm wirklich macht, im Wesentlichen so ist wie Google Earth,
beziehungsweise Google Earth ist dann eigentlich später so geworden wie Terrorvision, also eine komplette Visualisierung in Echtzeit, wo man rumfliegen kann der Erde.
Und um das Ding zu bedienen und jeder weiß, wie problematisch das ist, wenn man so Google Earth versucht, mit der Tastatur zu bedienen oder mit der Maus zu bedienen. Es.
Ja, ist einfach, es macht einfach keinen Spaß und viele Leute verbringen wenig Zeit mit dieser Software, äh weil sie sich einfach so nicht bedienen lässt. Man braucht dafür ein anderes User-Interface. Und das war euch ja auch klar,
Und was dabei herauskam war, du hast vorhin schon kurz erwähnt, der Earth Tracker und der Earth Tracker ist im Wesentlichen ein dicker, eine dicke fette Kugel.
Messer, was war das? Halber Meter.
Also äh ja schon also zwischen 80 Zentimetern und 1 50 hatten wir verschiedene Größen, also für die die Wall Street warten wir einen großen äh äh noch. Aber so ja, einen Meter ungefähr Durchmess.
Also ein dickes, fettes Teil, wo man so ordentlich die Hand drauflegen konnte und das wog auch irgendwie, was war so schön rund geschliffen, allein sowas schon mal hinzubekommen. Ist ja eine auf äh ein Aufwand. Ähm
Und das lagerte eben auf so Rollen, das heißt, man konnte diese Kugel beliebig herumrollen und zwei dieser Rollen waren aber im Prinzip umgedrehte Mäuse.
Ja, Trackballs oder umgedrehte Mäuse, ja. Mhm.
So, das heißt, in dem Moment, wo man diese Kugel auf diesen Rollen irgendwo hindrehte.
Konnte man quasi an zwei Orten, die X und Y Bewegung messen.
Und daraus lässt sich dann eben die tatsächliche dreidimensionale Bewegung, in Echtzeit dieser Kugel.
Weil normaler Trackball äh ist halt nur, äh ich sage mal X Y ist
zweidimensional, den kannst du nicht äh so sagen, wenn du den den einen Trackball um die vertikale Achse drehst, äh so wirst du keinerlei
Informationen über die Drehung, über die Vertikale Achse, aber dadurch, dass wir halt sagen, zwei hatten, konnten wir das dann äh äh rausrechnen und sagen, die Drehung um alle Achsen
vernünftig ermitteln, aber das war halt schon ganz schön nervig, das richtig hinzukriegen sozusagen aus zwei
XY Trackball Information, dann ähm sagen die korrekte Drehung rauszurechnen, weiß ich noch, da haben wir
wochenlang uns äh.
Ist das nicht eine relativ einfache mathematische Geschichte?
Theorie, ja, theoretisch, ja, aber in der Praxis hast du es dann irgendwie auch noch mit Schlupf zu tun und äh wie du das dann, ja, also es war, also es
Es hat eine Weile gedauert, äh bis äh das dann so funktionierte, wie wir das theoretisch hatten, weil du musst halt dann auch genau,
sagen, auch die Position der der Trackballs und den den Winkel, wo die wirklich sitzen in deinen Berechnungen, mit einfließen lassen und äh ja.
Also es war ein weiß ich noch.
Eine Aufgabe für sich. Aber ein geiles Interface so, aber wir sind ja noch gar nicht fertig. Also es war natürlich dann.
Immer der magische Moment. Man sieht so die Kugel auf dem Bildschirm und denkt sich so, ja okay, Bild von der Erde.
Was kann schon passieren? Ist auch ein Film schön eingefangen worden, dieser Moment. Man legt dann so seine Hand auf diese Kugel, dreht die irgendwie so ein bisschen und in dem Moment, dreht sich die Kugel auf dem Bildschirm einfach genauso. Und das ist so ein Interface.
Das versteht man einfach sofort. Also da muss man einfach niemandem irgendwas erklären. Das ist einfach 1zu1 die deine Bewegung im Raum.
Dieser Kugel wird äh unmittelbar auf das Objekt, was auf dem Bildschirm zu sehen ist, umgesetzt. Das versteht jeder und das ist einfach das ist dann so so der erste Schock,
Also allein das war schon mal irgendwie Schock genug, obwohl,
eigentlich erstmal nicht sehr viel mehr passiert, als dass sie eben so eine Kugel dreht. Ne, könnte man sagen, ja, okay, interessante Tech-Demo, super für eine Kunst äh Messe und so weiter, äh kann man auch vielleicht äh irgendwo noch einen Preis äh gewinnen, aber an sich ging das so.
Über dieser Kugel, schwebte aber jetzt noch so ein Arm und dadrauf war und ich glaube, es kam vom DLR.
DLR Space Maus.
Die DLR Space. Wie seid ihr denn an die geraten, gab's die schon länger? Das ist so quasi so ein.
Ja, wir hatten es.
Rollinstrument für 3D-Anwendungen.
Es gab davon auch Vorläufer, die wir irgendwie äh die also es wir hatten.
Welche für andere äh Zwecke und äh also wir kannten sagen diese äh diese Technologie äh äh schon, weil wir ja generell drei D gemacht haben und haben die dann äh dort eben integriert.
Genau, das war halt dann die geile Kombination, weil dann legt man halt einfach den Finger drauf auf so einen kleinen, runde äh Scheibe
Die man ganz gut so in in der Hand halten kann und die liest sich halt nach vorne, nach hinten drücken und schieben und im Prinzip konnte man halt in jede beliebige Richtung irgendeine Interaktion machen.
Aber man konnte halt auch gleichzeitig noch mit der anderen Hand diesen bedienen. Und das war, das hatte schon was Majestätisches, weil es konnte man eben durch das Schieben
Maus und durch das Drehen der Space Moors auf einmal einen Flug beginnen auch quasi
tauchen nach unten drücken, dabei, bei Bedarf eben auch noch so die Erde dadrunter äh durch rotieren lassen und dann im Prinzip jede beliebige Richtung in jeder beliebigen
Geschwindigkeit mit jedem beliebigen Blickwinkel einnehmen
und das ist dann schon so der Moment gewesen, wo die Leute äh wirklich angefangen haben, schwer zu atmen, weil das äh da explodierte es halt einfach im Hirn, weil es gab nichts Vergleichbares da draußen, also keinen
System hat war in der Lage und dann vor allem auch noch die tatsächliche Welt so anzuzeigen und man konnte halt wirklich bis auf die Erde herunter äh fliegen bis in die Gebäude hinein.
Und ich weiß noch das Rausfliegen so auf dieser Beamer Leinwand, das hat mir regelmäßig, obwohl ich das kannte, es hat mir einfach jedes Mal die Schuhe ausgezogen, habe jedes Mal äh äh eine Gänsehaut gekriegt nach Jahren noch, wenn ich so diesen.
Ins ins All äh äh nach oben äh raus und irgendwann hatten wir auch den den Mond noch äh mit mit drin äh im.
Später und.
Also wir hatten dann so viele Sachen äh drin. Wir hatten das Gravitationsfeld der Erde. Wir hatten sämtliche Erdbeben, Wann und wo die auf,
waren. Wir hatten die Ozondaten, wir hatten natürlich sowieso äh äh Cloud-Daten, wir hatten,
Wetterdaten, wir hatten Klimasimulations äh äh Daten.
Ja, all die Dinger, wir hatten Populationsdichten, ähm also wir hatten allein schon so viele Layer äh äh drin plus halt, dass du,
tatsächlich sogar auch in Innenräume gehen konnte. Das sind so Sachen, was mit Google Earth bis heute nicht.
Und tatsächlich, ich meine.
Mal vorwegzunehmen, weshalb ich wirklich sauer bin äh eigentlich auf Google ist gar nicht jetzt diese diese ich sage mal Plagiatsgeschichte, äh nenne ich, nenne ich mal, äh sondern.
Sie es nicht besser.
In den letzten zwanzig Jahren, äh seit sie das von Michael gekauft haben, ist nichts Wesentliches dazugekommen, ja? Sie haben's jetzt irgendwie alles
hübscher und schneller gemacht und für für verschiedene Devices äh und so, wobei das jetzt auch keine Kunst so ein so ein iPhone von heute ist
sage mal, hundertmal so leistungsfähig wie unsere oder zehnmal so leistungsfähig wie unsere Reality Engine von von damals mindestens, ja.
Und nee, das geht mir halt aufn Zeiger, dass äh und sagen äh Google, klar, auf der einen Seite haben sie es verfügbar gemacht und sie haben halt im Wesentlichen haben sie aber mir nur.
Daten äh äh mehr Daten gekauft, aber selbst da ist ich meine, es gibt keinen einzigen Baum in Google Earth bis heute nicht.
Du hast halt Satellitenbilder, die dann aussehen wie Wälder. Aber guck dir also, guck dir einfach mal jetzt auch noch den Vergleich zwischen Google Earth und Microsoft Flight Simulator an.
Das wäre eigentlich, wo Google Earth seit fünf oder zehn Jahren mindestens visuell hätte sein müssen, da wo Microsoft Flight-Seminator äh heute ist. Ja, sie haben einfach sagen den.
Und diese Technologie hat man wirklich für so viele andere Dinge einfach noch nutzen können, ja.
Aber außer, dass da mehr Daten äh drin sind und das jetzt auf mehr Devices läuft und uns sie irgendwie Städtelabels.
Haben, ja? Also Prinzipdaten.
Ist da jetzt ist das nicht aufregender als vierundneunzig? Ja, also dreißig, dreißig Jahre, ja.
Also Bäume haben sie, glaube ich, mittlerweile es gibt so einen Baum leer, den man irgendwie anschalten kann und manchmal machen sie da auch so Bäume, also so ein Baumdetektor haben sie schon äh eingebaut.
Habe ich nicht. Also ich habe, hatte gestern immer irgendwie geguckt.
Nicht überall und es ist auch alles so unfertig. Also es ist äh es ruckelt auch noch teilweise wirklich lächerlich. Äh.
Die die Farbkorrekturen, die sie, die sie auf den Satellitenpatches äh machen, ist nicht toll, ja, das hatte ich vor äh also unser automatischer
ich sage mal Farb
Interpulator und Farbanpassung. Ich meine, es ist nicht ganz einfach, aus den verschiedenen Quellen. Du kriegst halt sieben kanadige Landssat-Daten, die du dann irgendwie umrechnen musst und so. Und manchmal sind die unterschiedlicher Sonnenstand und so, aber,
das kann man also das haben wir vor alles vor 20 Jahren einfach viel besser äh äh.
Schon gemacht oder vor 30 Jahren besser gemacht als jetzt Google, ich sag mal mit der Technologie der Manpower und und dem Geld was sie da einsetzen ist es zwar, ich sag mal ja es ist irgendwie 'nen
solides Museumsstück, äh was sie da online haben aus meiner Sicht, ja. Da ist ja, das ist einfach, ja, das ist das ist halt schade,
dass man damit.
Es passiert auch irgendwie nix. Also es ist äh gibt kaum Updates, es ist ähm dümpelt so vor sich hin und klar ist es jetzt irgendwie in Google Maps irgendwie mit eingebaut. Also sie haben das jetzt auch im Webbrowser. Also insofern ist da schon bisschen was passiert, aber so als
Lösungen selber, wo man noch sehr viel mehr machen könnte, vor allem in der Visualisierung von ganz anderen Daten.
Ja, weiß ich nicht, ob sie jetzt im Hintergrund schon irgendwie an dem großen Update äh arbeiten, was sie dann irgendwann mal nach fünf Jahren Arbeit rausknallen, aber eigentlich ist das ja gar nicht so ihre Art.
Es bewegt sich auch nichts. Es ist, ich meine, diese einzige aktuelle Datens der Wolkenlayer und den hatten wir halt in Kyoto auch schon in Echtzeit aktualisiert, ja?
Und das hat die äh vor 25 Jahren vor 8undzwanzig
so deswegen. Also deswegen bin ich pisst halt, weil sie auf der einen Seite ja, haben sie allen anderen mehr oder weniger äh die Möglichkeit genommen, mit sowas Geld zu verdienen, weil wenn Google, ich sage mal, das Ganze,
kostenlos online stellt, also sie haben dafür für uns auch den Markt komplett ruiniert.
Ja, also alle Versuche äh von uns in dem Moment, wo sie dann mit Google Earth draußen waren, konnten wir halt auch äh äh tatsächlich jetzt,
einpacken äh äh so, weil,
Ja, du kannst, ich mein, vorher gab's halt durchaus Business äh Modelle, die hätten funktionieren können, aber in dem Moment, ja, wo Google sagt, hier und äh es äh ja, wir hätten auch mit Michael äh äh also.
Michael.
Wirst du jetzt mal auf die Story äh kommen, wie wie Google das sozusagen überhaupt zugekommen ist. Vielleicht steigen wir damit an der Stelle äh mal ein. Also, ihr habt Terrorvisionen gebaut,
Es funktionierte dann in Kyoto, die Begeisterung war groß, ihr seid dann auch, glaube ich, äh,
gut rumgereicht worden, auf Choreografik äh Konferenzen et cetera. Das war ja schon dann eins der herausragenden äh Items eigentlich.
Zeit.
Wir haben auf der präsentiert, der größten irgendwie Grafik äh äh Konferenz hatten wir's aufgebaut mit irgendwie,
unglaublichen äh äh Feedback. Wir sind vor allem in Amerika oder fast nur in Amerika mit Preisen äh überschüttet äh worden. So einmal einer Konferenz, den wir den sogenannten
Impact Award, den haben sie dann extra für uns noch geschaffen so, weil das so reingehauen hat, haben wir den Impact Award äh gekriegt,
aber am geilsten war tatsächlich, als die ACM uns da in die zu ihrer 50-Jahr-Feier uns äh in die.
Einfach so 'ne Liste der 50 wichtigsten Innovationen oder Erfindungen des Computerzeitalters und.
Da sind wir halt mit drin aufgetaucht so.
Ist die.
1947, glaube ich, gegründet äh worden, also die größte Informatiker Berufsvereinigung, ja? Und es war jetzt nicht so, dass wir irgendwie
jetzt äh irgendwelche ACM Connections gehabt hätten und da irgendwie im Hintergrund uns nach vorne gemauselt hätten, sondern wir waren halt da haben sich halt Leute, ja.
Hingesetzt nach der größten Informatikerorganisation und haben gesagt, wow, das ist so geil, das ist so abgefahren.
Wie heißt diese Liste? Liste von.
Äh ja, das war irgendwie Liste der, der, der, der 50 einflussreichsten Erfindungen des Computerzeitalters,
Ich hatte neulich mal versucht, irgendwie die ausfindig zu machen, also zu der anlässlich der fünfzig Jahr Feier, äh aber ich habe sie so auf Anhieb nicht gefunden, weil das war halt auch noch Mitte äh Ende der äh also
Mitte Ende der Neunziger, da war alles noch nicht so richtig äh wie wie heutzutage, aber irgendwo.
Sich das und ja wenn man auch.
Überhaupt nicht vorbereitet äh äh auf auf diesen äh ganzen äh Rummel, aber es war ja, ich meine, das ist ja selber miterlebt. Es war einfach,
Überall, wo man
präsentiert hat, die Begeisterung, egal ob Kinder oder ältere Leute oder Honorationen oder also alle waren irgendwie begeistert. Äh es hat allen Freude gemacht und mal gar nicht
aber irgendwann fing uns das allen natürlich auch an zum Hals rauszuhängen so, aber
so die die ersten Jahre äh waren einfach äh super, ja mit letztlich die Welt bereist und sind halt mit Lob und Anerkennung überschüttet worden. Es war halt.
War halt schon toll. Ja,
Aber okay und eines dieser, wir wollten jetzt auf den Punkt so, wie ist das denn jetzt was für eine Google Connection? Gibt's da jetzt.
Genau, dir erstmal eine Connection vor allem mit Silikon Graphics war.
Genau, es war, es war dann auch so, dass wir dann auch äh dann bei Silicon Graphics das präsentiert haben, beziehungsweise
die das auch kannten auf verschiedenen Wegen, weil wir uns deren Maschinen auch äh gerne geliehen hatten. Das heißt, die Vertriebsleute kannten uns und haben uns geholfen, so Leihgeräte zu kriegen in allen Teilen der Welt. Ich weiß nicht, auch in Moskau und so. Also die haben uns halt auch
unterstützt und waren halt begeistert und haben dann auch eine Version,
Terrorvision, also wir haben das dann in deren Showroom in Mountainview auch installiert, so eine.
Silicon Graphics muss man dazu noch sagen. Gibt's mittlerweile nicht mehr, die äh Firma, ne, in der Form. Also ist aufgekauft worden von Wetti noch mal gekauft. Sun, glaube ich, oder?
Ja, ich weiß, äh, äh, gar nicht, aber die hemden sich dann erstmal in SGI umbenannt,
so und ich weiß gar nicht, äh wem die jetzt gehören, aber jetzt die sind halt ein Haufen Leute, sind halt auch zu NVIA ab.
Packert hat die am Schluss übernommen. Ja, ja. Mhm. Sechzehn.
Ja und die haben sich im Prinzip äh äh wiederum ähm.
Ja, ein bisschen mit der, mit der Fusion, dann äh mit ähm Laden nochmal, den sie dann aufgekauft hatten.
Ähm wo sie dann fusioniert.
Cray, genau. Die haben sich an dem äh genau, die haben sich äh letztlich an dem an dem äh haben sie sich übernommen, wenn man so will und äh weil es bei Cray auch nochmal eine ganz andere Vergütungsstruktur war und,
Graphics war auch kein Start-up. Das war halt eine Computerfirma.
Ähm die halt jetzt zwar eigentlich den Fehler gemacht haben meiner Sicht irgendwann,
zu kaufen und sich nicht hinreichend zu kanibalisieren äh als dann die PCs kamen. Also sie SGI hätte NVIDIA sein können.
Mhm. Waren sie aber nicht. Aber trotzdem, sie waren halt damals sozusagen die die definierende Firma in dem Bereich drei D.
Ja, sie waren einfach mal also sie hatten halt einfach die größten und schnellsten Rechner mit äh Graphik beschleunigung. Und äh ja darunter eben dann die ONICS Reality Engine.
Die halt ja ähm.
Mitte der 90er würde ich sagen ungefähr so viel konnte, wie einen PC, zehn Jahre später.
Also.
Und zehn Jahre sind in der Computerentwicklung. Ja. Eine Menge.
Also wir konnten sozusagen mit den SGIs äh so will's den den PC von 2005 oder so. Den PC von in zehn Jahren
ähm voraussehen und damals ging's auch noch noch deutlich schneller. Die Entwicklung ist ja also kannst du jetzt heute mit einem zehn Jahre alten PC äh.
Kannst du immer noch noch arbeiten, aber 205 äh wolltest du halt von fünfundneunzig.
Nichts mehr sehen.
Nix mehr sehen, ja. Das war irgendwie sowas von, ja. Es gab keine äh äh Grafikbeschleunigung, es gab äh keine hochauflösende Farbe, nicht mal. Also es war halt entweder, weiß ich nicht, sechs vierzig, vier achtzig, VGA.
Halt so die Auflösung äh die Standardauflösung und dann also nee. Dunkle Zeiten. So, jedenfalls.
Äh war halt.
Kommt man halt zehn Jahre mit in die Zukunft gucken äh mit diesen mit diesen Maschinen und,
Ja und SGI war halt einfach begeistert natürlich auch von von Terror und Michael, die.
Jones äh leitete äh damals die Performer SGI Performer äh.
Entwicklung und Performer war so eine 3D Library, um äh lässt sich 3DSimulatoren,
zu schreiben, wenn du so willst. Die hat einem dann so eine Menge bereitgestellt, schon mal bestimmte Datenstrukturen und Synchronisationen zwischen Multi, also die ganze Wahl muss man sagen, auch noch Multiprozessor äh Maschinen, so dass man halt,
Ja damals noch viel Multis wird's dann später, aber eigentlich war's Multiprocessing mit Memory. Ähm.
Also mit mehreren Prozessoren gleichzeitig arbeiten konnte, was heute normal ist. Man kennt das, Computer haben einfach Kerne, genau.
Mehrere Kerne, genau. Genau und dieses Performer half einem so ein bisschen alle Kerne zu nutzen, sagen und das zur zeitlich ein bisschen zu verschränken.
Also eine Hilfsbibliothek für, ich sage mal, normale 3D Entwickler, die äh jetzt nicht wirklich bis äh auf den Transistor äh hinab äh steigen und alles äh verstanden haben, sondern die einfach so
eine Lösung haben wollen, sagen hallo, ich bin eine App, ich würde ganz gerne mal drei D machen, was kannst du mir denn so bereitstellen und das hat diese Bibliothek gemacht und dafür war Michael T-Jones.
Genau. Ja, die, die das Interface war damals GL, der Vorläufer von Open GA. Aber es war noch nicht Open äh zu dem Zeitpunkt und dann sagen und Performer machte eben dann die notwendigen GL,
Calls äh größtenteils für einen und es gab dann halt Demos und es war halt vor allem aber auf,
Echtzeit ausgerichtet. Es gab noch andere Tool-Kits, aber die waren jetzt nicht so auf,
Echtzeit, also eine konstante Framerate und so ausgerichtet, äh wie man's eher für Simulatoren brauchte, sondern für andere Dinge wie jetzt drei D Editing und äh gab's dann noch äh andere.
Systeme wie Inventor war beispielsweise ein anderes Ding, da konnte man sich auch so drei D äh Sachen zusammenklicken sogar, aber es war halt nicht so performant.
Der richtige Name so und Michael war halt Chef von der von der Performancegruppe, daher hatten wir ihn auch kennengelernt, weil der immer
Meeting irgendwie Graf und
da hat er dann immer Veranstaltungen gemacht und erzählt, was so Zukunft von Performer jetzt bringen wird und weil wir das auch benutzt haben, war natürlich immer gut so World of Maus, was hat jetzt der sozusagen Chef und Guru
der dafür verantwortlich ist, jetzt zu sagen, was was kommt und was nicht.
Daher kam halt die Verbindung und dann, als wir es im Showroom installiert haben, so äh ja,
hat er uns dann auch da noch äh eingeladen und uns eben auch äh ja die neue Bitterversion äh gegeben und uns erzählt und wir haben halt sehr viel,
dann tatsächlich drüber gequatscht und was.
Das war jetzt so neunzehnhundertfünfundneunzig.
97 wahrscheinlich gewesen,
in der Gegend vielleicht auch fünfundneunzig, also ist ja, wann wir, äh wann wir es genau, äh aber ich, ja, ich glaube,
95 könnte es gewesen sein, dass wir das damals lagen die Sachen irgendwie echt eng beieinander. Zeitlich so ja.
Für uns war's jetzt nun auch äh ja kein Ding. Ich meine äh hat sich gefreut, mein SCI hat Rechner verkauft,
und keine Softwareanwendungen, beziehungsweise wenn äh war's halt eher zu sagen, Vertriebspartner äh für uns, deswegen gab's da jetzt auch keinen Grund,
Irgendwie großartig zu befürchten. Das jetzt ist GI uns da irgendwas.
Cloud unbedingt, obwohl die haben wir nicht dagelassen äh und.
Aber ihr seid da hingefahren, habt Terravisionen, mal installiert, so zur zur Demonstration. Die hatten wahrscheinlich zu dem Zeitpunkt auch schon davon gehört. Aber ist noch nicht gesehen.
Genau, das war vereinbart, ne, die hatten es teilweise schon auf Messen äh äh gesehen und wir hatten dann vereinbart mit denen vorher, oh ähm
Ja äh wollte das nicht bei uns im Showroom installieren und hatten dann die Voraussetzungen, glaube ich, auch dafür geschaffen, irgendwie genug Festplatten beschafft und wir haben denen, glaube ich, dann sogar einen äh da gelassen äh und so, dass die das halt dann.
Dort in ihrem Showroom vorführen konnten.
Also nicht nur einmal, sondern über einen längeren Zeitraum.
Längeren Zeitraum, ich weiß nicht, dass es da bestimmt sechs mindestens sechs Monate wahrscheinlich über,
zwei Jahre oder so als Demo äh im im Showroom gelaufen auf jeden Fall bei SGI und ähm ja. Wir hatten dann auch.
Gar nicht so viel Kontakt äh mit mit Michael unbedingt,
Deswegen, weil er hat sein Performer gemacht und wir haben unsers äh gemacht, wobei eine lustige Anekdote war noch, als er dann.
Später.
Viel später irgendwie fast zehn Jahre später dann bei uns war und schon bei Google war, hat er uns damals erzählt, dass er halt.
Ähm verschiedene Features äh unter anderem so Texter-Paging in Performer eingebaut hat, weil er das bei Terror gesehen hat.
Wir wussten aber damals nichts davon und dachten, nur als es plötzlich dann in Performer auftauchte, dachten wir,
verdammter Mist, hätten wir jetzt äh das gewusst, dass der das demnächst äh auch ein Textur-Paging in Parfüm einbaut, hätten wir ja gar nicht unser eigenes Textur-Pating für Performer schreiben müssen,
so während äh erst dann später erzählt hat, ja äh nachdem ich euer Texting äh gesehen habe, musste ich das dann gleich unbedingt auch in Performer äh äh.
Also es war eine Inspirationsquelle.
Einbauen. Es war definitiv ja äh eine eine Inspirationsquelle und es war halt auch so, ich meine, aus heutiger Sicht, wenn man da drin steckt.
Das jetzt gar nicht unbedingt so schwierig vor nachdem man das halt gelöst,
hatte alles, aber es waren schon, es hatte schon ein bisschen was vom Ei des des Kolumbus, weil bevor man das nicht gesehen hatte, hat man das nicht für möglich gehalten, dass es überhaupt geht.
Kannst du das nochmal beschreiben, was da die technische Herausforderungen war in dem Teil? Also was was war da jetzt sozusagen so speziell daran?
Na ja, war halt, dass du ganz viele Dinge einfach zusammenbringen musstest, aufeinander abgestimmt. Du
braucht es die Daten, du brauchtest einen schnellen Zugriff auf die Daten im richtigen Format und die zu.
Also wir reden jetzt über über das Feature, was.
Diesen Textur Pager.
Also dieses effiziente von den von den Pixeldaten auf der Platte, die auch wirklich schnell und effizient auf dem Bildschirm.
Ja, ja, ja, ja. Wer, äh, das war dann im, im Wesentlichen, ähm, also, waren, waren mehrere Dinge, äh, du musstest sie im richtigen Format und in der richtigen Unterteilung äh, bereit,
stellen. Ähm du musst es dann, weil das halt äh war, du musst es halt höllisch aufpassen, dann,
der Synchronisation und dem dem Loking, wann du irgendwie welche Texturen dann äh wieder löscht äh und so und ja, es war halt ziemlich fummelig. Und damit du die schnell hochladen kannst
musstest du sie auch vorher nochmal
aufbereiten, je nachdem welchen Texturmodus musstest du halt das mit kombinieren, du musst es halt verhindern, dass der dass die Grafikkarte selber nochmal mit Maps berechnet, sondern in die mitunter also es war einfach nur,
Äh fummelig, so würde ich würde ich äh sagen, was jetzt das das Texter-Paging äh anging plus eine vernünftige Strategie dafür, welche Texturen man jetzt freigibt
und durch welche ersetzt so. Also es waren,
technisch fummelige Geschichten plus, wenn man der der übergeordnete Algorithmus und der Paging Algorithmus und das ganze Qing äh äh da drin, so das war halt.
Und jeder, der auch mal irgendwie Echtzeit, Multistrating äh äh gemacht hat,
auf und mit,
Direct Memory Excess durch Grafikkarten und andere die weiß es, kann sich ungefähr ausmalen.
Auf jeden Fall anspann.
Drin ist.
Okay, also dieses System lief bei Silicon Graphics in der Demo und für Terrorvision, das lief dann eigentlich so ein bisschen aus, kann man sagen, also.
Wir haben dann noch ich sag mal für die Telekom wir wollen dann natürlich auch viel rumgereicht unter anderem beim Börsengang haben wir wurden wir dann beauftragt mit dem Projekt Terrorvision einmal
aufzubauen mit einer riesigen Wand
und zeitgleich in Frankfurt äh vor der Börse und dann wurde halt mit Terror, sagen wir mal, zwischen Frankfurt und New York hin und her geflogen und äh das war so ein Ding,
und es kuliniert dann eigentlich äh der letzte große Auftrag von der Telekom, was Terror anging, war dann zur Expo zweitausend.
In Hannover, wo dann das System einmal dafür eingesetzt wurde.
Die Expo 2000 zu planen. Ähm die ganzen Pavillons äh wurden sobald die Pläne ja wurden reingepackt und so wurde halt im Vorfeld auch in den,
anderthalb, zwei Jahren vor der Expo wurde äh,
das System, wie gesagt, dafür genutzt, dann den Planungsstand äh zu kommunizieren zwischen allen Teilnehmern und,
wurde dann auch auf der Expo selbst dann im Pavillon gezeigt und wir hatten halt die gesamte Expo 2000 auch als Geometrie auf Terra mit den ganzen Hallen äh viele auch mit,
Innenräumen, sodass man bisschen dann, ja, quasi hat mir eine virtuelle Expo 200 mit Terrorvision gemacht. Das war.
Sagen, dass äh das größte Ding und dann war halt klar, wir brauchen halt eine PC-Version und wir haben dann auch noch einen.
Gemacht, allerdings unter Linox.
Weil es halt immer noch unter Performer äh lief und es kein Performer für Windows gab, beziehungsweise das das konnte halt nicht nicht so richtig viel,
und haben dann noch wiederum mit der PC-Version äh wiederum äh äh einen einen Projekt gemacht,
wo wir Troja das antike Troja noch visualisiert,
haben in Terrorvision, wo es dann auch noch, äh, wo Ubisoft zwischen auch noch eine CD rum von äh, äh, rausgebracht hat, mit anderer Technologie, also, da war.
Da ist dann noch einiges passiert. Ähm so, also es war nicht, war nicht komplett tot, aber es war so ein bisschen die die Luft äh auch raus und es hing uns auch allen dann irgendwann so ein bisschen zum zum Hals.
Raus und ähm haben dann,
Angefangene komplett neue technologische Basis auch zu entwickeln damals, äh die sich dann Y 60 nannte und dann von der Architektur her mehr wie einen
Browser aufgebaut war, äh also im Grunde genommen so eine Art Browser für 3 DähSzenen so, den haben wir dann entwickelt
So sagen die sechste Generation des 3D Rennrads, also in die Richtung ging das und wir hatten dann aber nie.
Wirklich, also bis zu dem Zeitpunkt, äh wo dann äh Google Earth rauskam, war's nicht wirklich.
Tod äh so, aber ähm ja.
Die Luft war ein bisschen, bisschen raus. So, aber wir hatten halt überlegt, okay, jetzt so ähm ja.
Man könnte, könnte noch was draus machen. So, das war äh.
Zu meiner Geschichte jetzt noch, ich bin halt 99 von Artcom weg, um dann die Firma Dango zu gründen.
Daraufhin ist dann auch der Großteil der Entwickler äh äh weg,
in alle möglichen Richtungen. Ein Teil hat ja dann Gate Five äh gegründet auch. Axel ist dann ja zu Gate Five
gegangen, wo dann heute jetzt sozusagen hier Technologies äh rausgeworden ist, der ist immer noch,
da, bei denen du sagst, es ist sozusagen dann mehr oder weniger im Bereich Geodaten äh äh geblieben und.
Ich meine tatsächlich, äh funktioniert auch, ach da ist also
war dann auch immer so, dass das hier dann auch so ein bisschen befürchtet hat gegen das Terrorpatent äh zu verstoßen, weil äh letztlich sie ist halt viele Dinge auch genau so gemacht haben in ihrer
Karten äh äh renderigen Software und so. Also äh ja.
Dann die Technologie von Terra ist dann in viele Richtungen äh gegangen, anderer Entwickler
so der an Terror beteiligt war, Mesh ist dann auch zu Google äh gegangen, äh allerdings hat er eher Maps äh gemacht äh so, aber.
Äh ja, die eigentliche.
Sagen die eigentliche Verbindungen aber war jetzt und das haben wir erst später mitbekommen bei ist dann auch der Kontakt zu SGI, weil er ist wurde auch immer weniger relevant für uns, ist dann eingeschlafen und was wir nicht wussten.
Äh ja Michael äh ist dann vom Chef der Performergruppe erstmal, das hat er mir dann später alles,
erzählt. Ähm ist dann äh zum CTO noch geworden, bevor er dann weggegangen ist und eine eigene Firma gegründet hat, Intrinsic Software, wo er im Prinzip nochmal sowas will, wie Performer,
Aber in neu äh für die Spieleindustrie hauptsächlich geschrieben hat, also dass dann auf der auch auf der PlayStation lief und auch auf PCs.
Und das lief dann aber nicht so richtig gut so.
Weil wir nur äh nur reiner Technologiezulieferer bis es immer schwierig, aber hätte dann mit dieser Software hatte er halt dann verschiedene Demos programmiert, unter anderem auch so eine Terra Demo.
Fand dann Anklang so bei Investoren, die sagten, ja irgendwie, ja, deine, sagen wir mal, Spielessoftware so, finden wir jetzt nicht so interessant, aber das mit der Erde,
finden wir.
Gut, da kann man noch eine ganze Menge draus machen und dann hat er halt Finanzierung äh bekommen von privaten Investoren für die Firma Keyhol,
Plus äh dann auch von. Das ist so der der Venture Capital Arm von der CIA.
Die haben ihm auch Geld gegeben und unter anderem hat der dann eben auch eine Version von Keyhole äh,
entwickelt, speziell für die Bedürfnisse, ja der CIA und deren Mapping Requests, so dass die die ganzen sagen, eine Spezialversion hatten, wo die ganzen geheimen äh da äh,
die hoch aufgelösten aus den Kieolsatelliten, die so fünf bis zehn Zentimeter Groundpixel Resolution äh äh haben, sagen.
Da hat er für die einen extra äh äh System eben auch gebaut und gemaint mit eben deren äh Daten, die sie dann auch entsprechend,
visualisieren konnten und ja und dann irgendwann hat Google davon äh Wind bekommen. Also.
Ja, es ist waren wohl tatsächlich dann die die Chefs, also irgendwie Larry.
Die das total geil fanden und dann gesagt haben, das müssen wir jetzt kaufen. Google war aber zu dem Zeitpunkt mitten im Börsengang.
Und konnte deswegen aus formalen Gründen konnten sie Keyhol nicht kaufen, sondern mussten einen machen,
Das heißt, es gab quasi eine Fusion, also Google hat nicht Keyhol gekauft, sondern fusioniert mit mit Keyhol, das fand ich irgendwie auch lustig, aber.
Und wir hatten vorher, glaube ich, Keyhol mal gesehen, aber fanden das jetzt nicht weiter.
Beunruhigend, weil das war halt ein ja, einen Dienst, mit dem man auch hätte in Wettbewerb äh äh treten können, muss das in der Regel bezahlen äh äh dafür, so das war.
Jetzt okay, irgendwo. Jetzt fand ich jetzt nicht nicht beunruhigend. Aber als dann plötzlich Google.
Keyhol gekauft hatte und plötzlich Google Earth in aller Munde war. So war für uns die Situation okay.
Äh hör mal irgendwie eigentlich alle vielleicht noch Hoffnungen oder Gedanken aus Terror irgendwie noch was zu machen, können wir halt beerdigen.
Können wir jetzt einfach mal abschreiben.
Weil willst du halt gegen einen kostenlosen Google Dienst irgendwo äh in Wettbewerb treten.
Zwar trotzdem noch äh äh.
Versucht dann auch äh sag mal mit mit Telekom Hilfe gab's dann auch noch Versuche jetzt Geld zu finden, unter anderem mit der aber die hat dann gesagt, nee, das äh.
Interessieren. Das war so um die zweitausend äh zweitausendeins.
Auch äh und nachdem dann Tventures gesagt hat, nee, äh da sehen wir keine Zukunft äh drin. War's halt äh ja,
auch Tod und viel ein großes Problem war auch mal mit der, warum ist es nicht gelungen, gerade in 2000, wo ja die irgendwie diese Bubble da war, eigentlich Investoren zu finden für,
äh Terrorvision, aus zum einen damit zu tun, dass nicht wirklich ein Start-Up war, sondern ganz anders,
aber das eigentliche Problem war, dass die Telekom niemand anderen mit drin haben wollte. Ich hatte halt verschiedene Pläne für Konsortien ausgearbeitet, wo Leute mitmachen wollten und Geld geben wollten, unter anderem äh und.
Paar andere Institutionen wollten mitmachen, ich glaube die DLR wollte mitmachen, weil für die DLR hatten wir nämlich unter anderem auch Teile von Terrorvision wiederum für eine Shuttle-Mission.
Bereit äh äh gestellt damals die SRTM äh äh Shuttle Raider topography äh mischen.
Ähm ja, aber am Ende war's halt die Telekom, die halt einerseits sich auf den Standpunkt gestellt hat, sie haben den Großteil dessen finanziert und haben im Grunde genommen auch.
Rechte und ähm ja äh also ohne Zustimmung der Telekom konnten wir jedenfalls niemanden
sonst reinholen und die haben im Grunde genommen alles abgelehnt und äh sagst, na ja, okay, wir machen das jetzt gegen die Telekom und die hätten uns dann verklagt äh oder so, kannst du auch vergessen, so. Das heißt,
letztlich, ja, war's weniger unsere Unfähigkeit äh als ich sage mal, der Unwille, auch der, der,
der Telekom ähm und zwar versucht dann auch so ein bisschen das System, aus deren Umarmung äh zu befreien einmal, was auch ein Stück weit
gelungen ist, weil wir dann Software auch für andere Sachen eingesetzt haben und die nicht nur mit Telekom Geld finanziert wurde, sondern ich hatte dann auch unter anderem Mercedes-Benz äh noch als Kunden äh gefunden, beziehungsweise Daimler,
für die wir auch eine ganze Menge gemacht hatten. Also.
Es es hätte viele Möglichkeiten gegeben, aber einerseits weil die Telekom sich ein bisschen zickig gezeigt hat, aber andererseits vor allem, weil Google mit Google Earth äh auf einmal so präsent war, war alles vorbei.
Und als dann genau und als dann Google Earth als Google Earth äh dann dann da war, war's halt äh ja, war's dann quasi sozusagen,
der Sankt Todesjahr doch irgendwie, also zumindest der Todesstoß für irgendwie das kommerziell äh zu äh entwickeln und.
Äh ja und dann äh ist es halt angeguckt und.
Waren dann auf zum einen natürlich so ein bisschen irgendwie.
Nicht so, nicht so begeistert davon, auf der anderen Seite natürlich super, dass es das jetzt auch für 'n für 'n PC gab und sie
'ne ganze Menge mehr, mehr Daten und so für dafür hatten, das das war gut und.
Was wir aber halt das einzige was wir noch hatten war letztlich das Patent. Und.
Was hat das abgedeckt.
Naja, das Patent hat im Wesentlichen.
Patent ist immer so aufgebaut, es enthält einmal einen Hauptanspruch und dann noch in der Regel eine ganze Menge abgeleitete Ansprüche. In der Hauptanspruch war.
Dieser Grundalgorithmus, wie man eben ähm,
Szene nimmt, wie man dann die Szene unterteilt und wie man dann die Daten äh welche Daten man dann anfordert und wie man die nachlegt. Also im Grunde genommen der, ich sage mal, Grundalgorithmus.
Plus dann mit einer ganzen Reihe mit Zusätzen, wie zum Beispiel äh des äh Koordinaten.
Spezielle Koordinatensystem, Transformation, was sie dann im Film Floating Coordinat System,
wo man dann im Prinzip das Koordinatensystem mit der Kamera mit Fliegen äh lässt, um in seiner Umgebung
irgendwelche Artifakte durch Fließkammerungenauigkeiten zu vermeiden, was sie sich denn so als Erdbeben manifestieren, dass jeder Frame, also die ganze Geometrie wackelt und äh wabert, das,
war auch ein Problem, was so in verschiedenen Spielen dann später aufgetreten ist, ähm so, wenn man sich zu weit entfernt hat vom Ursprung, dass dann die Geometrie anfing, so das hatten wir interra dann alles gelöst, plus,
ja, ich sage mal, noch ein Haufen,
anderer Zusatzansprüche, die sozusagen nochmal das verfeinert hatten. Also du versuchst halt einmal einen möglichst allgemeinen Anspruch zu haben und dann nochmal.
Abgeleitete Ansprüche davon die Nummer von dem System und was man machen kann und wenn wir das.
Patent heute durchliest, haben wir unter anderem in dem Patent auch äh.
Content Delivery Networks beschrieben, so wie sie dann später auch aufgetaucht äh sind, zu der zu.
Also verteilte Daten im Internet,
Das war ja auch so die die Grundidee, das haben wir ja auch drüber gesprochen, ne, so dieses wir müssen Breitband zeigen, ne, nur damals nannte man es halt nicht Internet und ich glaube, die Telekom selber hat das Internet als solches nicht äh ausreichend ernst genommen, um da diese Brücke schnell zu schlagen, aber diese
hochgradige
Verfügbarkeit von Daten, die an den unterschiedlichsten Orten gelagert sind und die in dem Moment, wo man sie braucht, äh erst zur Anwendung zu bringen, das ist im Prinzip,
das, was ja Terrorvisionen fast schon mit das erste Mal wirklich so gezeigt hat.
Ja genau, also unsere Idee ging halt auch mehr in die Richtung nicht, dass da ein System ist, was von einem Anbieter mit Daten befüllt wird und auf das alle zugreifen, sondern das ist halt ein System gibt,
Halt gewissen Standards genügt, wo es ein paar Basis äh leer,
gibt, äh in die man das Ganze einbindet, aber wo im Grunde genommen jeder einen, sage mal, Terrorserver mit eigenen Daten,
in Betrieb nehmen kann plus dass eigentlich unsere Vision auch war weg halt von,
Sag mal, statischen Daten hin mehr wirklich auch zu ähm ja, eher einer Simulation auch der der,
der Welt, wo Dinge drin passieren, wo äh ja, ähm.
Autos auch an dem das richtige Auto, an dem Ort ist, wo es wo es wirklich äh ist und solche Dinge, also mehr in die äh Richtung und wo.
Oder jetzt, wie ich meine, während wir äh sprechen, fließt jetzt grade Lava in La Palma irgendwie den Berg herab und äh
schaut sich Nachrichten an und man hat hier mal einen Clip und da mal einen Clip und hier mal eine Grafik, wie es denn so ist, aber eigentlich würde ich jetzt gerne, ja, Terrorvision nehmen, dahin fliegen und wirklich die Lava da so runterströ
sehen.
Und uns so ein bisschen äh war's auch, wo wir auch so ein bisschen hinwollten, war ähm hier äh äh Stevensen ähm Snow Crash.
Genau da ist ja in ja äh genau in in in Snow Crush gibt's ja so spezielle Satelliten. Ähm.
Die ganz viele Kameras haben
so und wo du dich dann quasi auch live drauf schalten kannst. Und das Interface war halt auch sagen die Erde, der, der, der Globus, äh aber das zu sagen, eigentlich wollten wir wirklich,
live Daten äh äh da drauf.
Äh so, äh wo du dann direkt äh aus dem Satelliten äh sagen, in Echtzeit äh die Welt an den Stellen, wo du hin willst, so sehen kannst, wie sie.
Gerade ist, ja, wo es natürlich dann Geld kostet und ja dann sogar hier dann auch mit der TU äh sogar äh
darüber geredet, eigene Satelliten hoch
zuschicken, weil die da Mikrosateliten gebaut haben und sagen, da schwebte uns vor, so wie jetzt heute Starling äh Halt äh nur wo dann zusätzlich
noch einen Haufen Kameras äh drauf sind
äh wo du dich dann, wenn du bereit bist zu bezahlen, dich dann live auf die Kameras draufschalten kannst und jederzeit live gucken kannst, was sich wo auf der Erde äh gerade tut. Das war so ein bisschen die die Vision, ja.
Und äh ja plus hat vorgestellt, dass das halt ja auch angefangen von so, ich sage mal, Bau,
Geschichten auch mit der deutschen Telekom darüber geredet ihre,
ihre gesamten Leitungspläne äh dann zu digitalisieren.
Und in das in das System zu packen.
Da stellte sich dann aber raus, dass das zu teuer.
Also nicht wegen Terror, sondern überhaupt die Digitalisierung, weswegen sie bis heute noch nicht digitalisiert haben, beziehungsweise immer noch dabei sind, äh äh ihre
Karten äh so Karten Blueprints wirklich äh ja sie arbeiten halt immer noch mit Blueprince, weil
die ja ist immer noch nicht noch nicht digitalisiert und es hätte wohl irgendwie 500 Millionen gekostet
allein nur die Daten äh wo jetzt die Telefonleitung verlegt sind, die äh zu digitalisieren, hatten sie geschätzt und haben das deswegen gar nicht gemacht.
Ähm ja. Äh gut, jedenfalls okay. Äh.
Ziel Terra äh Dinge auch, wie gesagt, bis hin zu, ja, Inflight, Entertainment-System und so für die Fluggesellschaften, das ist alles, das haben wir alles irgendwie,
gearbeitet äh äh gehabt ähm aber äh ja, jeweils.
Patent ist am Ende das einzige, was eigentlich übrig geblieb.
Genau, das Patent ist das einzige, was übrig geblieben ist und das haben wir auch gemacht. Äh deswegen, weil damals gesagt wurde, naja, wenn ihr irgendwie Geld einsammeln
wollt, so, dann braucht ihr halt äh irgendwie auch
Patente, weil eigentlich war er jetzt nicht so super begeistert davon, jetzt auch noch Zeit und Geld irgendwie sowas Bürokratisches, wie Patentieren äh, zu stecken, plus,
Neulich,
Beim zu welchem Zitat von Elon Musk äh gehört, äh der dann irgendwie gut erzählt viel Unsinn, aber den Spruch, den er da gebracht hat, ist sozusagen ein ein äh,
was dran also aber auf der anderen Seite
ja, das sind nun mal so die Spielregeln, äh wie sie wie sie sind und gerade natürlich zum Thema Softwarepatente ist natürlich nochmal besonders äh umstritten und bin jetzt auch kein Fan, aber äh so gut, was ich mir dann eingeredet habe,
Ja, selbst sehen, ob das jetzt überzeugend äh ist oder
äh ist. Das sind nun mal die geltenden Spielregeln und unter denen man momentan als Unternehmer äh zu agieren hat und man kann natürlich wie der Meinung, man kann natürlich irgendwie patente Scheiße finden
so oder halt 'ne.
Eine bessere Regulierung äh sich von Software äh äh Patenten äh fordern, politisch auf der einen Seite, aber das heißt jetzt nicht, äh dass man nicht irgendwie mit den,
geltenden, herrschenden Regeln äh äh irgendwie umgehen muss und damit äh auch zu spielen hat, äh sage ich mal, in dem Kontext.
Und äh dann jetzt auch nicht irgendwie.
Gedacht, äh irgendwie eine Patentklage ernsthaft zu führen. Normalerweise macht man das auch nicht, weil das ist irgendwie viel zu teuer und das ist halt eigentlich immer mehr oder weniger Geld
Verschwendung und es macht keinen Spaß deswegen ja läuft das normalerweise so, dass man dann an der Firma rantritt,
so ist mir das halt mit Siemens passiert, also im Grunde genommen bis wie ich an Google rangetreten bin, hatte ich mir eigentlich bei Siemens abgeguckt, die damals bei äh äh uns äh an der Tango rangetreten sind. Und äh gesagt haben, hier.
Wir haben jetzt hier die und die Patente und.
Ja, habt ihr nicht Lust, die zu lizensieren?
Und äh im Übrigen dann sozusagen dann ein ein Kreuzlizenzabkommen zu machen und äh dafür äh kriegen wir halt ein paar Prozent von eurer Firma äh äh.
So und sind mit dabei und dafür könnt ihr halt über unser Patent Portfolio auch verfügen, was ich dann so,
Ja äh und uns, sie waren halt auch sehr,
Also haben jetzt nie offen gesagt, irgendwie ja ihr verletzt unser Patent oder so, sondern nur schaut mal. Das hier ist so, sind so vielleicht relevante Patente für euch, wollt ihr mal gucken? Äh so, ja.
Dann gemacht, war okay, ich meine, der Tango, wenn's dann äh interessiert es dann später irgendwie äh von SAP gekauft worden ist, hat den SAP aufgegangen. Äh so auch eine der Firmen, die ich,
mitgegründet hatte. Ähm ja. Hm und nach der Tango äh bin ich dann aber wieder zu zu Art gekommen zurück.
Und äh weil mittlerweile waren da alle weg und ich habe dann halt komplett dort die Entwicklungsabteilung wieder neu aufgebaut so nach zweitausend.
Da waren auch irgendwie ein Entwickler da, den ich dann auch noch gefeiert habe, weil.
Einfach äh nie da war. Ähm.
Ja äh und ja, dann kam halt diese diese Google-Geschichte und dann haben wir gedacht, okay, was machen wir?
Jetzt äh damit und äh ja, dann dachte ich mir, naja äh keine Ahnung.
Schicke ich doch mal irgendwie eine E-Mail an Michael T. Jones mit dem Patent, vermutlich weiß er gar nicht, dass wir einen,
Patent darauf haben und sie soll mal einen Blick drauf werfen und gucken, ob sie das jetzt interessant äh finden und sagen, dieses Patent zu haben, um dann auch äh ja äh.
Der sicheren Seite ziehen.
Ja, einmal sozusagen aus aus mehreren Gründen. Einmal äh gab's halt damals auch andere Klagen äh gegen oder gab es halt Klagen gegen Google, wegen anderer Patente.
So
Aber nicht wegen Google Earth. Doch wegen Google. Wegen Google essen.
Doch wegen Google Arzt, wegen Google Earth, also Google Ars stand halt auch schon unter Beschuss, unter anderem von der israelischen äh äh Firma.
So, äh wobei, wenn man sich die Handpatent angeguckt hat, das war wirklich, ja, es hatte das, das, das war schon eigentlich Trollerei, das war schon ziemlich weit hergeholt, äh, so das, das Ganze. Und.
Und ich war jetzt auch nie davon ausgegangen, zu dem Zeitpunkt des Michael sich irgendwie mehr als Inspiration geholt hätte und technisch war er, habe ich ihn für absolut fähig gehalten, da irgendeine,
eigene Lösung äh zu.
Finden und na ja äh und ich wollte auch tatsächlich mich jetzt nicht irgendwie Arbeit und Zeit investieren in
zu gucken, wie funktioniert jetzt Google As wirklich und verletzendes Patent oder nicht? So, da die mir,
ich hab den nicht und das verteilt mühsam und eigentlich ist das einfachste ich schick denen das Patent,
soll mal draufgucken und wenn sie der Meinung sind, äh dass das vielleicht heikel für sie werden sollte, dann werden sie vielleicht schon motiviert sein zu sagen, okay,
Ja, vielleicht lizensieren wir das das Ganze und.
Ja und äh habe den halt eine nette E-Mail geschickt, habe ihm gratuliert,
Michael gratuliert zu zu sie taucht im Übrigen auch auf im Film sind viele meiner E-Mails und seiner E-Mails im Gerichtsverfahren dann auch aufgetaucht. Also
sagen das ist ja das ist ja war so, kann man halt nachlesen, ich hab eben halt
freundlich gratuliert und gesagt, hier so sieht's aus. Äh super, das ist das jetzt irgendwie.
Allen äh zur Verfügung äh steht und so und äh aber ähm ja, wir haben hier unter anderem dieses Patent und unter anderem haben wir auch noch ein Haufen Technologie, die vielleicht interessant wäre auch für Google Earth, weil äh.
So ein paar an vielen Stellen waren wir halt einfach deutlich weiter so und ja.
Daraufhin setzte er sich dann auch in den Flieger und kam nach Berlin äh zu Art kommen, wo wir dann halt drüber äh geredet.
Haben, waren super Meeting äh so, super Stimmung, er war total begeistert von Artcom, weil er kannte das halt nicht und von den ganzen Projekten und so und.
Also erkannte euch natürlich schon aus all den Jahren, dabei war noch nie da.
Er war noch nie da und er hatte auch gar nicht, also so wie wir nicht verfolgt hatten, was er jetzt gemacht hat in den letzten Jahren, hat er jetzt
irgendwie nicht artkommen auf dem Schirm gehabt und die Projekte und wir haben ihn dann halt das ganze Projekt, Portfolio gezeigt, was irgendwie für Daimler
gemacht hatten im im VR Bereich und was wir immer Hits Wissenschaft und Archäologie gemacht haben und also da waren
im im Bereich Medizin, äh so all die die Projekte und das war schon äh ja äh.
Einfach generell beeindruckend auch für ihn und er war auch ziemlich geflasht von Artcom plus.
Von dem von dem Patent und und,
er kam dann mit ja, ne, wir sollten, mancher sollten äh das Ding lizensieren und wir sollten zusammenarbeiten und Google sollte sich an beteiligen. So ist er halt.
So weg und äh weil wir ihn ich dann auch hingefragt so ja und in meinem.
Was er denn denken würde, was Google denn so bereit sein könnte für so ein Patent zu zahlen, was das wert wäre und er meinte dann, gut musste ihm dann versprechen, jetzt äh sagen das nicht.
Sagen, ihnen nicht zu zitieren äh damit, was ich jetzt äh ja äh dann irgendwann aber dann doch äh äh getan äh habe, aber muss sagen, die Zahl, die er genannt hat, er wüsste jetzt nicht, er wird sich jetzt nicht damit auskennen, aber äh.
Drei bis fünf Millionen, so könnte er sich schon gut vorstellen, äh dass das wert wäre. Ja, es kam, kam halt alles von ihm. Und ja, er ist dann auch zurückgefahren, also sein, sein,
ein direkter Chef war auch noch äh mit mit dabei.
Und äh beziehungsweise sind auch noch ein zweites Mal äh gekommen. Jedenfalls hat er das ging dann später aus intern Google Mails hervor, die dann im Prozess vorgelegt werden mussten.
Hat dann auch genau das, was er wollte, hat er gesagt, hier äh Artkommen.
Ist cool äh so, hat er in der internen Google E-Mail geschrieben äh,
seine Präferenz wäre halt das Patent zu lizensieren plus Anteile an zu erwerben plus Aufträge zu geben bestimmte Dinge weiter zu machen also eher
war ja,
War begeistert und wollte halt äh kooperieren plus sagen auch mit Hilfe des Patents und mit Hilfe dann unserer Zeugenaussagen vor Gericht dann auch noch andere
Patentrolle abzuwehren. Also war eigentlich ein, ich sage mal, ein super Paket für beide Seiten, denke ich, was wir da geschnürt hatten.
Aber zu Hause bei der Google Führung, die hatten irgendwie andere.
Pläne, weil die hatten dann gesagt, keine Ahnung, äh nee,
das sind jetzt Patentrolle, wir wir, keine Ahnung, wir weichen nicht ich weiß es nicht wirklich, warum, aber jedenfalls statt halt, dass man jetzt,
sagen gemeinsam, ich sage mal, über Business geredet hat, äh äh haben, hat Google halt eine Rechtsabteilung.
Ins Rennen geschickt. Und was auch immer äh deren Job äh war oder nicht. Also die Rechtsabteilung ist sicherlich erstmal nicht für.
Unternehmerisches, also für vorausdenkende unternehmerische Entscheidungen äh äh zuständig so
Und äh ja, am Ende, ja, sagen, war der eine Entscheidung, stattdessen die Rechtsabteilung äh zu schicken, führte dann einfach
äh sich zu einer weiteren Eskalation äh so. Die Rechtsabteilung, die haben ja erstmal gesagt, naja, äh hier aber,
sagen wir wir wollen euer Patent nicht, weil oder euer Patent ist uninteressant, weil wir nicht glauben, dass das formal äh standhält, weil äh sagen, es.
Es da bestimmte Veröffentlichungen gab, die ihr in einem
anderen, die im europäischen Patent angeführt hattet, die ihr aber sofort, als ihr die hättet ihr die auch dem amerikanischen Patenamt melden müssen und ihr habt somit jetzt Informationen vor dem amerikanischen Patent
Amt vorenthalten und deswegen wird es dieses Patent halt ja.
Nichtig. Äh so wird halt nicht nicht standhalten.
Naja, erstmal ernst nehmen, ich mich dann halt irgendwie schlau gemacht so und äh ja äh und was kann man da machen? Und eine Heilungsmöglichkeit ist halt äh du reichst das Patent sozusagen nochmal ein.
Mit dem Prioritätsdatum, mit dann aber den ganzen Dokumenten nochmal und äh guckst dann, ob das erteilt wird oder nicht.
Oder ob da durch die Dokumente sich irgendwas ändert. So.
Aber in unveränderter Form wieder erteilt wurde, trotz der neuen Dokumente, ist quasi klar, dass diese Dokumente, die jetzt damals versäumt wurden, aus dem europäischen Patent, jetzt nicht,
irgendwie,
entscheidend waren oder irgendwie das Einfluss auf die Erteilung hatten und deswegen sagen das das unproblematisch und wenn man hinterher sogar nochmal drittes Mal eingereicht, um so bestimmte Formulierungen, weil es ja eine Übersetzung, um nochmal Übersetzungsfehler äh
und das Patent wollen am Ende zum dritten Mal neu erteilt. So.
Wo sind wir jetzt in der Zeit?
Da sind wir jetzt wahrscheinlich so zweitausend dreizehn vierzehn irgendwie so was in der.
Gegend, also je nachdem wie die erste, die erste, zweite Re Show, aber es ist auf jeden Fall.
Auf jeden Fall ist so sechs, sieben Jahre nachdem Google Earth gelauncht wurde.
Genau, genau. Und während der Zeit, also wie gesagt, wir hatten dann die ersten Gespräche geführt, dann,
kam halt das das wie ein Schuh, das hat in Wirklichkeit, ich glaube sogar zwei Jahre gedauert äh oder so. Aber als das Reshow da war.
Dann habe ich dann tatsächlich auch wieder auf Google zugegangen, habe dann gesagt, hier,
eure formalen Bedenken, äh die ihr hattet, waren offensichtlich Gegenstandslos und äh.
Wie sieht's aus, wollen wir nicht mal äh äh wieder reden?
So und dann ging das über Monate auch hin und her, äh hauptsächlich telefonisch, also ich habe hatte dann, ich habe dann immer ähm per Telefon dann mit jemandem aus der Google-Rechtsabteilung telefoniert. Michael hatten sie komplett.
Linie geholt, beziehungsweise ihm verboten wahrscheinlich mit uns zu reden, nach dem Motto irgendwie nee, du redest dich da sonst im Kopf im Kopf und Kragen, wir wollen nicht, dass du da irgendwie äh weiter aktiv
bist oder so, ja äh weil ja und ähm,
waren dann auch der Meinung, dass wir haben dann irgendwann auch sagen wir telefonisch über das Verletzungs äh Thema gesprochen und sie haben mich auf den Standpunkt gestellt. Nee, sie würden
ist halt auch nicht verletzen, so. Und es war für mich dann der Anlass, um,
es dann jetzt doch rausfinden zu wollen so OK wie viel Terrorvision steckt den jetzt,
tatsächlich in Google Earth drin. So. Und da habe ich mich halt wirklich hingesetzt und mir den den Traffic vor allem angeguckt, den jetzt der Google Barsclient mit
dem dem dem Server macht und äh ja und danach war ich ein bisschen pisst, ehrlich gesagt.
Warum? Was hast du denn rausbekommen?
Weil ich nicht gedacht hätte, dass halt die Ähnlichkeiten so weit,
gehen, äh so. Also unter anderem war, wie gesagt, die Durchnummerierung des Quatsch war identisch, wie in unserem Patent, ja.
Also dieser ist ja so eine essenzielle Datenstruktur in Terravision.
Genau und ähm das ist sozusagen man unterteilt halt im Prinzip Quadrate oder Rechtecke dann in weitere Quadrate oder Rechtecke und äh immer, immer weiter, also.
Einfach, wenn man quasi sich der Erde nähert, hat man erstmal so dieses kleingerechnete Bild der ganzen Erde und umso näher man ranfliegt, um
teilt man dann quasi, macht so ein Kreuz äh durch und dann setzt sich das aus den vier Karten da drunter zusammen und wenn man irgendwie in eins von denen reinfliegt, teilt sich das wieder auf so einen Baum quasi, wo immer vier an einem dranhängen.
Beziehungsweise auch weniger äh manchmal oder mehr, also es ist nicht wie viel, ja, je nachdem, wo man das genau und.
Je nachdem, wie viel Daten da sind. Wie hast du denn das rausgefunden? Ich meine, du hast ja diesen nicht gehabt, sondern hast ja nur das Programm, was so auf dem Rechner läuft.
Ja ja, aber ich habe mir halt äh das Zugriffsmuster angeguckt, wie gesagt, wie er.
Übers Netz, wie er sich die Daten holt.
Übers Netz, wie er sich die Daten holt und wie er die Daten adressiert.
Das war nicht verschlüsselt.
Doch es war HTTPS, aber ich habe mich dann da äh irgendwie Men in the mittel oder so habe ich mich da irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, ich da ein Plug-in geschrieben habe oder irgendwie was äh also ich habe die jedenfalls unverschlüsselt äh abgegriffen, je.
Okay. Und dann hast du gesehen, dass die selbe nur ein Klatur verwenden dafür.
Ja ja, genau und es ist jetzt, ich meine.
Kennen die denn das dann? Also ich meine, wie konnten sie das denn kopieren, wenn sie so in dem Sinne nie im Besitz eures äh South Cools waren oder oder.
Näher. Ich sage zum einen, also ein bisschen davon hatten wir veröffentlicht, äh einfach unter anderem das mit dem Quartier und die Quartier-Nummerierung. So äh das hätten sie tatsächlich sogar ähm ich sage mal.
Also im Rahmen des Patentes veröffentlicht.
Ja, auch im Rahmen des Patentes, also es stand zum einen im Patent drin, aber es stand eben auch bei anderen Veröffentlichungen, frühen Veröffentlichungen so im Rahmen von Sigraf und so hatten wir halt auch ein bisschen die Funktion,
erklärt, was halt auch so ein bisschen ein ein Problem war noch, weil wir sagen dann,
Teile äh von den Patent äh konnten wir halt nicht äh äh wirklich.
Beanspruchen vor Gericht, weil es da durchaus schon veröffentlicht, also weil wir weil wir ja teilweise andere Informationen schon mal veröffentlicht hatten und wenn du die Sachen irgendwo veröffentlichst, dann sind sie in der Public
wenn du sie nicht vorher patentierst und dazu gehörte im Prinzip auch sagen dieses
Unterteilungs oder oder Nummerierungsschema, also dass das für sich genommen so äh hätten sie jetzt tatsächlich auch,
legal kopieren können, aber nicht den Teil der Gegenstand des Patents war, der halt Prinzip beschreibt, wie der ganze Algorithmus abläuft mit dem Verfeinern und äh irgendwie näher ran.
Rein aus dieser Netzwerkanalyse konntest du aber daraus den Schluss ziehen, dass sie das sehr wohl genauso.
Ja, ja. Und zwar war das irgendwie fast eins zu eins, als wenn das jemand irgendwie sich entweder unser Patent genommen hätte, was ich nicht glaube oder äh ja,
ähm keine Ahnung. Also war mir jedenfalls zu, war mir jedenfalls zu.
Aber wo, aber wo konnten sie denn dann das sich konkret abgucken, wenn, ich meine, dieses Programm Terravision ist ja so nie veröffentlicht worden.
Nee, na ja, wie gesagt, es war einmal äh äh war es ja installiert bei Silicon Graphics über einem Jahr, wo äh und ich hatte halt auch,
Michael damals mehr oder weniger komplett erklärt, wie's funktioniert äh so äh so wie wie auch das mit der Datenbank und wie wir die Daten adressieren. Also das hatte ich ihm halt alles erklärt. Äh so, also
es wusste äh eher wie's wie es funktioniert.
Aber das war dann eigentlich auch die einzige Quelle. Das, was du ihm erzählt hast, beziehungsweise die Software, die bei denen in den Räumen lief, das kann nur der einzige Ort gewesen sein, wo man das sich genauso 1 zu eins hätte abgucken können.
Ja, ja.
Aber es ist auch egal, weil es war jetzt kein Copyright äh äh Case äh in dem Sinne. So, sondern es war ein Patentfall und da spielt's jetzt.
Nicht unbedingt die Rolle äh so ähm wobei es natürlich hilft, also bei einem geschworenen Prozess natürlich einen einen Link zu haben, wo sagen in,
äh äh dort äh geflossen sind. Aber letztlich war es halt war das Patent öffentlich und das Patent zeigt halt auch dieses Schema und andere Dinge. Also im Grunde genommen kannst du halt schon mit dem Patent auch.
Das Ding nachbauen wenn du wenn du das hast und das.
Denkst du, woraus sie es nachgebaut haben?
Naja, ich, also meine Vermutung ist, als er es gebaut hat
so wird es entweder unbewusst wird Michael das unbewusst im Gedächtnis gehabt haben oder er wird sich irgendwie nochmal alte Dokumentation,
an Ö geguckt haben oder so, der hatte sich oder er hat sich einfach erinnert, wie wir das gemacht haben, weil.
Was ich dann auch noch gemacht habe, war, ich habe dann geguckt, ob irgendjemand irgendwo auf der Welt für Mapping-Geschichten.
Ähnliches verwendet, insbesondere mir angeguckt, wie macht es den Google Maps, weil,
Ja auch ähnliche Adressierung auf einer ähnlichen Pyramide von Daten äh haben, ja und Google Maps macht es damals völlig anders.
Zum damaligen Zeitpunkt, so die haben halt mit einfach mit Koordinaten operiert, mit Längen, Breitengraden.
Und während wir halt, äh wir nannten das ganze Ding dann GAI oder Global Area, Identify und,
Das war dann ein String im Prinzip von Zahlen. Äh je nachdem welcher Quadrant halt gemeint war, konntest du sozusagen,
Äh im Grunde genommen so eine Art Telefonnummer äh für jeden einzelnen Patch hattest du, aus dem halt raus ging, wo der Patch hingehört,
und wie die Unterteilung ist und wie halt dieser äh äh Level äh äh auf auf die so und,
Google Earth hatte halt genau denselben Global Area Identifier benutzt und er hat dann auch Microsoft hat ja auch mal irgendwie sowas ähnliches, dann,
draußen mit Bingen, genau und die haben's auch ganz anders äh äh gemacht, ja. Äh wobei die den Kern Algorithmus äh schon auch benutzt haben, aber ja, jedenfalls.
War's halt äh irgendwie doch hm ja war ich halt überrascht so äh wie hm.
Bin nah dran.
Wie nah dran es ist und wie auch jetzt nicht nur eigentlich der, sagen, der Hauptanspruch von dem Patent, sondern ganz viele der Unteransprüche, auch
verwirklicht waren und das ist eigentlich normalerweise eher selten, dass du halt sagst, okay, das ist uns jetzt Hauptanspruch und irgendwie und das und das und das und das und das.
So, haben sie alles äh gemacht, ja? Und das war dann so äh der Moment, äh wo ich mir, wo ich mir dann dachte, also nee, äh.
Da sollten wir jetzt äh äh mal äh schon nochmal gucken, äh ob wir die nicht nochmal zum Reden äh äh kriegen. Und der nächste Schritt, um zu reden, ist dann halt eine Klage.
Einzureichen.
Ja, aber äh Sinn und Zweck äh sowas ist eigentlich nicht, das durchzuziehen bis zum Ende, sondern die Klage ist dann eigentlich normalerweise ein Eskalationspunkt, wo man dann,
in der Mediation äh nochmal reingeht und eigentlich nochmal eine Möglichkeit hat, das Ganze gültig aus der Welt zu schaffen, was man in der Regel auch tut.
Weil es einfach irrsinnig teuer ist. Aber
damit man natürlich glaubwürdig ein bisschen wie nukleare Abschreckung, damit es auch glaubhaft ist, muss man sagen, sich auch entsprechend aufmunitionieren dann mit einer entsprechenden Großkanzlei und,
die Mittel haben das zur Not auch durchzuziehen, also glaubhaft demonstrieren, dass man bereit ist, dann auch die fünf oder zehn Millionen ähäh einzusetzen,
um den Weg zu gehen.
Nicht ernst, dann ist es so, als ob man in die Bank reinläuft mit einer Wasserpistole und sagt, hier Hände hoch.
Genau, genau. Also wenn wir das jetzt einfach nur so äh so na ja, macht mal. Und,
Die haben auch eine ganze Weile gebraucht überhaupt, bis die das ernst äh genommen haben.
Und bis dahin hatte dann OK vielleicht,
noch wie wir dann an eigentlich an der Anwaltskanzlei gekommen sind. Ich hatte dann äh ja einen einen einen Freund hier, der Martin Silbernagel, der äh.
Hatte halt, hat längere Zeit in New York gelebt und kannte auch eine ganze Menge Anwalts äh Kanzleien und kannte sich auch in dem ganzen Patent Business äh äh ganz gut aus und,
ähm ja, mit dem.
Der hat ein paar Leute abtelefoniert und mit ihm bin ich dann halt rumgefahren zu den zu den Anwaltskanzleien, die sich dann das äh erstmal angeguckt haben, dass das Material und
bereit gewesen wären, zum einen auf Contentcy Plus mit einem sogenannten Business Dispute Finance Service so heißt, das sind dann quasi nochmal VC-Firmen, die extra nur Gerichtsverfahren,
finanzieren, also aus der Kombination quasi plus, ich sage mal, wir ein bisschen auch noch, aber die,
anderen sagen, dass das Gro übernommen der, der, der.
Also quasi so Risikokapital, für Gerichtsverfahren. Ja. Die schauen sich das an und sagen, aha, äh,
aus unserer Position heraus scheint das ganz äh wertvoll äh zu sein und die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist groß, dass man das dann auch gewinnt. Genau. Und dann muss ja Google die ganzen Kosten tragen und dann äh.
Die das. Aber auf der anderen Seite bedeutet das für die auch, wenn man verliert, tragen die dann auch die Kosten.
Genau, euern Großteil, weil äh also.
Jetzt waren sie neunzig, fünfundneunzig Prozent. Ähm ja und tatsächlich war's dann so, also die erste Kanzlei war halt auch erstmal interessiert, woraufhin wir dann denen unser gesamtes,
Archivkorrespondenz zur Verfügung gestellt haben und die das dann durchgegangen sind und dann halt auf dieses eine Angebot von mir gestoßen sind, wo ich dann irgendwann in dem Prozess äh so.
Äh hatten wir äh dann auf den äh äh Wunsch äh sagen ihnen auch einen sagen wir mal einen einen Angebot äh geschickt.
Und äh ja, da war halt, sagen wir mal, alles zusammengefasst und in dem war eben auch eine Summe von drei bis fünf Millionen.
In dem Angebot und das war dann äh aber so, dass sie dann sagten, tja,
ein riesen Fehler gemacht, weil äh letztlich, wenn ihr schon mal ein Angebot gemacht habt, ist das Dank der der Wert äh die maximale Schadenssumme, äh die ihr geltend machen könnt und,
niedrigen Angebot
Könnt das einfach knicken bei dem Risiko braucht braucht braucht man mindestens also eine mögliche Schadensumme von 100 Millionen äh so, damit sich das für die Lohn 5 oder 10 zu investieren, weil.
Also wenn du dann vor von vornherein irgendwie ja die Schadensumme so gedeckelt äh hast äh so,
fast es halt keiner an. Und.
Ähm es ging dann auch, also im Juli dann halt auch erzählt, dass das einige Firmen äh tatsächlich als Strategie gemacht haben, halt.
Angebote eingefordert äh haben, äh um eben.
Dann ein Angebot in der Hand zu halten, um dann quasi äh äh nicht zu kaufen, aber für den Fall, dass dann jetzt eine Klage kommt, äh äh einfach auf der sicheren Seite,
sein,
weiß nicht, ob Google das auch so strategisch äh gemacht hat. Ich glaube nicht wirklich oder zu der Zeit glaube ich noch nicht wirklich,
und äh wie gesagt, äh Google ist ja auch nicht irgendwie ein monolithisches Ding, sondern da gab es eben auch unterschiedliche Leute, die unterschiedliches wollten,
bei Google und Michael wollte mit uns zusammenarbeiten und lizensieren und andere Leute wollten's halt nicht äh so,
Insofern äh und äh außerdem schienen die mir auch so ein bisschen zu dem Zeitpunkt äh noch ein bisschen unbeleckt gewesen zu sein. Also Google was so Patente,
angeht. Die waren da gerade auch erstmal dabei, äh sich sich zu orientieren. Und die erste Kanzlei, die sie dann auch gegen uns ins Feld geschickt haben, war irgendwie so eher,
drittklassig.
Und äh ja, wir hatten halt äh eine, wo dann ja, unter anderem einer der Partner halt James Baker, der ehemalige Außenminister hat und die halt allein 780 Anwälte äh hatten, in dem äh äh
Bereich ja und einfach schon so eine mega Kanzlei.
Ja, die halt schon zum so Toptier gehörte, die halt normalerweise ja die Anwälte hier mal vorher, so Apple, gegen Samsung und so gemacht. Also die waren, also war halt eine Kanzlei, die so Milliardenprozesse führt, einfach
und die dafür aufgestellt ist und dafür ausgestattet ist,
Google erstmal so 'n mehr oder weniger Wald und Wiesent Anwalt gegen die ins Rennen geschickt hat, der hat komplett abgelöst,
der tat mir auch wirklich leid.
Inwiefern abgelöst, also kam's jetzt schon zu irgendwelchen Verhandlungen in dem Zusammenhang.
Es ist so, also im Vorfeld vor der Fahndung finden halt ganz viele äh Dinge statt, unter anderem gibt's auch so eine Smartmin Meeting. Ähm,
da wird äh definiert, was was im Patent eigentlich zu bedeuten hat. Da legt man quasi so eine Art,
ja äh äh Wörterverzeichnis oder Wörterdefinition an.
Mhm. Vom Glossar.
Gloss H, genau, ein gloss H und,
Jede Seite kann jetzt Vorschläge machen, also wenn erstmal die zentralen Begriffe definiert und jede Seite kann dann Vorschläge machen, wie dieser Begriff auszulegen ist in dem Patent und der Richter entscheidet dann äh.
Welches von beiden er nimmt oder kann dann auch selber sagen, nee ich definiere das jetzt anders so,
und das sind dann so vierzig Punkte und ich weiß nicht, wann hatten das Meeting, glaube ich, mit äh fünfunddreißig oder sechsunddreißig zu vier gewonnen, ja, so der Richter hat nur in vier Fällen die Definition
von Google genommen und in den 36 Fällen jetzt unsere Definition.
Heißt das.
Plus so laufend andere äh äh Sachen, wo einfach also.
Geht dann im, im, wie gesagt, im Vorfeld wird dann halt definiert, was worum es denn in dem Prozess eigentlich gehen soll und worum es nicht gehen soll und wie lange er dauern soll und das alles wird halt so im Vorfeld festgelegt. Und.
Ja
und es war einfach desaströs Plus. Vorher gibt's halt noch die Positions, da war ich dann in Frankfurt im Generalkonsulat. Und da hatte halt auch dieser Google Anwalt dann schon mal die Gelegenheit mich und die anderen Zeugen
schon mal zu befragen mit Videokamera und dann sagen auch vor dem Gericht zu sagen, machen alle ihre Aussagen auf Video so,
und die Depositions sind halt auch super für uns äh gelaufen. Also es ist,
hat halt, der auch dann die Anwälte von Google einfach keine Sonne gesehen, weil die versuchen natürlich auch dann irgendwie Sachen rauszukitzeln, ja weil alle einfach
perfekt performt, dass wir ja auch daran lag, dass der arme Anwalt irgendwie voll erkältet war und Fieber hatte und der Übersetzer, der da war, auch komplett inkompetent äh war, sodass der dann also dieses,
für Google war halt auch diese Depositions äh so von deren Seite. Es waren Desaster, wie das gehandelt äh wurde. Und.
Ja
Und der Wandel kam dann ein paar Wochen vor dem Prozess, vor dem Prozess, hat dann Google die Anwaltskanzlei komplett ausgetauscht und sich eine vernünftige geholt und der Richter wurde ausgetauscht.
So und.
Wodurch? Also, ich meine, wer kann den austauschen.
Er hat sich selbst über das Verfahren äh äh an Land gezogen. Das war ein Richter, der halt noch nie einen Prozess geführt hat, der aber
sagen auf, äh also ähm Apellationsgericht, also Berufungsgenau aufm im war halt Berufungsrichter und das ist
in den USA ist das ein extra Job, so Berufungsrichter, weil du dann so sagen, formal, prüfen musst und ähm Berufungsrichter ist halt kein Trial
so. Und er wollte halt jetzt mal, man war auch irgendwie, weiß nicht, fast 80 Jahre alt. Ähm,
und wollte gerne doch mal immer irgendwie ins eine Feldstudie machen oder so, wie das denn so in so einem Prozess Patentprozess äh,
eigentlich läuft und äh das war sozusagen die offizielle äh äh Begründung. So, warum der sich das jetzt gegriffen hatte.
Der kann sich das einfach so greifen, weil er da ja.
Weil er irgendwie auf einem höheren Berufungsgericht und äh ja, also er hat es einfach getan.
Okay.
Was halt ein bisschen komisch war und ein bisschen, ja es gab halt auch so dann so ein paar komische Momente, wo dann im Verfahren Dinge nicht optimal gelaufen sind, weil halt keine Erfahrung hatte. Aber im Großen und Ganzen ist jetzt nicht aufgefallen, dass er irgendwie.
Parteiisch sich verhalten hätte oder so jedenfalls nicht, nicht, nicht offen.
Aber was halt auch so ein bisschen, was man halt nicht weiß, ist, was passiert, also wie instruiert der jetzt die Jury zum Beispiel. Also er hat halt.
Der ist halt dann derjenige, der halt dann auch in sozusagen sich dann vor die Jury stellt,
Und den nochmal erklärt, wie sie was zu entscheiden äh haben. Da kriegst du natürlich nichts von mit. Und was halt so ein bisschen auch komisch war, wie mir äh berichtet wurde, ist, dass seine Frau äh wohl
Lobbyistin ist für Google ähm so. Also es ist, ich will jetzt nicht unterstellen, dass da irgendwas gelaufen ist. Ähm,
so, aber äh es gilt halt gerade in den Bereichen äh gilt es auch den Anschein
zu vermeiden, ja? Also speziell so im öffentlichen Dienst, hast du halt eigentlich auch so ein Anscheinsvermeidungs
Gebot, Pflicht, so. Und Aussehen tat das für uns nicht
ja, dass plötzlich irgendwie der Richter zwei Wochen vorher äh äh ausgewechselt äh wird äh der dann irgendwie möglicherweise auch noch äh Konflikte
ist äh ja, dass das war dann also.
War da nicht so toll. Ich meine im Film taucht das übrigens deswegen nicht auf. Wir wir kommen da hinterher drauf, aber äh weil das äh aus dramaturgischen äh Gründen nicht gepasst hätte, weil das Ding ist in der Realität passieren Sachen auch einfach aus Coinzidenz
Aber wenn du in einem Film irgendwas bringst,
ist klar dem Zuschauer das hat Konsequenzen, weil du normal du packst halt nichts in den Film rein, was dann hinterher bedeutungslos ist. So das heißt da wäre dann einfach das Spannungsmoment dann verloren
deswegen wurde das halt äh rausgenommen plus noch dann auch eine sehr zweifelhafte Aussage noch von einem Google Zeugen, der
aus meiner Sicht einfach glatt die Unwahrheit gesagt hat vor Gericht aber erzählt hat er hätte uns damals sein und er sei in Wirklichkeit der Erfinder dieses,
ist Algorithmus äh und so und,
und ich meine es war halt von dem Laden, die halt auch ein Projekt hatten, was irgendwie Terrorvision hieß, was auch auf der Sieger zur selben Zeit gezeigt wurde, werden wir die ganze Welt hatten, hatten sie irgendwie 40 Quadratmeter rund um Fort Irving,
wo sie dann mit Panzern rumfahren konnten. Also sie hatten halt einen Simulator im Prinzip, also einen einen, ja, aber also es war.
Nicht vergleichbar. Bei denen haben sie dann irgendwie auch nochmal aus aus der Versenkung gezogen, es kommt auch nicht im Film äh äh vor, aber der aber die Sachen, die vorkommen, so die gab's, die gab's halt auch, aber wie gesagt, aus dramaturgischen Gründen. Und,
Man wird auch nie nie wirklich wissen, woran's denn gescheitert ist, weil das ist nur die geschwollen, die geschworen sind auf Ewigkeit äh zum Stillschweigen äh verdammt. Das,
was der Film eigentlich auch nur tun kann am Ende ist, ist spekulieren, aber äh ja, wir müssen jetzt, jetzt, jetzt äh irgendwie vorgegangen, aber jedenfalls.
Die ersten Anwälte hatten uns dann gesagt, gesagt, geht nicht, aber äh so die andere Anwalts äh Kanzlei, die wir dann gekriegt haben, die haben wir nochmal durchgeguckt.
Denken, okay, äh dieses Angebot ist aber sozusagen ein bedingtes Angebot, was nur sagen, Gültigkeit hatte als,
Paket, nämlich Kollaboration, plus Aufträge, plus äh Lizenzierung und da kann man jetzt nicht irgendwie.
Die Lizensierung einfach mit rausnehmen und da es nie zu einer Zusammenarbeit gekommen ist, ist dieses Angebot auch komplett nicht dicht, zumal es auch noch andere Angebote,
gab, wie man das äh äh.
Regeln könnte, ja. Und wie gesagt, dann die andere Kanzlei, die wir dann, die wir dann hatten, hat dann gesagt, nee, ähm also das sehen wir jetzt nicht als als Killer äh äh Problem und,
wie gesagt, dann noch Ösen, ja, Business Finance war dazu geholt und haben sich dann die Kosten mehr oder weniger
geteilt, also die Anwälte haben dann auch teilweise auf Honorare verzichtet und seine niedrige Stundensätze und der Business, der der Finance hat dann vor allem die Gutachter und so bezahlt, also der Typ, der sich den Southcode dann angeguckt hat, bei Google und
Financial Gutachter und ähm also es gab für alles Experten. Äh in dem ganzen Ding.
Auf jeden Fall waren die ein bisschen heiß, äh googelt da mal einen einzuschenken, sonst hätten sie es sicherlich nicht gemacht.
Also die, wie gesagt, es war jetzt nicht so,
nur weil ich jetzt irgendwie vielleicht aus verletzter Eitelkeit glauben würde, dass Google äh irgendwie das Patent äh verletzt, investiert niemand zehn Millionen in einen äh solchen Prozess
Das heißt, es haben sich halt im Vorfeld verdammt viele Leute nochmal angeguckt, äh so ist da jetzt was dran
oder nicht? Äh ja, haben wir, haben wir damit eine eine, eine, eine Chance, äh, so oder nicht. Und.
Ähm und die sind halt auch zu der Einschätzung gekommen, ja, das ist.
Vielleicht nicht hundertprozentig eindeutig oder oder aber die die Chance ist extrem hoch.
So, äh dass das vor Gericht äh äh gewinnen äh zu können. Das war sagen.
Aber es kam anders.
Ja, es kam äh dann, wie gesagt, anders und es zeichnete sich so ein bisschen eben schon ab, äh plötzlich mit äh ich sage mal, der
der neue Richter, mit dem alles nicht mehr so rund lief äh wie lang die zwei Jahre zuvor plus die neue Anwaltskanzlei, also das Ganze hat auch,
dazu geführt, dass es alles auch nochmal ein bisschen chaotischer
wurde. Und eine Herausforderung war, dass diese Geschichte auch so komplex
Ist ja mit diesen ganzen Zusammenhängen und mit Michael und dann im Einzelfall, was jetzt zur Sprache gebracht werden konnte und was nicht, weil meiner Sicht dann vorher auch geeinigt
aus Prozessökonomischen Gründen nur fünf Tage zu machen und deswegen
war sie sämtliche Copyright-Aspekte äh auch mit rauszunehmen oder halt ein reiner Patentverletzungs äh Prozess und über bestimmte Dinge halt gar nicht zu reden.
Des Weiteren war noch das Problem, dass alles so lange zurücklag und da gibt es dann wiederum die sogenannte,
besagt, dass wenn du als Kläger zu lange wartest irgendwelche Ansprüche.
Vorzubringen, dass äh dann äh alleine nur, weil sich niemand mehr richtig erinnern kann, äh nach so langer Zeit
quasi du aus formalen Gründen rausgeworfen wirst, weil sonst auch der Verteidigung ist,
zu schwierig ist, nach so langer Zeit irgendwie noch entlastendes zu zu finden, so das heißt, was wir jetzt auch nicht tun konnten, war.
I don't know äh zu antworten bei Befragungen. Das war halt auch noch eine Instruktion
für mich. Das heißt, es war, gab halt ganz viel Druck so, okay, also über das darf nicht geredet werden und du darfst jetzt auch nicht äh ich weiß nicht oder ich kann mich nicht mehr erinnern äh äh sagen, aber
Du musst auch aufpassen, irgendwie mit dem ja und neins äh so, da darfst du dich auch nicht zu sehr irgendwie in den YES-Train äh reinziehen äh lassen und äh ja.
Dann äh war's aber auch einfach super schwierig. Ich meine dann so fünf Laien. Dieses dieses Ganze, diese ganzen Komplikationen äh auch äh.
Die Jury bestand aus fünf Leuten nur.
Nee, es waren, ich glaube, es waren acht Leute, acht Leute waren's, ja genau, acht Leute waren's,
Das hätten mindestens irgendwie noch fünf, glaube ich, übrig bleiben müssen oder so. Ja, also es war jedenfalls also.
Selbst dann für für Experten,
einfach teilweise schwierig äh dem dem äh zu folgen und die Jury war einfach teilweise komplett überfordert.
Das kann ich mir vorstellen.
Auch mit dem mit dem äh Thema, weil ähm ja.
Sprich am Ende gab's den Beschluss der Jury, dass ihrer Auffassung nach das Patent nicht äh oder nicht ausreichend verletzt wurde.
Sie haben irgendwie in in allen Punkten gegen uns äh entschieden, also komplett. Es war sozusagen ein äh selbst bei bei Dingen, wo man jetzt sagen würde, da hätten sie jetzt aber allein, weiß ich nicht, aus äh.
Also es wäre nicht begründbar. Aber du kriegst halt eben auch keine äh sagen, nicht, nicht wirklich jetzt eine Begründung.
Die sagen einfach nein und dann.
Sagen einfach, nee, es ist, wir sehen das so und dann ist das so.
Ist echt ein merkwürdiges System, dieses geschworen System, ne?
Ich meine, das hat sicherlich auch gewisse Vor- oder Nachteile, aber grundsätzlich ist es halt, glaube ich, für heutige Zeiten einfach ein Scheißsystem. So und speziell für solche Arten von Streitigkeiten, weil.
Expertenwissen ist, was bewertet werden muss.
Deswegen gehen auch die Firmen zunehmend jetzt nach Deutschland um hier ihre äh äh Patentstreitigkeiten,
zu führen und zu sehen, wie denn ich sage mal halbwegs Sachverständige, äh das ganze Thema entscheiden
und sich dann in Amerika quasi dran orientieren, beziehungsweise gar nicht die teuren Prozesse dort führen, sondern hier ist es halt.
Ein bis zwei Größenordnungen günstiger. Also hier kannst du.
War das für euch keine Option, das in Deutschland zu machen?
Nehmen, weil wir äh nämlich nur ein amerikanisches Patent hatten und kein Deutsches.
Weil wir irgendwann auch mal formal äh sagen, dass das deutsche äh Patent äh äh nicht,
durchgefochten haben, weil in Deutschland war wiederum Patentprüfer da, der das Patent nicht mochte.
Der persönlich vorher irgendwie in
Simulator irgendwie mit Flugsimulatoren und Geoinformationssystemen selber zu tun hatte, selber so was entwickelt hat und äh der der mochte das nicht. Der hat das, glaube ich, auch nicht,
nicht voll begriffen, worum's worum's jetzt geht, aber er meinte, naja, ist doch alles simpel, es gibt's doch alles schon, ne.
Verstehe.
Während aber der europäische europäischen Prüfer und die amerikanischen ja Plus eben alle die sich das später angeguckt haben und gesagt nee das ist schon das ist schon.
Hat schon was.
Das, das, das, das hat schon äh was.
Wie viel Zeit habt ihr denn da jetzt so insgesamt reingesteckt.
Jetzt in die, in die ganze Patent äh Geschichte.
Ja, in diesem Prozess selber. Also zu dem Zeitpunkt, als das dann sozusagen klar war, jetzt jetzt wird es wirklich zu diesem Prozess äh kommen. Im Film nimmt das ja auch einen gewissen Raum äh ein.
Es gab im Vorfeld dann schon mal Vorbereitungen so hier in Deutschland wird 'ne für die sogenannte für die im Vorfeld und jetzt dann direkt in in Wimmingen.
Äh bin ich eine Woche früher, also eine Woche früher angereist, also eine Woche vor Prozessbeginn und dann war im Prinzip
von also jeden Tag von morgens bis abends war ja kreuzverhöhren mehr oder weniger.
So oder ja.
Also man hat so Prozess geübt.
Prozess geübt, beziehungsweise Kreuzverhör besteht halt einmal, da wird man vom eigenen Anwalt befragt und dann vom fremden Anwalt. Und was man dann erstmal vorbereitet, ist natürlich die Befragung durch den eigenen Anwalt.
Ähm.
Die richtigen Fragen stellen, um an.
Also das ist, das ist im Prinzip da mehr oder weniger inszeniert, das heißt, da ging's dann beim Üben darum, welche Fragen
werden und wie ich darauf zu antworten habe, damit halt bestimmte Dinge jetzt
transportiert werden oder bestimmte Fakten schon mal transportiert und untermauert werden und schon mal auch eine sagen, die gestellt werden, bevor die Gegner geschaden wald, die stellt, das heißt, man versucht dann auch, sagen
eine Seite dem gegnerischen Anwalt schon mal so ein bisschen das.
Auch das äh Material zu nehmen oder den Wind aus den Segeln zu nehmen, indem man kritische Fragen auch von der eigenen Seite gestellt kriegt. Plus dann äh tatsächlich auch ein bisschen, dass man dann in die Zange.
Genommen wird und dann auch, ja, so Dinge schon dann auch wie Körpersprache und wie man sich verhält, äh so, wenn man als Trainer kommt und wie man dann auch gegenüber dem Anwalt dann
äh den den befragenden gegnerischen Anwalt so ein bisschen aus dem Tritt äh bringen,
und wie man sich so aus einer Situation rettet, wo man dann jetzt wie rein manövriert äh worden ist. Also sie versuchen einen natürlich
irgendwohin zu manövrieren, dass man dann entweder an anfängt irgendwie zu stammeln oder Unsicherheiten äh zeigt oder das Gefühl äh dass die Jury das Gefühl hat, erzählt jetzt nicht die Wahrheit und.
Ähm ja und das das war schon ganz schön anstrengend. Das ging halt, ich glaube
und ging halt teilweise während des Prozesses noch weiter, aber hauptsächlich war's dann halt die zehn Tage, also vor dem Vorprozessbeginn und das war ging er schon ganz schön offen zum Zahnfleisch, zumal so ein fensterloses
äh Hotel, beziehungsweise äh waren die da in dem,
Also in Wilmington, wenn ich noch ein paar Worte dazu äh in sind halt die meisten,
Aktiengesellschaften der Welt registriert. Ich weiß nicht, wie viele Millionen, also über, ich glaube, über die Hälfte auch oder so der amerikanischen Firmen sind in dieser Stadt äh in diesem äh,
beheimatet.
Das liegt daran, dass schon seit 1900 oder so oder länger einen Gesetz hatte,
dass Lizenzeinnahmen, also Einnahmen auf immaterielle Güter, Steuerfrei,
sind dort in dem Staat. Das heißt also immer wenn du mit irgendwie Lizenzen oder so was zu tun hast und deswegen haben die Konzerne das so gemacht, das heißt die haben dort ihren Hauptsitz,
dort wird das Geld äh vereinnahmt, aber hm.
Sagen, äh beziehungsweise verschieben sie dann zwischen verschiedenen Firmenteilen die Lizenzeinnahmen so, dass sozusagen eine Firma stellt halt,
anderen Firmenteillizenzkosten in in Rechnung und dann kalkulieren die das aber so, dass der Teil der,
Jetzt außerhalb von Wilmington ist äh keine Gewinne aus äh Lizenzen hat, sondern nur der Teil, also die Lizenzgewinne fallen dann in an, wo sie keine Steuern gezahlt werden müssen. Äh und äh ja, die die.
Ist ein Steuersparmodell und es war halt auch interessant, weil ich bin ja extra zu dem Haus gegangen, so ein Haus, wo glaube,
Adresse, die sich die meisten Firmen auf der Welt
teilen, ich weiß nicht, wie viel ich ja über 100.000 Briefkastenfirmen äh in sagen, einer, das wollte ich mir doch mal angucken, wie das aussieht. Das waren unscheinbare Bungalow im Prinzip mit
er wo
Damals auch ein auch ein Foto gemacht. So deswegen und deswegen sind dort die Hotels haben halt auch unten komplette Räume für Anwaltskanzleien
die halt aussehen wie so eine Anwaltskanzlei mit mehreren Räumen, sind aber komplett leer. Und da sind dann auch unsere Anwälte angerückt mit zwei LKW mit Aktenordnern
Druckern, also sie haben haben da halt dann komplett dort, glaube ich, mit 20 Leuten angereist und zwei Lastern und haben dort dann kurzerhand mal in einem Tag oder oder für die Zeit des Prozesses und der Vorbereitung dort
eine mittelgroße Anwaltskanzlei in dem Hotel aufgebaut und die Hotels sind halt alle dafür ausgelegt.
Und äh ja und es war halt schon, war halt einfach schon krass. Ähm
wie weit die ins Detail gegangen sind, also die die Gutachter, also jetzt auch, was den Schadensgutachten angeht. Sie hatten danach sechs verschiedenen Modellen äh äh den den Schaden
berechnet so den Schadenersatzanspruch, also nicht nur auf einen und auch,
Was, glaube ich, ein bisschen schiefgelaufen ist, ist die Juryauswahl. Weil bei Jurys immer noch funktioniert es so.
Du hast halt in der Jury wenn's um Fachthemen geht, gibt es dann meistens einen Meinungs,
der sich so äh rauskristallisiert. Also
sich, wenn einer irgendwie Buchhalter ist und es gibt irgendwie Zahlen, dann hören alle, hört die ganze Jury auf dem Buchhalter und wenn einer Informatiker ist, dann äh ja oder wenn einer Mediziner ist
So ähm,
Ja und äh sie hatten halt äh leider den Informatikstudenten nicht ausgewählt, sondern halt äh lieber dann die Krankenschwester, weil man wählt eben normalerweise
Leute, die im Gesundheitswesen arbeiten möchte, man als.
Kläger nicht in der Jury haben, weil die halt alle so abgegessen sind von den ganzen Kunstfehlerverfahren und deswegen
als Jury äh äh man die lieber als als sagen verteidigende Seite möchte man lieber Leute aus dem Gesundheitswesen haben, äh während man ja,
Und in dem Fall, äh wie gesagt, glaube ich, war's äh der Informatikstudent, der möglicherweise äh ja dann äh den entscheidenden Ausschlag gegeben hat, weil der Rest hat man das Gefühl, sei es überwiegend nicht so aus, als wenn die,
Geschichte folgen konnten, wirklich.
Und ihr hättet den theoretisch rausfehlen können. Ja. Aber habt es nicht gemacht und jetzt denkst du, dass der dann quasi Googles.
Also ich
ich hatte das, ich hatte das vor, ja, ja, ich hatte also als ich das gehört habe, ich war da selber jetzt nicht nicht dabei oder beteiligt. Ich hörte da nur am Abend, wie das gelaufen ist. So und äh als ich dann hörte, dass dachte ich mir, oh, oh, das
ist ich fand das kein gutes Vorzeichen so, weil äh ja.
Schade eigentlich.
Ja, also ich fand's erstmal äh einfach ähm total.
Krass äh und interessant, das einfach erleben zu können. Ich meine, es ist es ist im Grunde genommen unbezahlbar.
Ja, okay, so.
So, ja, so das kannste.
Podcast drüber machen.
Ja und ein Podcast drüber machen und ich meine gut, dass das dann hinterher auch noch verfilmt äh werden äh würde und äh irgendwie da genauso,
genauso viel Geld äh in den, in den Prozess äh äh wie in den Prozess, dann in die Verfilmung äh äh dessen irgendwie Größenordnungsmäßig geflossen ist und das dann in dreißig Sprachen
übersetzt äh äh würde und äh sagen daraus eine Geschichte mit, ich weiß nicht, zwei Tatortkommissaren und ähm,
überhaupt ja also.
Hast du davon erfahren? Und wie hast du davon erfahren? Also wie lief das die bei euch.
Ne, ja, ja, Joachim ist auf mich zugekommen und der hatte halt den Oliver, der hat halt auch äh mir auf äh hier ist das Ding,
Es ist Marienwerder, wie so eine Insel jedenfalls vor seiner Dacia hat und äh da haben die sich getroffen beim Grillen und dann Joachim irgendwie dem dem Oliver Ziegenbalk das erzählt, was er gerade macht und.
Also Oliver Ziegenberg ist einer der ist der Regisseur.
Der, der ist ja Regisseur und äh auch äh ja und der fand.
Geschichte halt so irre und interessant, dass sie halt mehr davon wissen wollte. Und dann ist Joachim.
Also da ging's erstmal gar nicht um einen Film, sondern der hat einfach nur die Story erfahren.
Ja äh ja und er überlegte dann schon, ob man das nicht irgendwie,
ähm da ein Film raus machen könnte, aber es war erstmal nicht also Netflix-Serie war erstmal gar nicht angedacht.
Gute Geschichte, die man irgendwie auf die Leinwand vielleicht auf die Leinwand bringen könnte und dann,
erstmal Joachim mich äh gefragt, ob ich mich auch nicht mit ihm unterhalten konnte, da habe ich so ein bisschen äh ihm davon erzählt und so nahm das dann den den Ausgangspunkt, dann kriegte er noch ein bisschen Drehbuch äh äh Förderung, sodass er dann,
nochmal richtig also mehr Zeit äh investieren konnte und dann gab's halt.
Interviews mit vielen Leuten. Er ist die Prozessakten durchgearbeitet und und und.
Ist das her? Also wann war das erste.
Drei Jahre oder so, also es war muss dann irgendwie also der Kontakt ist, glaube ich, fast noch während der Prozess gerade lief.
Prozess war dann zwanzig siebzehn, achtzehn.
Sechzehn, es ist sechzehn, 7zehn. Das soll's gewesen sein.
Ich weiß es nicht. Ja. Ja, ich weiß auch nicht.
Ja. Ja, ich weiß auch nicht, äh so. Also Jahreszahlen.
Okay, vor ein paar Jahren, okay. Und danach äh kam dieser Kontakt zustande. Da war das sozusagen auch noch relativ frisch alles. Mhm.
Ja ja, aber dann passiert ja erst mal nicht viel und ich habe da ehrlich gesagt auch nicht wirklich dran geglaubt, dass man da irgendwie einen Film rausmachen könnte. Und wenn, da einen Film rausfern würde, würde das bestimmt superpeinlich.
Weil er in so eine komplizierte Geschichte und du weißt wie das oft ist, wenn da irgendwelche Computer äh zu sehen sind äh und dann,
irgendwie ist es halt oft an Peinlichkeit nicht zu übertreffen und deswegen dachte ich dann, naja gut, macht da irgendwie eine Geschichte raus, also solange irgendwie meinen Namen da rauslasst, äh so,
die Geschichte ist interessant, aber bitte so ich ich möchte jetzt nicht irgendwie ich möchte nicht Charakter in einer irgendwie,
deutschen Fernsehproduktion sein mit mit meinem Namen und ja
Ach so, ich habe dann darüber getwittert übrigens, als ich die mein Twitter-Feed reingucken, als es darum ging, weil die gefragt haben, so, ob ich denn bereit wäre, also ob sie denn meinen Namen,
verwenden können oder nicht und dann ähm eigentlich alle einhellig gesagt, irgendwie nee, das das halten wir jetzt für keine gute Idee. Aber eigentlich war's dann auch die bessere Idee, weil äh,
sonst, abgesehen von der Peinlichkeit, äh,
ist die, ist die Realität, also das das also Fernsehen oder oder Film ist halt ein Format, das hat halt gewisse formale Anforderungen auch, wie Geschichten zu strukturieren und
und äh ja sie waren dann auch, ich glaube, vom Anfang an sowieso immerhin dreiundzwanzig war's halt, war's halt auch ähnlich, da gab's ja eigentlich.
Ja äh da wurden auch viele Leute oder Charaktere zusammen äh äh gelegt und,
das war in dem Fall, glaube ich, auch eine ganz, ganz gute Idee, äh dass das so zu tun, weil man dann.
Ja, das Thema, glaube ich, besser transportieren konnte und dann interessanterer Film äh äh raus raus wird.
Genau, das heißt aus dem Team von vier Leuten sind im Film 2 Leute geworden. Ja. Die eine Person vermengt mehr so die gestalterische Seite, mehr den Artteil und äh die andere, die ihn kommen, teil.
Und der Businessteil ist komplett rausgelassen, der auch eine wichtige Rolle,
also jetzt, was weiß ich, äh irgendwie Andreas Wiek oder Detlef Andreowitz, die so dann auch wichtigen treibenden Teil dann irgendwann nach 2tausend ähäh waren, das.
Also die in der Geschäftsführung.
In der Geschäftsführung äh dann äh das voran äh getrieben haben, äh die wurden halt ganz äh rausgelassen, die stecken dann quasi auch mit in der Person von dem Karsten äh äh drin,
von dem Gestalter und auch.
Man muss auch sagen, also äh,
Jetzt wird sowieso nur noch gespoilert, ja? Also bis dahin war die Story ja sozusagen das, was wirklich passiert ist. Ähm,
Ich fasse mal ganz kurz zusammen, weil es jetzt auch nicht an uns hier ein Movie Review äh äh zu machen. Ich dachte nur, es wäre vielleicht mal ganz sinnvoll, auf ein paar Unterschiede einzugehen, ne
Die Story, die dann letzten Endes erzählt wird, ist zwei junge Leute, einer halt so mit dem UDK Hintergrund, äh einer mit dem
Chaos, Computerclub, Hintergrund. Ja, das musste natürlich sein. Äh ja und tatsächlich
was dazu sagen, wo das herkommt. So kommen halt irgendwie äh zusammen, finden sich irgendwie über das Thema, äh entwickeln dann diese Idee, ja ja toll Terrorvision zu bauen, dann kommt überhaupt erstmalig die Telekom ins Spiel. Das war ja jetzt, wie wir
gehört haben, einfach äh ganz anders. Diese Firma gab's ja schon vorher, hier wurde sie dafür quasi gegründet so in so einem Start-up-Moment. Ja und dann ähm,
entwickelt sich das halt alles, die Software läuft, viele Dinge sind extrem detailgetreu, nacherzählt worden, die Sache da in äh auch viele Details auf dem Weg
äh dahin, die Computerdarstellung, finde ich, ist sehr gelungen. Ähm ich hatte eigentlich keinen einzigen Fremdschämenmoment.
Dich, das ist schon eine hohe Auszeichnung für den Film, muss ich sagen. Also es ist einfach mal so ein Film, wo wo das alles sehr realistisch und trotzdem.
Ergreifend geschildert wurde, was sicherlich auch ein bisschen an dem Projekt lag, weil es halt einfach nur mal so war. Ja und am Ende äh nimmt es eben auch.
Sehr viel von diesem, von dieser Gerichtsverhandlung äh auf, zeigt diesen Prozess, auch diese Vorbereitung, was du erzählt hast, ähm bis zum Ende und äh schafft es, dass ähm,
Kurzweilig und farbenfroh darzustellen. So würde ich das jetzt mal so grob äh umschreiben.
Auch mit einer schönen Reministin an die Neunziger äh so das
in der Neunziger und so, das kommt ganz gut rüber und ich glaube auch so ein bisschen so die so eine gewisse deutsche Technik bräsigkeit von damals irgendwie das äh die.
Gibt's mehrere Spitzen der.
Also insofern hat das, ich meine, Ersatz hat halt für verschiedene Leute auch, was ich so habe, also,
Ja, es ist, es ist schon auch ein bisschen in Augenöffner, äh, glaube ich, für für verschiedene Dinge, so für einmal, ja,
konnten Konzerne, denn amerikanische Großverfahren, aber auch
Telekom Kunsthochschul. Also es ist irgendwie schon 'ne ganz interessante Mischung, dass Berlin der der Neunziger und all das ist so 'ne so 'ne schon 'ne Gemengelage die der Film,
ganz gut aufgreift. Natürlich,
an verschiedenen Stellen vereinfacht, aber ich glaube jetzt auch nicht wirklich verdummt äh so muss man äh äh sagen, sondern so ich ich glaube,
man ist ein bisschen,
klüger, auch wenn man den den Film äh gesehen hat, äh so, was was so bestimmte Abläufe angeht, was so.
Gewicht äh passiert und so, was vor so einem amerikanischen Gericht passiert und auch, ich glaube, so technische Details äh und so äh kann man auch ein bisschen.
Der eine oder andere lernen oder heraus äh gucken, so wie dann im Grunde genommen Google Earth oder Terrorvision funktionieren. Da gibt's dann auch durchaus gewisse Anklänge, äh wo man dann auch, glaube ich, so ein bisschen sowohl ja,
Technisch als auch juristisch äh hinterher, glaube ich, so ein bisschen äh ähm ja auch klüger ist, aber es ist vor allem es ist halt Unterhaltung.
Genau und.
Was man auf jeden Fall an dieser Stelle insbesondere an diesem äh Podcast, der so viel CCC Hintergrund hat, äh dann auch nochmal klarstellen muss.
CCC hatte das eigentlich nichts zu tun im eigentlichen Sinne. Also das Projekt selber hat keine,
ist nicht irgendwie aus dem Chaos, Computerclub herausgeboren worden und auch das Team, was es letztlich realisiert hat, hat sich auch nicht aus dem CCC heraus, wie ist der Film darstellt, so rekrutiert.
Sondern es war aber.
So, es war eher so, dass halt kommen von Anfang an vom Chaos, Computerclub unterwandert. Äh war, wenn man das äh so.
Wieso von Anfang an doch nicht?
Ja doch, weißt du, Hans war der Erste, der der äh irgendwie diesen Zettel gefunden hat, äh den die Künstler da am am Brett von der TU äh äh,
Ähm aufgehängt hatten, das war Hans, der sozusagen.
Jetzt den Film.
Nein, nein, das ist sozusagen in Realität. Jetzt sagen die Art kommen, also wie überhaupt,
also wie überhaupt Entwickler äh jetzt, also wir alle zu Art kommen gekommen sind, war, weil Hans Anne TU äh diese Ausschreibung, wir suchen halt Leute gefunden hat irgendwie achten,
80 oder so.
Und dadurch halt alle möglichen Leute angeschleppt hat und in den Neunzigern war's ja dann auch so, dass er irgendwann in den Neunzigern dann schon der halbe Berliner zumindest.
Nicht der halbe, fast der ganze. Fast der ganze. Also mir würde jetzt eigentlich so aus dem Stand nur eine Person äh einfallen.
Also Andy war nicht dabei.
Ja und alle anderen waren eigentlich dabei.
Ja, okay, also ja, vielleicht 90 Prozent des und und ähm im Grunde.
Des Berliner CCC, der damals noch recht neu war.
Äh und der des aktiven, also rede jetzt von den, genau, äh so. Also das war irgendwie quasi auch also Artcom äh also er kommt Teil von Artcom und
Wenn irgendwann, also war jetzt nicht nur zäh und es war dann, ich sage mal, Leute waren dann auch irgendwann in der Minderheit, weil bei Art kommt schon das deutlich mehr Leute irgendwann bis zu achtzig Leute
dann bei Artcom gearbeitet. Insofern war's jetzt nicht, aber ja, eine Zeit lang war schon irgendwie äh ja Frank und Steini und äh,
Tobias, äh ja, also.
Ganze Rotte halt einfach. Also kulturell war das auf jeden Fall sehr nah so und äh gar keine Frage. Nur konkret für Terrorvision in der Story, wie es dort so erzählt wird, ist es halt nochmal,
anders gelaufen. Trotzdem, die Gemengelage, die Zeit dieses äh Hackergefühl, äh diese unglaublich intensive Auseinandersetzung mit Technologie, Techno,
ja Partys und so weiter. Also das war alles da drin. Im Film ist auch glaub ich nochmal einiges rausgeflogen, ne?
Ja ja, also es wurde in Wirklichkeit wurde viel mehr gekifft damals. Äh das hatten die halt auch in dem äh aber äh das war wohl irgendwie Netflix, wollte nicht so viel Kifferei äh drin haben in dem in dem in dem Film äh einfach und deswegen ist da.
Trotzdem ist da ein ganz unterhaltsames äh Filmchen bei raus äh gekommen und sollte nur, wenn man ihn sich jetzt halt anschaut, insbesondere, was jetzt das.
Protagonisten sich untereinander verhalten, da ist die große Erfindung drin, das ist sozusagen die die das eigentliche kleine Märchen äh dadrin, das ist äh
äh dadurch allein schon, dass es eben sehr viele mehr Leute waren, die da in äh zwei und ein paar Randcharakteren zusammengefasst sind, äh kuliniert das natürlich, dass an der Stelle äh anders als es jetzt wirklich war,
Aber das Drumherum, das Past, die Computer, die Geschichte an sich, der Prozess, das ist alles sehr wahr.
Ja und es finden sich auch auch, ich sage mal, Elemente und Versatzstücke, von Dingen, die wirklich passiert sind,
an anderer Stelle im Grunde genommen äh äh wieder. Also es gab zwar jetzt diese große, ich sage mal diese.
Ich sag mal Freundschafts.
Geschichte, die dort, also diese Zweiergeschichte gab's jetzt nicht in der Form, aber sie gab es halt in einer anderen äh äh,
später in einem anderen Kontext äh äh so. Also, wer jetzt Hendrik und ich beispielsweise,
uns dann sozusagen nach der Tango acht Jahre oder so nicht miteinander geredet haben, weil wir uns äh also was halt auch äh irgendwie ja äh,
Und äh so äh gibt's halt äh viele, viele Dinge, die halt ja äh gibt's so die eine Szene, äh wo,
wie dann,
Charaktere, ich weiß gar nicht, ob's Juri ist, ja, ich glaube, genau sagt, ja, wenn wenn ich schlafen gehe, geht mein Computer auch schlafen.
Da war, sagen die, also die wahre, wahre Geschichte war.
Der gesagt hat, wenn mein wenn ich schlafen gehe, geht man auch schlafen,
war zu einer Zeit, wo er dann meinte, irgendwie fummelt bloß nicht irgendjemand an meinem Code rum, sondern das ist jetzt irgendwie das,
So, so hast du dir das. Und dann die Geschichte mit dem Hyperventilationssyndrom noch.
Ähm gut, das ist dann im Making-off. Erzählt Axel die Geschichte auch. Ähm so ich bin tatsächlich äh so da vom Stuhl gefallen, weil ich hyperventiliert habe. Paar Tage vor Kyoto.
Und äh das ist mir aber nur, dass wir da zum ersten Mal passiert und seitdem auch nicht nicht wieder. Und ich musste auch nicht im Krankenhaus,
und hat da jetzt auch nicht den.
Moment, sondern wenn der Arzt hat mich halt fünf Minuten in eine Tüte äh atmen lassen, dass es alles gut gehen, so meine Kneipe trinken sie ein Bier, entspannen sie sich.
War alles gut so und das war das erste Mal, wo ich dann im Krankenhaus quasi als,
als Therapie, irgendwie gehen sie mal in die Kneipe und trinken sie ein Bier äh gekriegt. Äh habe und ich war dann tatsächlich irgendwie zwei Stunden später war ich dann wieder am Terminal und habe weitergemacht.
Jetzt wo du es gerade sagst, das ist wirklich super in dem Backing Off. Wie achsen, das war so ich war so im Film, ich habe das gar nicht gemerkt.
Genau. Du Henne, ich glaube, der Pavel ist gerade vom äh umgefallen. Kannst du dich mal kümmern? Genau. Ja. So war, war's dann. Äh äh tatsächlich auch. Das war echt, echt weird,
Ähm also letztlich ist das halt durch schnelles Atmen stärkt glaube ich der CO2-Gehalt im Blut oder so zu schnell.
Übersäuertes und dann kriegt man halt tatsächlich irgendwie, also ja, war war voll krass äh so so hatte ich hatte ich noch nie ja,
Aber ja, ich habe wieder eine Angststörung äh äh wie der äh äh Juri im Film. Ach ja und ich bin jetzt auch nicht aus Budapest, äh sondern ich bin in Prag geboren und ich bin dann auch.
Als Gärtner dann wieder nach Prag äh zurückgezogen, nachdem das irgendwie.
Äh nicht weg bin, sondern ich, ja, hatten wir ja vorhin vorhin die Geschichte. Ich habe da noch viele andere Dinge äh äh gemacht, die glaube ich.
Wäre für mich teilweise mindestens genauso spektakulär waren wie jetzt diese Google Geschichte. Also ich meine die Piratennummer äh einfach, das war dann auch nochmal äh.
Später nochmal genau, wie war das? Vielleicht also wer weiß, ich habe gerade irgendwie gehört.
Mit Budapest ist es interessant, das heißt so vorhin äh mir im Gespräch äh gesagt, es gibt einen Grund, warum äh deine Person nach Budapest verlagert wurde. Man hätt's ja auch genauso mit Prag erzählen können, aber der ganze Film ist dort gedreht worden.
Also der Großteil des Films ist tatsächlich in Budapest gedreht worden, aus verschiedenen Gründen. Ein Grund äh war, dass das Berlin der Neunziger in Berlin kaum noch zu finden ist oder gar nicht mehr zu finden ist.
Und äh dass man dann halt, um sozusagen das 90er-jahre Berlin der neunziger Jahre Flair äh man halt einfacher in Budapest äh gefunden hat, indem man dann dort,
ja eher hingegangen ist und dann Straßen, so die haben die sind dann hingegangen, haben dann Laternenstraßenlaternen ausgetauscht und und Schilder ausgetauscht und andere Autos hingestellt und äh äh weiß ich nicht, vielleicht ein bisschen,
Graffiti äh äh verändert.
Echt gut gelungen, weil ich mir nämlich beim Gucken mir schon die ganze Zeit dachte so fuck irgendwie das wo wo haben sie denn das jetzt bitte gedreht? Es sieht schon irgendwie nach Berlin aus, aber ich erkenn's gerade.
Und einiges haben sie auch, ich weiß nicht wie selbst einiges sah halt, also zum Beispiel der Fahrstuhl da bei Artcom.
Mhm, der sah genauso aus.
Sah halt, sah genauso aus wie damals. Ich glaube, weiß nicht, ob's den noch gibt, aber äh ja, also den haben sie irgendwie voll äh äh gut nachempfunden. Ähm.
Die ganzen Arbeitsräume waren. Ja. Genau perfekt.
Die Arbeitsräume, das haben sie auch so nach nach Fotos äh.
Leider gab's ja auch 3 D Modelle von also.
Genau, stimmt, da gab's auch noch drei D Modelle äh äh von, na ja und der Blick aus dem, aus dem Fenster da, äh Kyoto, haben sie super
nachgebaut, muss man auch sagen, aber ja, also Budapest war zum einen äh so, weil es von der Szenerie her passte, aber natürlich auch
teilweise weil es günstiger ist dort zu drehen also einfach einfach billiger ist so auch Komparsen und so was,
und äh ja und dann.
Auch 'ne Fördergeschichte, es gab halt glaub ich auch schon,
äh Ungarn, also äh sagen dadurch, dass dies dann auch in Ungarn gemacht haben, wobei ist das äh wahrscheinlich fast in allen Ländern äh äh gibt, wenn du da hingehst, aber das kam dann halt auch noch,
On top und das Problem war für die.
Dass es halt während Covid äh äh alles gedreht wurde. Ich habe von dem nicht viel mitgekriegt, dachte mir nur, oh mein Gott, jetzt,
Haben sie auch noch, jetzt haben sie grade angefangen zu drehen und jetzt kommt irgendwie,
Corona äh rein. Das war natürlich für die heute diese Produktion so international. Die Schauspieler kommen von überall aus der Welt. Aber die Schauspieler konnten halt jetzt plötzlich nicht mehr reisen.
So, das heißt, sie wussten halt, OK, das kommt, dann haben sie halt sämtliche Schauspieler für einen Monat nach Budapest
die die nur ein oder zwei Drehtage hatten, die dann die ganze Zeit im Hotel gesessen haben, bis sie dran waren, weil sie sonst einfach nicht die Szenen hätten
äh drehen können. Und das war wohl, ja, das unnatürlich entsprechend, ja, musste dann die Leute halt.
Dann für einen Monat anheuern, statt für drei Drehtage und so, also das das deswegen, das war, glaube ich, nicht ganz einfach und.
Und da haben sie halt nur sagen, äh doch mussten ja eine Menge improvisieren, zum Beispiel sie die ganze Wüste ist ist halt auch auf dem Parkplatz äh äh aufgenommen, wo sie den Sand drauf geschüttet haben, wo dann wohl im Hintergrund.
Dieses Ding.
Burning Man äh Ding, genau. Das ist äh ja ist ähm das auf dem Parkplatz von dem Studio.
Aufgenommen mit Sand hingekarrt und da stand wohl noch von irgendeiner anderen Fernsehserie die ganze Zeit irgend so ein so ein Hexenschloss oder so. Hinten äh rum, was sie dann aber raus retuschiert haben, aber da merkt man nichts von. Also ich finde äh ja.
Das ist echt perfekt an der Stelle.
Also muss man sagen, das ist ist schon ja aus meiner Sicht sehr, sehr ordentlich.
Geworden und äh ja, ich hatte, ich hatte riesige Panik, das ist wirklich riesige Panik, aber ich ich befürchte, dass das irgendwie äh ja auch.
Klar, kann ich mir gut vorstellen. Sie ist ja auch oft genug äh schiefgegangen,
Aber äh unterm Strich kann man sagen, wieder ein interessantes äh Zeitdokument, was so im Kino läuft, was so diese Zeit und diese ganze Hackergeschichte in gewisser Hinsicht ja auch mit porträtiert. Ich finde dieses,
kam gut rüber und ich fand's auch natürlich sehr schön, dass auch so viel von dieser Hackerethik äh äh quasi dort äh untergebracht wurde, was sicherlich schon,
ähm eine Rolle gespielt habe, weil ihr habt ja auch.
Making-of dann auch nochmal klar Position bezogen, dass klar diese Klage zu verlieren, das war jetzt,
Vielleicht blöd so.
Geschichte wäre noch ein bisschen runder gewesen, wenn man's noch gewonnen hätte. Aber ansonsten bereut ja auch nichts, so wie es gelaufen ist.
Ich hatte nö, ist es halt, wie gesagt, was was halt schade ist.
Immer noch so Scheiße.
Google Earth immer noch so scheiße ist so, das hätten wir sicherlich ändern äh äh können, ja. Äh so äh also im Grunde genommen ja äh mein das.
Dachte ich, äh so damals als Google das von Michael gekauft hat, dachte ich irgendwie, wow, wow, jetzt mit der Power von Google, da kann ja, das kann ja jetzt äh richtig, richtig was werden,
was ich nicht geahnt hatte war, dass das im Grunde genommen der Todesstoß äh äh war, dass Google diese Firma äh gekauft
hat ja, wenn auch nicht, also jedenfalls der Todesstoß für die Vision, äh wo es hätte hingehen können, sondern jetzt haben sie halt, ja, einen ist ja,
seit zehn Jahren ist da nichts passiert wirklich, ja? Außer technisch hier und da an ein paar Enden und ein bisschen mehr Daten, aber ansonsten ist das ist das eigentlich ja, leider
so uralte Software, das ist halt ärgerlich, dann ist ärgerlich, wobei,
ein bisschen Schadenfreude äh tatsächlich auch nicht verhehlen kann, ist, dass äh Google äh wahrscheinlich weniger Geld,
In die Hand hätte nehmen müssen, äh wenn sie das Patent lizensiert hätten, als sie dann hinterher in die Hand nehmen mussten, um äh die Klage äh.
Zu wehren und na ja, was gut, was nicht planbar war, was kein Mensch.
Oder erwarten konnte, ist jetzt dieser Film.
Anschließend irgendwie das halt irgendwie vierhundert Millionen Leuten in äh dreißig Sprachen dann irgendwie eine Geschichte äh auch äh untergejubelt wird, wo ja ich meine.
Google auf einmal wieder total evi.
Ja Google ist also Google kommt halt jetzt nicht super äh drin weg. Die Frage, ist es jetzt äh ich sage mal.
Ja, ich ich finde, es ist eigentlich durchaus fair, ja. Immer,
Michael, beziehungsweise Vorbild für Brian Anderson äh war ein ganz anderer äh äh Typ, das war ja auch noch wichtig. Sagt, ich hatte nie wirklich einen großen Konflikt.
Mit ihm. Wir haben uns auch nach dem Prozess äh nochmal unterhalten. Er hat mir erzählt, was er so macht. Er hat dann halt, der hat zu der Zeitpunkt Pokemon Go, Niantik äh äh gemacht.
Äh der Prozess lief und äh ja und es ging uns beiden eigentlich hatte gerade mein äh Machine Learning Startup äh äh.
Begonnen und äh ja, war halt, war jetzt nicht so, dass einer von uns jetzt irgendwie das Gefühl gehabt hätte, es geht uns jetzt scheiße, weswegen oder wir fanden's halt nur ärgerlich und.
Hat Google dann am Ende auch mehr oder weniger gefickt. Ähm.
Ähm weil äh sie äh da hat er sich dann irgendwann geäußert im Interview auch äh so, weil sie halt dann die CIA,
äh gedropt haben als Kunden,
weil sie aufgehört haben, obwohl er das denen versprochen hat, obwohl das nur sagen, er das zur Bedingung gemacht hat für diesen, wenn sie die das äh sagen, Google,
weiter jetzt diese Regierungsjobs macht, weil das die Leute waren
die letztlich ihm geholfen haben, soweit äh zu kommen und äh ja, man kann jetzt unterschiedlicher Wahlgang sagen, okay super geil, gut gemacht, Google irgendwie Rüstungsaufträge äh und,
und so,
Aber äh ja, erstens die Amerikaner sehen das nicht nicht so, die sind halt jetzt nicht so die Pazifisten, wie wir in Deutschland, die haben halt auch nicht äh so diese.
Äh Berührungsprobleme und und so und wie gesagt und am Ende fühlte er sich sozusagen auch menschlich äh irgendwie äh betrogen auch von von Google,
so wie das wie das gelaufen ist plus ja.
Dass es halt jetzt stagniert und äh es es fehlt halt einfach komplett die Vision, wenn man auch überlegt, ich meine, wie viel von den Sachen, die.
Google jetzt anbietet oder er äh hat Google, also haben ihren Ausgangspunkt bei Google äh genommen. Ja, eigentlich.
Außer,
Suchmaschine außer der Suche ist alles andere was wir an Cooks ist zugekauft ja. Gmail haben sie zugekauft, YouTube haben sie zugekauft,
Ja äh also egal wo du hingehst, ich habe äh ich meine.
Was sie selber versucht haben zu entwickeln ist auch nichts geworden.
Berghut? Nicht Berghut, ja. Genau.
Ja nicht nur das, also ich meine, sie haben da, ich meine, wenn man sich die Liste an Projekten anschaut, die die Google nicht mehr verfolgt, die sie alle eingestellt haben und sind halt relativ wenig Gewinner wirklich dabei, so. Google ist halt eigentlich nach wie vor
die Suchmaschine Maps kann man sagen, ist äh Google Maps.
Haben sie auch zugekauft von einem Norweger, glaube ich, äh ursprünglich, ja.
Na gut, aber ich würde sagen, das haben sie schon nennenswert geprägt und auch wirklich zu einem echten Erfolg äh gemacht.
Aber ist auch nicht, hat seinen Ausgangspunkt, also war auch nicht irgendjemand bei Google, der gesagt hätte, äh irgendwie in sein lass mal Maps machen. Nee, nee, sondern da haben sie auch äh sagen, sich sich zugekauft, äh so weiß ich auch.
Und auch Mitarbeiter von Art Plus com äh dazugeholt.
Genau, aber äh ja, also das ist das ist halt so ein bisschen und ich ich habe auch ein bisschen,
Ja in den 2tausenderjahren bisschen bei Google abgehangen, weil wir da andere äh auch noch andere Freunde und uns so, die da, die da gearbeitet hatten. Ich wurde also.
Sie haben mich äh auch gefragt, ob ich nicht irgendwie zu Google kommen möchte, beziehungsweise war dann eher so ja äh.
Weil dann wir denken nicht, dass wir dir irgendwie einen
attraktives Angebot machen äh können, dass du zu uns kommst. Deswegen äh äh fragen wir dich jetzt gar nicht, wobei das schon so äh lohnt es sich, dich vielleicht zu fragen, ob wir dich äh
ja? So, aber ich wollte da einfach äh nicht, nicht hin. Das war mir dann einfach, ich wollte auch also Großkonzernen äh
war halt so ein so ein Ding. Das habe ich seit ich irgendwie als 16-jähriger mal einmal damals bei bei Nixdorf äh durch die Hallen äh gegangen bin, war für mich klar, irgendwie in die Großkonzernen
äh weil da bist du halt,
Dingen ausgesetzt, über die du keine Kontrolle hast die ganze Zeit in einem Konzern. Da passieren Dinge und wenn du ganz oben bist,
dann hast du keine Ahnung, was in der Firma passiert. Das sind so, also deswegen Konzern ist halt einfach, nee für also für mich
Ich bin da, ich bin da so, so gar nicht der Typ. Äh ich habe mir immer am liebsten meine Arbeitsplätze selber geschaffen und äh weil dann ist man zwar klar von Auftraggebern und Kunden abhängig, aber den Kunden kann man halt dann immer noch sagen, irgendwie nee.
Ja, während äh wenn du halt Angestellter bist und du kriegst gesagt, mach jetzt das. Äh klar, kannst dann sagen, ach nee, aber dann,
Das ist halt dann nochmal eine eine andere Kiste oder sagen wir gesagt, wir brauchen dich jetzt nicht mehr. Ja.
Und äh ja und am Ende kommt dann halt eben so eine Scheiße äh dabei raus, auch noch bei den Konzernen, dass dass da äh.
Also alles richtig gemacht, würde ich sagen.
Ja äh weiß ich nicht. Wahrscheinlich.
Hätte ich jetzt auch lieber zwanzig Milliarden oder nee, nicht wirklich lieber, wenn jetzt 20 Milliarden hätte, die wahrscheinlich so was wie Elon Musk äh gemacht, äh hätte ich wahrscheinlich auch mir irgendwie meinen eigenen Raumfahrt äh Konzern, weil das war immer mein mein Ding,
So, das wäre meine Vision äh äh gewesen, äh so ein vernünftiges Raumschiff zu bauen, mit dem man günstig in die Umlaufbahn kommt. Das war so, was ich mir dann.
Als als Ziel gesetzt hätte, aber ansonsten habe ich eher das Gefühl, dass ich eigentlich viel zu viel Kram.
So, dass ich eigentlich viel mehr habe, als ich brauche.
Dass ich sowieso irgendwie ja überversorgt bin mit mit allem und äh ja es fehlt mir eigentlich an nichts äh und.
Ähm nee, von von daher.
Obwohl, ich sage mal, wenn wir jetzt wie gesagt so ein paar Millionen hätte ich jetzt genommen, die hätten mich jetzt nicht weiter äh die hätten mich jetzt nicht, nicht weiter gestört, äh.
Ähm so und hätte bestimmt irgendwas sinnvolles, geiles damit gemacht, denke ich mal.
Vielleicht kommt das ja noch. Wenn man noch ein bisschen Zeit die ein oder andere Idee kann äh noch umgesetzt werden. So, die haben wir ja jetzt aber ausreichend äh erzählt. Ich denke, jetzt machen wir mal Deckel drauf.
Ja. Vielen Dank für die äh ausführliche Darreichung.
Ja
Und äh mal gucken, was äh demnächst so verfilmt wird aus unserem Umfeld.
Was daraus. Genau, was daraus noch so so passiert.
Genau und falls jemand von Google zugehört hat.
Macht mal euer Google alles ordentlich. Falls ihr da Hilfe braucht, ich müsste da jemanden. Aber so geht's nun wirklich nicht.
Ja, es ist es ist.
Bin bei Terrorvision wiederhaben. Vielen Dank und vielen Dank fürs Zuhören hier bei äh CRE. Das war's äh für heute. Ich hoffe, bald geht's wieder weiter. Ich sage tschüss und bis bald.
Tschüss.